GOOD MORNING WILL BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING- TODAY IS THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING. ON
EDUCATION FINANCE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- BUDGET WILL FOCUS ON
OUR A ONE MILLION. PLUS STUDENT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
FOCUSING TODAY ON A ROMANTIC
FUNDING FORMULA DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE STUDENTS SUPPORT-
NEW POSITIONS IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CYBER
SECURITY AN UPDATE ON CAL RIGHT
COLLEGE. LIKE ALL HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS LAST YEAR'S-
BUDGET PROVIDED COMMUNIQU ALL
THOSE SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
INCREASE ONE LARGEST IN HISTORY-
AFTER THE KOBE DEFERRALS IN TWO
YEARS AGO WERE ABLE TO PAY THOSE
BACK AND PROVIDE A 5% COLA. WE
KNOW THAT COLLEGES FACED A COST
INCREASES INCLUDING PENSION
COSTS AND ENSURING THE FACULTY
AND STAFF RECEIVE FAIR WAGES AND
BENEFITS WILL TALK ABOUT THAT
TODAY AS WELL AS A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA- IN HOW WE CAN BEST PLAN
FOR COLLEGES GOING FORWARD. OF
COURSE OUR MAIN CONCERN IN THIS
COMMITTEE OVER THE YEARS ALWAYS
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION INCLUDING
COMMUNICABLE JUST WITHOUT THE
BARRIERS FOR- STUDENT. FEES IS
MINIMAL- COMMUNICABLE **** WITH
THE- THE PROMISED GRANTSAS WELL
AS THREE COMMUNIQU ALL FULL TIME
STUDENTS- BUT IT'S ALWAYS AN
ONGOING ISSUE WITH THE NON
TUITION COSTS- ONE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE FOCUSED ON. IS THE BIG
DROP IN ENROLLMENT OF THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS LAST
THREE YEARS TWO YEARS AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- NOT CERTAIN
IF THIS IS A TEMPORARY- DROPPERS
GOING TO BOUNCE BACK BUT IT DOES
HAVE SOME. OVER OUR OVERALL DONE
CONCERNS FOR CALIFORNIA AND OUR
ECONOMY IN THESE COLLEGES THAT
WE KNOW IT'S A NATIONAL ISSUE AS
WELL- WE'D LIKE TO HEAR ABOUT
STRATEGIES FOR GETTING STUDENTS
BACK- FOCUSING ON. IN PERSON- TO
HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT-
AND LASTLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSION ABOUT CALIBRATE
CALIBRATE COLLEGE- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER. OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I BELIEVE ALL OF THEM TO
HAVE SERIOUS QUESTIONS ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS. ONLINE
COLLEGE- HOW IT OPERATES AND
WHAT WE DO GOING FORWARD SO WITH
THAT LET'S BEGIN WE'LL START
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. THE ROMANS AND
BRING UP THE PERMANENT FINANCE
LA- IN OUR CANCERS OFFICE.
EVERYBODY IS IN PERSON. FINALLY
JOINT. WITH.
OKAY BERMAN TO FINANCE GOOD
MORNING THIS EARNERS TIME WE SEE
EVERYBODY IN PERSON I KNOW AND I
THINK OVER TWO YEARS SO WELCOME
BACK THANK YOU IT'S GREAT TO BE
BACK- WELL GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS- DAN HAD ARE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
START OF LIKE TO QUICKLY TOUCH
ON THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MULTIROTOR AT. THE
RUNOFF BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOCUSES ON
EQUITY AND STUDENT SUCCESS-
BUILDING UPON THE SYSTEM'S
VISION FOR SUCCESS THE ROADMAP
ESTABLISHES SHARED EXPECTATIONS
IN A VICIOUS GOALS. INVESTING
AVAILABLE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT RESOURCES. FOR THE
COLLEGES TO SUPPORT THESE
EFFORTS IN EXPANDING CHANCES
OFFICE CAPACITY. TO BETTER
SUPPORT COLLEGES IN MEETING
THESE GOALS. IN PARTICULAR THE
MULTI YEAR ROADMAP FOCUSES ON
GOALS RELATED TO INTEREST
SEGMENTAL COLLABORATION FOR
TIMELY TRANSFER. REDUCING TIME
TO DEGREE. CLOSING EQUITY GAPS
AND IMPROVING ALIGNMENT WITH K.
TWELVE AND WORKFORCE NEEDS. ARE
NOW TURN TO ENROLLMENT. THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO SEE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT ACROSS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AS A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT THREAT
TO BASE FUNDING FOR DISTRICTS.
TO EIGHT ADDRESSING THIS ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND IS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR ENROLLMENT
OUTREACH TO- AND STUDENT
RETENTION EFFORTS. BUILDING ON
THE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION PROVIDED LAST YEAR.
THESE FUNDS WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR SIMILAR USES AS THE AFTER
MENTIONED FUNDS PROVIDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
. FURTHER TO MEET THE DIVERSE
LEARNING MENTALITY DEMAND TO THE
STATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THE BUDGET INCLUDES AN
EXPECTATION THAT DISTRICTS
PROVIDE AT LEAST 50% IN PERSON
EDUCATION. FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE ACADEMIC YEAR
PROVIDED THAT APPROACH IS
CONSISTENT WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES IN PLACE AT THE TIME.
AND STUDENT DEMAND. THIS
EXPECTATION IS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS TO MEET
THEIR NEEDS AND ENCOURAGE
GREATER ENROLLMENT. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT HIS INVESTMENTS.
THANK YOU L. L. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN CARTY POSTING HAUSEN
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. TO TALK ABOUT. THE TWO
PROPOSALS IN YOUR- AGENDA PAGE
FIVE. ON THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
PROPOSAL THAT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ROMAN
GROWTH. AND THEN THE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME.
THAT MISTER HANOVER MENTION FOR
RECRUITMENT RETENTION STRATEGIES
. SO CONSISTENT WITH NATIONWIDE
TRENDS FOR TWO YEAR COLLEGES
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT
ENROLLMENT DECLINE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC. AND
THE AGENDA REALLY DOES A GOOD
JOB SUMMARIZING THOSE TRENDS.
ARE BASED ON PRELIMINARY DATA
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR SOME
DISTRICTS APPEAR TO BE
RECOVERING FROM LOST IN ROMAN.
BUT FEW IF ANY ARE ANYWHERE BACK
TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS. SO
DESPITE OF WHAT'S WEAKENED ROMAN
DEMAND RIGHT NOW BUT LEGISLATURE
STILL MIGHT WANT TO PROVIDE SOME
LEVEL OF GROWTH FUNDING. IN THE
BUDGET YEAR GIVEN THAT
ENROLLMENT POTENTIALLY COULD
START TO REBOUND NEXT YEAR NOW
EVEN IF THE ENTIRE AMOUNT
DESN'T END UP GETTING USED
EARNED BY DISTRICTS THAT MONEY
CAN STILL BE USED TO FUND
SHORTFALLS FUNDING SHORTFALLS IN
THE FORMULA. OR OTHER PURPOSES
AND SO IT'S REALLY A LOW RISK OF
LEGISLATURE PROVIDING SOME LEVEL
OF ROLLING GROWTH FUNDING FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR AND THAT WAY
THAT MONEY CAN JUST BE USED IF
IT'S NOT EARNED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES. WITH REGARD TO THE
HUNDRED TWENTY HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. ONE TIME THAT
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES FOR
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STRATEGIES- AS MISTER HANOVER
JUST NOTED THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PROVIDES A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME FOR THE SAME PURPOSE. NOW
WHEN THAT MONEY WAS ALLOCATED TO
WAS APPROPRIATED TO THE COLLEGES
THEY WERE NOT REQUIRED TO REPORT
ON HOW MUCH THEY SPENT HOW MUCH
THEY HAVE LEFT OR EVEN WHAT THE
EFFECTIVENESS WERE OF THOSE
FUNDS AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
REALLY DOESN'T HAVE A GOOD IDEA
AT THIS POINT. ABOUT- WHETHER
ANOTHER ROUND OF FUNDING REALLY
IS HAS MERIT TOWARDS A PROMISING
USE OF MONEY. IN ADDITION THERE
ARE NUMBER OF SURVEYS THAT- THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND OTHERS
HAVE DONE- AND RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT THE MAIN REASONS WHY
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT ENROLLING
IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNICORP WHICH
IS IT AT THIS TIME IS THE NEED
TO WORK FULL TIME- GIVEN THIS
FAVORABLE JOB MARKET. AND THE
NEED TO CARE FOR FAMILY SO IF
THAT'S THE CASE IT'S UNCLEAR IF
MONEY FOR RECRUITMENT RETENTION
STRATEGIES MONEY FOR MORE PHONE
BANKS AND ADVERTISING IS GOING
TO HAVE MUCH OF AN IMPACT. BUT
TO THE EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE
THINKS THE COULD BE A GOOD USE
OF MONEY OR HAVE AN IMPACT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD COULD
APPROPRIATE THAT MONEY ANOTHER
OPTION WOULD BETO MAKE THIS
MONEY MORE FLEXIBLE TO TAKE THIS
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME OR ANY AMOUNT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. YOU KNOW WANTS TO
DECIDE ON. AND USE IT AND ALLOW
COLLEGES TO USE IT FOR BROADER
PURPOSES SO ALLOW THEM TO USE IT
FOR RECRUITMENT RESEARCH
STRATEGIES BUT ALSO THEY CAN
MAYBE USE IT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ARE COVERED RELATED
PURPOSES OF GIVING THEM. A
COLLEGE IS MORE OF AN OPTION TO
USE THAT MONEY KIND F LIKE A
BLOCK GRANT SO HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. GOOD MORNING
TURN MCCARTY- AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
LIZ THAT NEVER HAD EXECUTIVE
VICE IN SERVICE TO TIONAL
SUPPORTS AND SUCCESS OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. WE ARE
PROUD THAT TODAY'S- COLLEGE
POPULATION LOOKS AND REPRESENTS.
A LIGHT CALIFORNIA IN FACT 64%
OF ME COLLEGE STUDENTS OUR
STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND 40% OF
THEM ARE TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
OLDER. IN THE LAST FEW YEARS-
THE CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGE IS A
PLACE GREATER FOCUS ON OUTREACH
TO POSTER NATIONAL STUDENTS
THOSE THAT DON'T FIT. THE NORM
BUT THAT HAS- IS OUT BEEN
OUTDATED IN CALLING ON THE
STUDENTS NONTRADITIONAL- IN FACT
THEY ARE OUR OUR STUDENTS. THIS
FALL THE CHANGES OFFICE VISITED
EIGHT COLLEGES BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH OUR STUDENTS AND
WHAT WE HEARD- IS THAT THEY RE
ITERATED POINT THAT THE ALLEY-
MENTIONED THAT. A STUDENTS ARE
FINDING IT BEAT BALANCE SCHOOL
AND WORK OVER 60% OF OUR
STUDENTS WORK MORE THEN- PART
TIME. NEARLY THIRTY HOURS OR
MORE A WEEK MAKING THEM THE SOLE
PROVIDERS NOT JUST FOR
ENRICHMENT BUT REALLY FOR. A
SOUL- BEING THE SOLE PROVIDERS
AND FOR NECESSITY. THEY
REITERATED THAT MANY OF THEM
HAVE DEPENDENT CHILDREN OR ARE
K. CARETAKERS OF PARENTS AND
OLDER. MANY OF THEM ARE FIRST
GENERATION. THESE POPULATIONS
ACROSS A RANGE OF INDICATORS
HAVE EXPERIENCED GREATER HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS- AND AS THE
GREAT RENEGOTIATION HAS
OCCURRED. MANY OF THEM ARE
FINDING OPPORTUNITIES AND
OPPORTUNITY COSTS AND RETURNING
TO WORK. SO OUR WORK IS REALLY
TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE
SEEING THE VALUE THE LONG TERM
VALUE. IN HIGHER EDUCATION. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THESE ARE NOT ICE
TO- AND THAT ACROSS THE NATION
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE BEEN
HIT ESPECIALLY HARD BECAUSE MANY
OF THEM FALL INTO THESE
INDICATORS. WE KNOW THAT THE POP
DAY PANDEMIC CAME AS A PRE
PANDEMIC IT ENROLLMENT DECLINES
WERE ALREADY ANTICIPATED
CALIFORNIA AS YOU MAY KNOW FROM
YOUR WORK IN K. TWELVE IS LOST-
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. AND K. TWELVE
ENROLLMENTS ARE EXPECTED TO DROP
PRECIPITOUSLY BY TWENTY THIRTY
ALL OF THESE AFFECT OUR LONG
TERM PROJECTIONS. AND CREATE
URGENCY AROUND OUR NEED TO
REACHED OLDER ADULT LEARNERS.
WE'RE FORTUNATE THAT ACROSS TO
ME COLLEGES ARE LEADERS HAVE
REALLY GALVANIZED TO ORGANIZE
AROUND ON BRINGING STUDENTS
BACK. TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WE
ALSO ARE WORKING WITH VARIOUS
FOCUS GROUPS STUDENTS SURVEYS
AND WHILE WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO WHAT WE'VE LEARNED THAT
COLLEGES HAVE DONE IS THAT
THEY'VE BEEN. OPERATING CALL
CENTRES TO REACH OUT TO STUDENTS
THAT MAYBE TOOK AN EXCUSE
WITHDRAWAL DURING THE PANDEMIC
SO THAT THEY CAN COME BACK. OR
STUDENTS THAT ENROLLED IN ONE
SEMESTER AND THEN HAVE IT COME
BACK- TRYING TO RE ENGAGING.
WHERE ARE COLLEGES ARE
REIMAGINING HOW THEY PACKAGE
STUDENTS SUPPORTS SO THEY'RE NOT
JUST FOR PROVIDING FINANCIAL
LATER ALSO PROVIDING EMERGENCY
GRANTS. PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT
LAPTOPS ARE HOT SPOTS ACCESS TO
FOOD PANTRIES FORGIVING DEBT
ACROSS OF OUR OUR DISTRICTS OVER
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF STUDENT
DEBT HAS BEEN FORGIVEN- AND THEN
OUR- COLLEGES ARE ALSO PROVIDING
EMERGENCY GRANTS AND VOUCHERS.
THEY'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON DUAL
ENROLLMENT- AND CREATING GREATER
PARTNERSHIPS WHEN THEIR K.
TWELVE AND OTHER INDUSTRY
PARTNERS. AND THEY'RE EXPLORING-
CHANGES COURSE SEQUENCING AND
SHORTER QUALITY. COURSES THAT
CAN GET STUDENTS IN AND. OUT AND
BACK INTO THE LABOR MARKET. SO
AS SUCH WE SEE. DEEPER
ENROLLMENT GREW. AND THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
FOR STUDENT RETENTION FOR
PROFITS ARE OUT SPENDING ASKS
FLORIDA ONE WHEN IT COMES TO
REACHING OUT TO STUDENTS WE NEED
TO RE ITERATE THE VALUE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THESE
RESOURCES ENSURE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE A RESENCE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMING COLLEGES
ACROSS THE STATE. ADDITIONALLY
THE FEDERAL STIMULUS DOLLARS
THAT WERE PROVIDED TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WERE NOT ALLOWED TO BE
USED ON OUTREACH AND ENROLLMENT
STRATEGIES SO THIS IS THE ONLY
SOURCE OF FUNDING THAT IS
AVAILABLE FOR THAT PURPOSE. OUR
WORK IS COMPLEX AND CRITICAL BUT
WE ARE READY TO BE STEADFAST
PARTNERS WITH YOU TO SERVE
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED US MOST
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY HOWEVER A
FEW QUESTIONS- MY FIRST QUESTION
IS FOR THE FOR THE L. A. O. ON
ON IN THE ENROLLMENT DROP I HAVE
THE SAME QUESTION FOR OUR- K.
TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS I KNOW A
LOT OF THEM ARE. FREAKING OUT BY
DECLINING ENROLLMENTS IN HOUSE
IMPACTS OUR FINANCES BUT I
BECAUSE AS A LABOR PERSON I ASK
WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A- EXACT NUMBER GOING FOR
EDUCATION. IF THERE'S FEAR
STUDENTS TO SPIKE YOU KNOW
MATHEMATICS YOU LEARN IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL YOU GET THE
SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY SO YOU GET
MORE MONEY FOR FEWER STUDENTS.
SO IT'S THE SAME THING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES GET 11% OF PROP NINETY
EIGHT. GRANTED WE HAVE OTHER
PROBLEMS WITH NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
IN COLLEGE UP IN THAT TRANSFER
STUDENTS FOR UC'S HIS. WHEN HE
WORKED GETTING DEGREES INSERT.
TO FILL THE JOB OF TODAY AND
TOMORROW AND ET ALL THAT BUT AS
FAR AS THE MONEY PIECE. THE
DISTRICTS. IF THEY'RE STILL BE
STILL GET 11% OF PROPERTY WHICH
IS GROWING GROWING GROWING. R.
ISN'T IT THEY'RE GETTING MORE
MONEY FOR IF YOUR STUDENTS SO
WHY WOULD ANYBODY WHAT'S THE
CONCERN. SURE I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT YOU HAVE THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT CONSTITUTIONAL
GUARANTEE IT'S ABOUT 38% RIGHT
NOW OF GENERAL FUND REVENUES GO
FOR K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION. AND
THEN SIDES OF THE CONSTITUTION
AND STATUTE YOU HAVE A SPLIT
THAT GOES BETWEEN OF THAT MONEY.
K. TWELVE GETS A CERTAIN PERCENT
AND COMMITTEE COLLEGES GET A
CERTAIN PERCENT I THINK IT'S
ABOUT 11% THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
GET AND SNATCHING. SO THE
QUESTION IS HOW DOES THAT MONEY
GO OUT THEN TO THE COLLEGES AND
SO COLLEGES- WILL TELL YOU AT
LEAST ADMINISTRATORS OF THEIR
THE PAPER PAPER FOR THAT MONEY
AND UNRESTRICTED WAY THROUGH
PORTION IT'S WHICH IS THEIR
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA. AND SO IF THE FORMULA
IS BASED IN LARGE PART ON
ENROLLMENT ENROLLMENT DECLINES
AND THEY'RE GOING TO SEE A
DECLINE IN THE UNRESTRICTED. OF
APPORTIONMENT MONEY THAT THEY
GET. THAT MONEY THEN. WOULD NEED
TO GO BACK INTO EITHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OR IF YOU MENDED
STATUTE K. TWELVE AND NOW MONEY
PRESUMABLY THEN WOULD GO INTO
RESTRICTED- FOR RESTRICTED
PURPOSES SO. WHICH WHICH GIVES
THEM LESS CONTROL SO IT'S KIND
OF AN ISSUE FOR THE COLLEGES
ABOUT HOW THAT MONEY COMES TO
THEM DOES IT COME TO THE MINUTE
UNRESTRICTED WAY WHERE THEY HAVE
A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY OVER HOW
THEY USE THAT MONEY TOWARDS A
COME IN AND IN A IN A RESTRICTED
WAY WHERE THEY'RE TOLD EXACTLY
HOW THE MONEY COULD BE USED IN
THERE ARE WORRIED ABOUT A
MISALIGNMENT I GET ALL THAT BUT
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IF. THE
COMMUNICABLE JUST HAVING FEWER
STUDENTS AND ROLL SWEET HERE
CONCERNED- NO WE'RE WORRIED
ABOUT OUR BUDGET BECAUSE WE HAVE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT BUT YOU'RE
STILL GETTING THE SAME AMOUNT OF
MONEY FROM THE STATE FOR
EDUCATING COMMITTEE CALL
STUDENTS YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY
GETTING MORE MONEY PER STUDENT
YOU STILL GET THE SAME OUT OF
POCKETS HIGHER YOUR- FACULTY PAY
SALARIES PAY YOUR YOU KNOW PLAN
FEES AND MAINTENANCE AND- ENERGY
COSTS SO. WHY WHY THE BIG DEAL
FROM YOU KNOW DISTRICTS WHO ARE.
YOU KNOW FREAKING OUT I GUESS.
IF IT'S NOT EQUAL IF. IF LET'S
SAY THERE'S HUNDRED COMMITTEE
CALL DISTRICTS AND IT'S A
HUNDRED AND TEN OR SOMETHING
THAT LET'S SAY LIKE A HUNDRED OF
THEM HAVE DECLINING ENROLLMENT
THERE DIRT DECREASING BY 5%
EVERY YEAR AND THEN. THE OTHER
TENER DECREASING BY 20% SO
THEY'RE OUT LIARS THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE BUT IF EVERYTHING'S
BASICALLY SOMEWHAT IN THE RANGE
OF EVERYBODY'S FALLING. IN A
SIMILAR MANNER. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT AND WHY WHY THE
CONCERN. SO YOU'RE RIGHT THE
MONEY PER STUDENT WOULD STAY THE
SAME IN THAT CASE OVERALL IS
SIMIEN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
STATUS LEVEL COMMUNITY COLLEGES
GOT THEIR 11% BUT IF THE FORMULA
WHERE TO STAY THE SAME THE
APPORTIONMENT. FORMULA WHERE TO
STAY THE SAME AS IT IS NOW.
FUNDING PER STUDENT YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH THEY GET PER STUDENT HOW
MUCH THEY GET PER IN ROMAN R.
FOR OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE TO STAY
THE SAME THAT LEVEL WOULD DROP
SO THEY'RE THEY'RE UNRESTRICTED
MONEY THEIR PORTION OF MONEY
WOULD DROP. AND THEY WOULD THEN
GET MONEY. TO THEM ON A
RESTRICTED BASIS AND THAT WOULD
BE. AS THEY WOULD SEE A LIMITING
SO YOU'RE RIGHT OVERALL THE
FUNDING PER STUDENT WOULD SAY
THE SAME. BUT COLLEGES ARE ALSO
THINKING ABOUT WILL HOW MUCH.
ABILITY HOW MUCH FLEXIBILITY DO
I HAVE OVER THAT MONEY BECAUSE
IF IT COMES BACK JUST IN THE
FORM OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE I'M
SURE THEY WOULD APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY BUT WE
STILL HAVE SALARIES TO PAY WE
STILL HAVE PENSION OBLIGATIONS
TO MEET WE STILL HAVE OTHER
OPERATING COSTS. GOTCHA AND THEN
FOR MAYBE YOU CAN ENLIGHTEN US
ON THIS- FORMER CHANCELLORS
OFFICE THAT- FORGET YOUR LAST
NAME. AT THE AT EXACTLY- WHAT'S
ON WHAT IT FROM DO YOU HAVE AS
FAR AS THAT GOES ON INTENT RIGHT
SO THE THEIR INVOLVEMENT
DECLINES OUR- I'M SURE THAT'S
DIFFERENT BUT IS THERE ARE AS
OUR A RAFFLE RANGER IS IT
ROUGHLY IN THE SAME- PERCENTAGE
WHAT CAN YOU LINE IS HERE. WITH
YEAH I HAVE SHARE A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT KIND OF WHERE WE ARE
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT- THERE
HAVE BEEN ENROLLMENT DECLINES
ACROSS ALL SEVENTY THREE
DISTRICTS AND A HUNDRED SIXTEEN
COLLEGES- THERE. AND MORE ON
EVEN IN CERTAIN AREAS OF THE
STATE- WE'VE SEEN DROPS IN THE
FAR NORTH. AND WE'VE ALSO SEEN
DROPS AND SOME OF IT- THE MORE
EXPENSIVE AREAS TO LIVE I THINK
PART OF- THOSE KIND OF ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
FACING. WE DO SHOW SOME
DISTRICTS ABOUT FIVE THAT ARE
STARTING TO- RE ENROLL STUDENTS
WHO WERE SEEING THEIR STRATEGIES
PAYING OFF AS SOME OF THEIR
INVESTMENT OF THEIR FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS. IN COMBINATION
WITH THE STATE INVESTMENTS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IN THE FIRST YEAR
OF THE PANDEMIC WE LOST A LOT OF
MALE STUDENTS PARTICULARLY BLACK
AND- AND NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS SO THEY'RE A LOT IT
TARGETED EFFORTS NOW. TO BRING
BACK THOSE STUDENTS- ANOTHER KEY
STRATEGY THAT'S REALLY BEEN
EFFECTIVE HAS BEEN DISMISSING
FEES SOMETHING THAT COLLEGES
HAVE DONE THROUGH THE FEDERAL.
DOLLARS THAT THEY RECEIVED. I
GUESS WHAT I ASKED IF WE HAVE A
TO DO YOU HAVE LIKE A RANGE AS
FAR AS AB YOU KNOW RAPPERS ARE
IS YET ONE THAT'S AT 25% ONE
THAT THREE OR ITS IT'S- ARE
THEY- DO WE HAVE LIKE 90% ARE
ROUGHLY. BETWEEN ONE NUMBER
OTHER NUMBER YEAH I CAN ALSO GET
IT WE HAVE A MEMO THAT SHOWS
THAT NOT- I'LL BE. SURE TO
PROVIDE IT TO YOU SHORTLY AFTER
THIS BUT THE RANGE RIGHT NOW
THAT WE'RE SEEING. IS ANYWHERE
FROM AN EIGHT TO A 28% GOTCHA.
AND HOW MANY ARE IN THAT HIGHER
AND TO ROUGHLY. MOST ELEVEN THE
MEDIAN- RANGE AROUND TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN- ACROSS OUR COLLEGES
WHERE YOU ARE SEEING THOSE
LARGER ONES AGAIN I MENTIONED.
MANY OF THEM WERE IN AREAS THAT
WERE ALREADY SEEING LARGE
POPULATION DECLINES EVEN PRE
PANDEMIC. AND THIS JUST
EXACERBATED THAT WERE PEOPLE
MOVING OUT FOR COST OF LIVING OR
OTHER. ISSUES SUCH AND THEN I
KNOW THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR-
CHAIR TEAM. ON THE- IN PERSON.
R. HE I MIGHT. THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES ARE WHICH ARE THE LAST
SEGMENT TO GO. FULLY IN PERSON-
BUT IS THAT A FACTOR IS HAVING
MORE. ONLINE ESSENTIALLY-
PROVIDING. A REASON FOR PEOPLE
TO ENROLL MORE HAS MORE THAN
AROUND YOU KNOW 40% OF OUR
STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE OUR OVER
TWENTY FIVE WHAT WE'RE SEEING ON
THE GROUND IS THAT WHEN A
COLLEGE OR DISTRICT PUTS THEIR
COURSE SCHEDULE ON UP AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEMESTER MANY
OF THEM SEE THEIR ONLINE CLASSES
FILL UP FIRST AND THEN- ARE
HAVING TO CONVERT IN PERSON
CLASSES ONLINE OR A HYBRID
MODALITY SO. RIGHT NOW- AROUND
60% OF COURSES ARE BEING OFFERED
IN PERSON OR AT LEAST STARTING
AS IN PERSON AND THEN
TRANSITIONING ONCE THEY SEE
STUDENT DEMAND WE SEE THAT ALSO
REFLECTED IN ERY SURVEYS THAT
WE'VE HAD OF STUDENTS WHERE
THEY'VE LEARNED THAT THEY LIKE
THE FLEXIBILITY IT WORKS FOR
CERTAIN CLASSES. ARE CAREER AND
CLASSES HAVE BEEN PREDOMINATELY-
IN PERSON SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC FOLLOWING HEALTH AND
SAFETY- PROTOCOLS SO WE ARE
SEEING A DIFFERENCE BUT FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE WORKING THEY
NO LONGER HAVE TO BATTLE TRAFFIC
FINE CARE TAKERS. AND WHILE THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO GO TO SCHOOL.
OKAY THANK YOU. QUESTIONS MR HEY. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I WANNA GO BACK TO
THE TO THE DISCUSSION OF ONLINE
COURSES AND LOOKING AT THE CHART
HERE ON PAGE FIVE. AND IT. IT
SHOWS ME **** IF I'M READING
THIS CORRECTLY. BUT SHOWS THAT
IN THE FALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN
WE'RE TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
ONLINE. AND NOW WE HAVE
PROBABLY- LOOKS LIKE UNDER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND ONLINE IS THAT
ACCURATE. YEAH AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY BASED ON OUR THIS IS A
BASED ON A SURVEY OF SIXTY EIGHT
DISTRICTS SO DOESN'T INCLUDE-
ALL REPORTING BUT WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IS THAT THERE IS YOU SEE
THAT- THAT COMPLETE SHIFT- AND
SO YOU ALSO I KNOW- THAT THESE
ARE FROM FALL- TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SO WE'RE STARTING TO SEE WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IN SPRING- HIM WE'LL
SEE MORE IN PERSON COME THIS
SPRING- BUT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER OUR DEMAND IS STILL.
CONTINUING TO BE HIGHER FOR
ONLINE OR HYBRID CLASSES WILL
NOTE THAT FACULTY ARE ALSO
EXPLORING A NEW MODALITY THAT-
MANY OF THEM FIND A VERY
EFFECTIVE CALLED HIGH FLEX WHEN
THEY CAN BOTH IN PERSON- AND
ONLINE IN A VERY INTERACTIVE.
MODE SO- IF I'M CORRECT THE DATA
SHOWS THAT STUDENTS TYPICALLY
AREN'T AS SUCCESSFUL IN THE
ONLINE EXPERIENCES THEY ARE AND
THEN CLASS- AS THEY ARE IN THE
WITH THE IN CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE
SO WHY SHOULD WE DO SOMETHING.
AND THIS MAY BE A QUESTION FOR
THE CHAIR LATER I DON'T KNOW WE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING TO ENSURE
THERE ARE MORE IN PERSON CLASSES
BECAUSE FOR SOME IT'S NOT JUST A
MATTER OF CONVENIENCE I GET
THAT- STATES THEIR LIFE RIGHT
THEY'VE GOT JOBS ETCETERA BUT
FOR SOME THAT MAY NOT BE SO TRUE
IF THEY'RE NOT IF STUDENTS
AREN'T FINDING SUCCESS. IN THE
ONLINE EXPERIENCE OF THE UNITY
CAREFUL ABOUT PROMOTING IT.
HERE'S ANOTHER QUESTION SO IS
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OPEN. WE
ARE- WE GO BACK TO OUR REAP WHAT
WE'RE CALLING OUR TRANSITION
BACK ON HYBRID SPACE- NEXT MONTH
SO YOU GO BACK TO THE SO THE
OFFICE IS NOT OPEN TODAY. WELL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING- EVERY SINCE
THEN BUT WE GOT THIS IS A TO ME.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE CAN ASK
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS TO GO BACK
IN A CLASSROOM BUT NOT HALF
ASKED PEOPLE TO GO INTO AN
OFFICE BUILDING GO TO WORK IN
THIS NOT YOU NOT PUTTING THIS ON
YOU PERSONALLY. BUT IS JUST
CRAZY TO ME TO THINK THAT THE
CHANCES OFFICES OPEN FULLY OPEN
. I TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE THE OTHER
DAY AND RENEW MY CREDENTIAL
RIGHT I HAD A PROBLEM WITH THAT
THE PLATFORM THE COMPUTER
PLATFORM. I CALLED OVER. WELL I
TRIED TO CALL OVER TEACHER
CREDENTIALING COMMISSION. WELL
THERE IS NO PHONE NUMBER TO CALL
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS AT HOME.
THERE WAS AN EMAIL ADDRESSES I
DON'T WANT EMAIL ANYBODY. BUT
THE POINT IS- PEOPLE NEED TO GET
BACK IN THE OFFICE. SO THAT OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM CAN FUNCTION
OUTSIDE OF THE K. TWELVE SCHOOL.
K. FOURTEEN IF YOU WILL. AS WELL
TO ME IT'S JUST. I CAN'T
CONCEIVE. WHY YOU KNOW THE
THESE. THE STATE OFFICES ARE NOT
OPEN I THINK WE OUGHT TO DO
SOMETHING IN THE BUDGET MISTER
CHAIR. TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
OPEN. BECAUSE I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY PEOPLE CAN AS TEACHERS GO
BACK IN A CLASSROOM STUDENTS
GOING TO CLASS ME YET CAN'T SEEM
TO. TO DO IT THEMSELVES AND- IT
WE NEED TO LOOK AT TYING
FACILITIES MONEY TO IT BECAUSE
OF YOU ARE. TOO IF STUDENTS ARE
COMING BACK TO THE CLASSROOM. DO
WE NEED TO. GIVE AS MUCH
FACILITIES MONEY TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. I GET
THERE'S NAY THEIR- RIGHT TO GET
THERE'S MAINTENANCE I GET THIS
REHABILITATION BUT OF STUDENTS
ARE COMING BACK TO THE CAMPUS.
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO REBOOT AS WELL TAKING A LOOK
AT THAT- WITH THAT I'M I THINK
YOU. GOT A QUESTION. YOU'RE THE
ONE RESPONSIBLE IT'S NOT REALLY
QUITE EIGHT. PROBABLY A- AND-
DON TAURIEL MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE. BUT I REALIZED BUT I WHAT
I AM JUST THE STRUCTURE WE CAN
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION I'M ADAM.
SAYS NEED TO GET OPEN THE
CONSERVE THE INSTITUTIONS. THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO SERVE THANK
YOU. YEAH THAT'S IT THAT'S AN
ISSUE I GUESS THERE'S TWO ISSUES
THERE ONE WE'RE SEEING DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. AND ONE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MORE ON IN PERSON BUT I
GUESS THE COLLEGES ARE SAYING
WELL IF WE DO ALL IN PERSON WE
MAY NOT BRING BACK IN A MOMENT
BECAUSE SOME OF THE STUDENTS ARE
USED TO NOW DOING THE ONLINE-
THAT WE DON'T KNOW LONG TERM IF
IT'S SUCCESSFUL YOU KNOW THEY'RE
PARTICIPATING BUT ARE THEY-
DOING WELL AND THEY YOU KNOW-
MOVING ALONG IN AND GETTING. OUT
OF IT WHAT THEY NEED- I KNOW OF-
COLLEGES FOR YEARS IT HAD SOME
TYPE OF HYBRID TYPE PROGRAM SO.
I WILL ADD THAT IN EARLY DATA
WE'VE SEEN THAT STUDENTS- HAVE
ACTUALLY DONE WELL- ANNA AND
PART OF THAT IS YOU KNOW THAT
THE GREAT WORK OF OUR FACULTY
AND THEY'VE REALLY ENGAGED IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
THIS WORK HAS PROGRESSED SO
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT.
ONLINE TEACHING ONLINE QUALITY
AND SO WE JUST WHERE- SERVING
MYRIADOF STUDENTS AND ALL HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THEIR NEEDS A LOT
MORE DURING THIS TIME. YEAH
OKAY. THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN WE'RE GONNA SKIP
AROUND THE AGENDA AND- I KNOW.
THERE ARE SOME MEMBERS WHO HAVE
TO BE ANOTHER COMMITTEES TODAY'S
BUSY DAY- SO WE'RE GONNA JUMP TO
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT RIGHT NOW
CALTRAIN.
FOR
YEAH RIGHT WE'RE JUST HEARING
FROM- CALIBRATE TO PERMIT A
FINANCE ELIA. THIS IS. YOUR LIFE
THIS IS THE CASE YEAH THE I
WOULD JUST HEARING FROM THE ****
WHERE IS THE TELE YEAH WHETHER
TWENTY FOUR LAST WEEK. VERY
LITTLE WE HAVE LA. NO OKAY YEAH
THIS IS JUST NOT SORRY NOT THE
L. A. NORTH IS JUST ENOUGH. TO
HEAR FROM CALIBRATE AND R. LEE-
DIRECT ON. WITH MINUTE THE YES
HAS THE PRESIDENT YES IT
PRESIDENT MANY THANK YOU YES
WELCOME WELCOME THANK YOU-
SHOULD BEGIN YES PLEASE HEY GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN CARTY I SHARE
FONG AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THIS
MORNING WE AT CAL RIGHT CONTINUE
TO BE LASER FOCUSED ON BUILDING
A NEW COLLEGE FROM THE GROUND UP
AND I'M VERY PROUD TO SHARE OUR
RECENT PROGRESS SINCE JULY WE
MORE THAN DOUBLED OUR ENROLLMENT
WE CREATED NEW SUPPORT SYSTEMS
FOR STUDENTS. WATCHIN INNOVATIVE
NEW PROGRAM WELCOME CSEA AS ARE
CLASSIFIED UNION AND CONTINUE TO
EXPAND OUR CAPACITY TO LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR SUCCESS TODAY AND
IN THE FUTURE. WE'VE ALSO TAKEN
TO HEART AND ACCEPTED EACH OF
THE IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE BY THE STATE AUDITOR LAST
SPRING. AND WE ARE ON TRACK TO
ACCOMPLISH EACH DELIVERABLE ON A
PRESCRIBED TIME FOR TIMELINE.
ONLY HALFWAY THROUGH A STARTED
PERIOD AND OPEN FOR ENROLLMENT
SINCE OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN WE
HAVE MET EVERY MILESTONE
OUTLINED IN CALVERT COUNTY
LEGISLATION. AND- TWO YEARS
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE FOR CREDIT
ATION. AND WE ARE GUIDED BY OUR
BOARD APPROVED STRATEGIC VISION
WHICH LAYS OUT AN AGGRESSIVE BUT
ACHIEVABLE SET OF GOALS. AND A
CLEAR PATH FORWARD TO THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND BEYOND.
AS A STATEWIDE INSTITUTION WE
ARE GUIDED BY THE REALITIES OUR
STUDENTS FACE IN KEY REGIONS OF
THE STATE. AND SO I'M PLEASED TO
SHARE THAT WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SUBSTANTIAL STEPS FORWARD
DEVELOPING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
MISSION ALIGNED ORGANIZATIONS.
RESEARCH FROM OUR COLLEAGUES AT
CAL COMPETES TELLS US THAT 42%
OF ADULTS. IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
WOULD LIKE TO ENROLL IN HIGHER
ED BUT ONLY 7% ACTUALLY ARE. AND
WHEN WE SPEAK WITH ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ENTITIES LIKE THE
INLAND AND EMPIRE ECONOMIC
PARTNERSHIP. WE HEAR OF THE NEED
FOR AN EDUCATIONAL PARTNER THAT
IS NIMBLE AND RESPONSIVE TO BOTH
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE NEED.
THERE'S A SHARED PRIORITY ACROSS
INDUSTRY AND EDUCATION TO
EMPOWER ADULT LEARNERS. THIS IS
WHY WE ARE WORKING WITH. TIONAL
SERVICES IT'S WHY WE HAVE
PARTNERED WITH S. C. A. U. U. H.
W. UNITED HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
TO DEVELOP A LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSING TRAINING PROGRAM TO
CREATE AN ACCESSIBLE AND
POWERFUL PIPELINE FOR MORE
TOWARD MORE DIVERSE FRONTLINE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE WORKING WITH
NEXT GEN POLICY TO EXPLORE I. T.
TRAINING FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
CAN HELP BRIDGE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE FOR INDIVIDUALS AND SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS. AND REFLECTING
OUR ROLE ON THE LEADING EDGE OF
THE LEARNING CURVE WE'VE
LAUNCHED A MULTI YEAR
PARTNERSHIP WITH UC IRVINE'S TOP
RANKED SCHOOL OF EDUCATION.
THROUGH THIS COLLABORATION WILL
APPLIED BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE AND
DATA ANALYTICS TO ACTIVITIES
ACROSS THE STUDENT LIFECYCLE
THAT DRIVE STRONGER OUTCOMES FOR
ADULT LEARNERS. THIS RAPID CYCLE
ARE INDEED HELPS IS QUICKLY
BUILD ON LESSONS LEARNED IN OUR
VERY HUMAN POWERED STUDENT
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. TO BE ABLE TO
TEST NEW IMPROVEMENTS AND
INCORPORATE THEM QUICKLY TO
SCALE WHAT WORKS. AND THE VALUE
OF THESE EFFORTS EXTEND BEYOND
OUR STUDENTS TO CALIBRATE. BY
ADDRESSING THIS YEAR CHALLENGERS
THAT WE FACE ACROSS THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. I'VE
HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR FOR MOST OF MY
CAREER. WORKING TO EXPAND
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY AND
OPPORTUNITY. AS PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S HIGHER EDUCATION ADVISER
AND LEAD INITIATIVES LIKE THE
COLLEGE SCORECARD SIMPLIFYING
THE FASTER. AND IMPLEMENTING
OVERSIGHT OF PREDATORY FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES. LIKE ALL OF YOU
I RECOGNIZE THE PRIVILEGE AND
RESPONSIBILITY IT IS TO BE A
PUBLIC SERVANT. AND FOR ME I ARE
WORKING CALVET IS VERY PERSONAL.
AND REFLECTS THIS UNIQUE MOMENT
WERE SPONSORED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND THEY AREN'T COMING
BACK. WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES
WHY. HIGHER HIGHER EDUCATION
PATTERN IN. AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. ON HOLD GOING FORWARD
UNLESS WE ADDRESS FUNDAMENTAL
DESIGN ISSUES. WE SEE THIS IN
OUR OWN DATA 90% OF STUDENTS TO
CALIBRATE. SHARE THAT OUR UNIQUE
MODEL IS WHAT ME THEIR PROGRAM
ACCESSIBLE 26% OF THE NATION'S
ENROLLMENT DECLINE DURING THE
PANDEMIC CAME FROM CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
HAS LOST MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE PAST
TWO YEARS. ONLY A SMALL NUMBER
OF CAMPUSES OBSCENE AND WRONG
STABILIZE. AND THOSE STUDENTS
WHO WE ARE LOSING AT HIGHS RATES
ARE CONFRONTING UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES IN THEIR LIVES THE
EXACT LEARNERS THE CALVERT WAS
CREATED TO SERVE. OUR MOMENT
REFLECTS OUR PURPOSE AND OUR
MISSION 92% OF OUR THOUSAND
STUDENTS ARE AT LEAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD. MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE SYSTEM WIDE RATE 24% BLACK
33% LATINO. AND ROUGHLY 80% OF
OUR STUDENT BODY IDENTIFIES BY
PARK. AND THEY COME TO US FROM
FORTY COUNTIES TWENTY TO RURAL.
AND MORE THAN ONE IN THREE ARE
PARENTS OR CAREGIVERS SISTERS
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER THAN THE
SYSTEM WOULD RATE. HIGHER
EDUCATION WAS NOT BUILT TO SERVE
THE STUDENTS WELL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND CERTAINLY NOT
DURING. CALIBRATORS MISSION
CRITICAL BECAUSE WE NEED AN
INSTITUTION WITH A DEDICATED
FOCUS ON SOLVING FOR THE COMPLEX
CHALLENGES. FACING LEARNERS
OTHERWISE LEFT BEHIND. CALIBRATE
IS THE FLEXIBLE SKILLS BASED
PUBLIC OPTION CALIFORNIANS NEED
AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO PREDATORY
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES. AND IT IS
AN ESSENTIAL PART OF SOLVING THE
COMPLEX EQUATION. REQUIRED TO
BUILD A MORE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY
AND MORE EQUITABLE EDUCATION
SYSTEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU THIS MORNING. AND ALSO
JOINED BY BOARD OF TRUSTEES
PRESIDENT PAMELA HAINES AND WE
ARE HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THAT THERE ARE A
SERIES OF- QUESTIONS HERE FOR
YOU I KNOW SOME OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WANT TO ENGAGE BUT
THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY OR ANOTHER
COMMITTEES AS WELL- ALL START
OFF WITH MR O'DONNELL. THANK YOU
AND WHAT'S YOUR OFFICIAL TITLE
IT'S THAT PRESIDENT AND CEO
PRESENCIA OKAY WHEN I CHANCELLOR
. AND THE MORE APPROPRIATE GIVEN
AS A COLLEGE YOU KNOW I I'M NOT
ATTACHED TO THE TITLE I THINK
I'M ATTACHED TO THE PURPOSE OF
MAKING A CHANCELLOR. IT'S MORE
ACADEMIC. AT WE WILL TAKE THAT
UNDER ADVISEMENT- HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT SUGGESTION ARE MORE
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION. AND I THINK YOU'RE
KIND OF A TOUGH SPOT- BUT
APPRECIATE YOU TRYING TO RIGHT
THE SHIP. BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT
THERE IS ANY WRITING UP THE SHIP
QUITE FRANKLY I'M NOT SOLD ON
THE CALIBRATE EXPERIMENT TODAY-
I REMAIN SOMEWHAT OPEN MINDED
OVER LAST YEAR. BECAUSE YOUR
CHANCELLOR OF PRESS IN THE UPON
ME TO DO THAT BUT I DON'T SEE A
LOT OF SUCCESS TODAY- AND I WANT
TO SEE SUCCESS AND I JUST WONDER
IF THIS WOULD BE BETTER FULL IT
UNDER AN EXISTING. A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. BUT THAT TO ME- SEEMS
TO BE THE APPROPRIATE THING EVEN
A FUNDING MODEL HERE IS VERY
UNIQUE TONS OF MONEY. BUT NOT
TONS OUTCOME. QUITE FRANKLY- NO
. WE'RE ALL THE AUDITORS-
REGULAR. ADOPTED YES THEY WERE
NOT IN THE BACK TO BACK ON OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE ON IT. AND
I'M SORRY BY THE SPEAKER YES SIR
WE DID ACTUALLY LEAN INTO THE
AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS AND IN
FACT IN MANY WAYS. THE AUDIT
CERTAIN IMPORTANT PURPOSE FOR
DEVELOPMENT AS AN INSTITUTION.
OUT WE LEANED INTO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE USE IT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND TO REALLY
STRENGTHEN A LOT OF THE WORK
THAT WAS UNDER WAY WHEN I FIRST
TOOK THE HELM. AT THOSE KEY
IMPROVEMENTS ARE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAVE WITH
A LOT OF- BUT SO FAR WE TURNED
EVERYTHING ACCORDING TO THE
DELIVERABLE SCHEDULE THAT THE
AUDITOR HAS PRESCRIBED AND WE
CONTINUE TO STAY ON TRACK IN
THAT REGARD. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO DIGITAL FEEDBACK FROM THE
AUDITOR TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADJUSTMENTS THAT NEED TO BE MADE
TO OUR SUBMISSION- AND AS YOU
KNOW THERE WAS SEVERAL TIME
TABLES LAID OUT IN THAT ADIT
FOR MONITORING AND WE CONTINUE
TO IT HERE TO THE US. AND YOUR
CREDIT YOU REALLY INHERITED A
MESS OVER THERE I RECOGNIZE THAT
DUE TO SOME. SOME PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION. BUT LET'S GO
BACK TO THE TO THE TO THE
EMPLOYEES OR SIXTY TWO FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES TWENTY FIVE
CONTRACTORS RIGHT. SO SIXTY TWO
PLUS TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN.
THERE'S NINE. TEACHERS THERE.
NINE SO ME OUT I'M OKAY K.
FACULTY HELP ME UNDERSTAND THE
RAY THERE THAT'S ALL AWFUL LOT
OF NON TEACHING STAFF WITH NO
UNIVERSITY TO TOUCH RIGHT- I
ASSUME YOU HAVE AN OFFICE BUT
REALLY THERE'S NO PLACE FOR
STUDENTS TANGIBLE- TO ARRIVE AT
TO RECEIVE INSTRUCTIONS A HOW IS
IT. THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE WORKING THERE. AND SO IF
YOU FACULTY AND QUITE FRANKLY
THE OUTCOMES SEEM A LITTLE BIT
NEBULOUS AS WELL. YES IT'S
IMPORTANT REMEMBER THAT WE'RE
STILL ACTUALLY QUITE EARLY IN
THE STAGE OF OUR SEVEN YEAR
START A PERIOD ABOUT HALFWAY
THROUGH AND SO WHILE WE HAVE
NINE FULL TIME FACULTY THIS YEAR
YOU'LL SEE HAS INCREASED BY
ABOUT 60% TO FIFTEEN FACULTY.
AND THAT'S IN DIRECT RELATION TO
THE WAY THAT WE'RE GROWING OUR
PROGRAMS AND OUR ROLE IN IT BUT
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
OTHER PEOPLE TOUCH STUDENTS AT
OUR INSTITUTION WE HAVE FOLKS ON
THE FRONT LINE ENGAGED IN
STUDENT INTERACTIONS. THAT ARE
BEYOND OUR FACULTY STUDENT
SUPPORT SPECIALIST FOLKS WERE
SUPPORTING STUDENTS TECHNOLOGY
NEEDS AND IT IS A FULL HANDS ON
DECK EFFORT WITH EVERYTHING
FOCUSED ON THE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE. AS A WHILE OUR
STAFFING REFLECTS THAN WHAT WAS
NEEDED TO PUT IN THE STRUCTURE
AS AN INSTITUTION AT TO PREPARE
US FOR SCALING ENROLLMENT GROWTH
AND WHAT WE WILL SEE NOW IS A
LOT MORE HIRING AND FOCUSED ON-
THOSE ARE ON THE FRONTLINES OF
THAT STUDENT SUPPORT AND STUDENT
TEACHING ASPECT OF THINGS. SO
GIVEN THAT YOU HAVE NINE
FACULTY. AND WHAT A THOUSAND
STUDENTS THAT WE NEED THAT MEANS
EACH FACULTY MEMBER HAS ONE
HUNDRED STUDENTS WELL AGAIN
THEY'RE SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT- FOLKS CENTER CAMPUS
AND WHAT THIS PREPARES US TO DO
TO HAVE THE FULL TIME FACULTY
QUORUM PLACE IN THE STUDENTS
IMPORTANT PLACE IN THE
TECHNOLOGY IN PLACE. IS IT
ALLOWS US TO DIAL UP AND SAID
ACT ASSIST TO PREPARE FOR THE
SCALE WE HAVE A VERY FOCUS
GROWTH PLAN THAT'S BEEN APPROVED
BY OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES TO GO
FROM. OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS THAT WE HAD IN THE
SUMMER TO FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SO IT IS NOT WITHOUT A AT
THE CORE SET OF PLANS AND
OBJECTIVES TO IT TO HOW IT
SCALES WE HAVE TO. BUT
EXPERIENCE IN THE IN. IN PLACE
BEFORE WE SEE. BECAUSE GROWTH
NOT JUST ABOUT. IT IS. ABOUT
ACT. REALLY BEING ABLE TO FOCUS
ON THE QUALITY OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING. AND OTHER STEPS I WILL
JUST MENTION LIKE ACCREDITATION
AND ALL THOSE THINGS. THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT STAT STAGES IN THE
COLLEGES DEVELOPMENT PRESS
PROCESS THAT. ALSO ALLOW US TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU LIKELY HAVE AROUND.
WHAT IS OUR FUTURE REVENUE MODEL
LOOKS LIKE WHAT IT WHAT WE NEED
TO THINK ABOUT IN TERMS OF. AT
GOING FORWARD HOW WE DECIDE AND
DEVELOP A FUNDING MODEL. AT
ALWAYS CONTEMPLATED UNDER
LEGISLATION TO SCALE OUR ABILITY
TO COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION
PROGRAM NOT JUST TECH HELP RIGHT
BUT ACROSS THE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE. YOU KNOW WHAT I NOTICE
WITH CALVERT EVERY TIME THEY
COME UP HERE AND I DON'T I'MNOT
GONNA ASK YOU RESPOND TO THIS
COMMENT IS IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO
HAPPEN. IS ALWAYS GOING TO
HAPPEN WE NEED MORE MONEY. WE
NEED MORE STAFF BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. BUT I'M NOT
SURE THAT IT'S HAPPENING. AND I
THINK THE DATA REFLECTS THAT ONE
THOUSAND. EIGHTY GRADUATES. FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
WITHDRAWALS. NOT DEFENSIBLE FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE. ESPECIALLY WITH
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT MONEY
THAT'S GOING INTO THIS PROGRAM
AS A STUDENT MONEY. MONEY MEANT
FOR STUDENTS. AND IT LOOKS TO
ME. LIKE IT'S GOING TO HIRE
EMPLOYEES OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM OR EVEN THE VIRTUAL
CLASSROOM. THANK IS A REAL ISSUE
HERE- STUDENT TO TEACHER RATIO
AND ALL THESE FOLKS I KNOW
YOU'VE MADE THE ARGUMENT THAT WE
NEED THEM WE NEED THEM. BUT
EVERY TIME. CALVET HERE WE NEED
THIS WE NEED THIS AND IT'S GONNA
HAPPEN IT'S GONNA HAPPEN. I JUST
DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING TODAY. I
THINK MISTER CHAIR WE NEED TO
END THIS EXPERIMENT. I KNOW IT
WAS WELL INTENTIONED. BUT I
THINK- IF THERE IS SUCH A
PROGRAM THAT SHOULD EXIST IT
SHOULD EXIST. UNDER AN EXISTING-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT TO ME IS
THE NO BRAINER AGAIN WE'RE
TRYING TO RECREATE THE WHEEL. OR
EVEN PERFECT WE'LL ONE ALREADY
EXISTS. I DOWN THE ROAD HERE IN
SACRAMENTO- SO- I. I'M NOT
CONVINCED TODAY I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING- BUT I'M JUST
NOT CONVINCED TODAY THAT THIS IS
A PATH WE SHOULD KEEP GOING DOWN
. IT'S TIME TO END THIS. BERMAN
BACK TO YOU. CHAIR YEAH YOU- I
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS THAT WILL
BE TO MISTER MEDINA. SO I
REALIZE WE HAVE ONGOING MONEY
AND ONE TIME WHEN THERE'S THIS
IS A BUNCH OF THE ONE TIME STILL
THERE. AND IT DOES SEEM LIKE A
LOT OF MONEY ON GOING FOR THAT
HE PEOPLE SO IT'S I GUESS LIKE
TWO HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER EMPLOYEE BUT MAYBE
IT'S YOUR START UP IN LOCAL
CHANGE. BUT I GUESS THE BIGGEST
ISSUE. THAT I WANT TO RAISE IS
WHEN THIS WAS CREATED. BEFORE
YOU WERE AROUND HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH YOU YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY THE
MOST COMPETENT PERSON IN THIS
ENTITY HERE THAT WE'VE SEEN. BUT
IT HAS ZERO TO DO WITH YOU IT'S
ABOUT THIS MISSION TAXPAYERS A
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT ELSE WE DO
SO WHEN THIS IDEA WAS PROPOSED I
THINK FOUR YEARS AGO. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC IT WAS A DIFFERENT
WORLD. AND WE JUST HAD. ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THEY CAN'T COUNT
COLLEGES TALK ABOUT HOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE BECOMING
MORE AND MORE ONLINE. AND THIS
IS THAT WAS THE REASON WHY THIS
WAS CREATED BECAUSE THERE WASN'T
A LOT OF ONLINE STUFF AND MISS
NAVARETTE JUST ARTICULATE THIS
IS THE FUTURE OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STUDENTS ARE VOTING
WITH THEIR FEET. THEIR FINGERS
THEIR IPHONE OR THEIR COMPUTER
TO SIGN UP WHEN THEY GO ON A
ROLL. THEY PRIORITIZE ONLINE AND
I UNDERSTAND THEY'RE BUSY
COMMITTEE COSTUMES ARE OLDER.
AND JOBS ARE FAMILIES ARE LESS
FLEXIBLE AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD SO
THEY'RE DOING THIS ONLINE STEPS
IF WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND TEN
COLLEGES WHO ARE THRIVING AND
THEIR FACULTY ARE LEARNING HOW
TO DO. ZOOM EDUCATION NOW WHY DO
WE NEED THIS EXPERIMENT IT SEEMS
THAT IT WAS EXPERIMENTS AND IT'S
NOT WORKING AND I CONCUR THAT.
WE'RE GONNA ZERO FUN THIS ONCE
AGAIN THAT'S OUR DESIRE HERE IN
THIS BODY- AND THEN THE SECOND
PIECE. IS THAT WHEN THIS WAS
PROPOSED TO US THE NOTION WAS
WE'RE GOING AFTER THE STRANDED.
STRANDED CALIPHS IT'S- THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE AN ALTERNATE
SERVER SHASTA COUNTY OR YOU KNOW
EAST OF. YOUR AREA MR MEDINA WHO
WHO DON'T HAVE EDUCATION DON'T
HAVE ACCESS SO THEY NEED THIS
ONE WE JUST WE HAVE THAT THAT
EARLIER CUNY COLLEGES ARE NOW
DOING. MORE THAN HALF OF THE
STUFF ONLINE. BUT ALSO THE
NOTION WAS YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO
FOCUS ON PEOPLE. WITH LIMITED
EDUCATION BACKGROUND AND I THINK
THAT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I
THINK THOSE PEOPLE NEED A
COLLEGE TO GO TO EXISTENCE WE
NEED ACADEMIC SUPPORT THEY DON'T
REALLY DO WELL ON YOU TO THE
UNIVERSITY THEY NEED PEOPLE TO
HELP THEM PAY I KNOW IT'S A
TOUGH. ASSIGNMENT YOU GOT A BAD
GRADE HERE BUT YOU KNOW KEEP
GOING TO DO X. Y. Z. SO IT NEEDS
TO SUPPORT I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING
TO THAT ONLINE BUT IT'S NOT THE
SAME HYBRID WE AT IN PERSON. BUT
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE 33% OF
YOUR STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES SO OF YOUR-
SO CALLED A THOUSAND STUDENTS
HERE AT OF COMPLETED. THAT'S THE
POPULATION THAT WE WEREN'T
SUPPOSED TO FOCUS ON YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO FOCUS 1100% ON
PEOPLE. WITHOUT BACHELOR'S
DEGREES WITHOUT ANY COLLEGE THAT
WAS WHAT YOU SOLD US WITH. FOUR
YEARS AGO THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
GO OUT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO WERE.
BARELY A HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE OR
DROP OUT TRYING TO GET BACK IN
THE COLLEGE GAME WHO WHO NEEDED
SKILLS TO ADVANCE THEIR CAREERS
AND SELL. IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S THIS SCOPE SHAFT. AND
THAT YOU KNOW WE CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY IN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS THIS PANDEMIC HAS HAS MADE
THINGS. VERY VERY VERY DIFFERENT
SO. CHAMBER GALGIANI YEAH LESS
THAN YES I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
RESPONSE IT WOULDN'T IN THE FORM
OF A QUESTION SO I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S A LOT OF THEIR
INTERVAL WITH ME RESPONDING
NUMBER OPEN I'D LIKE TO UNPACK A
COUPLE THINGS IF YOU'LL LET ME
THAT THE FIRST THING IS REALLY
AND THIS QUESTION AROUND THE AND
THAT 30% OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE
COME TO US WITH BATCHES DEGREES
IS A VERY INTERESTING ONE THAT
WERE UNPACKING RIGHT NOW AT
LARGELY BECAUSE MOST OF THE
STUDENTS WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR CRM
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE BILL CAME TO
US FROM THE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
SYSTEM WHICH MEANS THAT THEY'RE-
FACING AT POINT IN TIME ECONOMIC
DISLOCATION. AND SOMETHING IS
TRYING THEM TO OPEN ACCESS
INSTITUTIONS AND WE ACTUALLY
SURVEY OUR STUDENTS AND WE YOU
KNOW OUR OUR AGE DEMOGRAPHIC IS
HIGHER IN TERMS OF THE AVERAGE
AGE OF STUDENT THAN REGULAR THAT
THE REST OF THE SYSTEM IS AND
BUT WHEN WE SURVEY THEM 90% OF
THEM TALK ABOUT OUR FLEXIBLE
MOBILE AND THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY
JUST ABOUT BEING ONLINE THAT IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT BEING A SKILLS
BASED COMPETENCY BASED MODEL-
THAT'S DESIGNED AROUND AT THE
LEARNER'S NEEDS AN ASYNCHRONOUS
NOT TIED TO THE ACADEMIC
CALENDAR AT. AS RESTRICTIVE IN
NATURE AND WHEN WE LOOK AT WHO
HAS FALLEN OUT OF OUR THIS IS.
JUST CALVET. COLLEGE THIS IS
COMMUNITY. A THE- IT IS THIS
POP. OF LEARNERS. SO WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY FOCUSED ON-
ESPECIALLY NON DEGREED
INDIVIDUALS BUT WE'RE ALSO
UNPACKING. WHAT IS HAPPENED IN
THE COURSE OF SOMEONE'S LIFE
THAT THEY'RE SUFFERING FROM.
UNEMPLOYMENT EVEN WITH A DEGREE.
AND IT WASN'T AT THE HIGHER
LEVEL HM A CRACK AT THAT THEY'RE
COMING TO US FOR. RESKILLING
OPPORTUNITIES AND SOME OF THOSE
THINGS AND- I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO ME FOR. THIS
BODY TO CONSIDER AND TO
UNDERSTAND AS- WE DON'T SEE
OURSELVES AS SEPARATE AND APART
FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. WE ARE DEFINITELY A PART
OF IT AND WE'RE A KEEP IMPORTANT
FEATURE IN THAT LANDSCAPE
BECAUSE- EVERYTHING THAT WE
LEARN AND CAN CONTRIBUTE. CAN BE
SHARED ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND
THIS IS NOT A POPULATION FRANKLY
THAT WE'RE DOING WELL WITH THAT
AGAIN THAT'S NOT JUST CALIFORNIA
THAT'S AMERICAN HIGHER EDUCATION
RIGHT NOW. YEAH SO LET'S GO HE
WENT ON PASSING THINGS HOW ABOUT
THAT THE- ISSUE I THINK IS THE
OVERWHELMING ONE IS WHEN WE-
STARTED THIS. THIS PROPOSAL FOUR
YEARS AGO. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS
AND THE FACULTY THE- OPPOSES NOW
I REALIZE YOU HAVE. NO A DOZEN
SO PEOPLE THAT MAY HAVE A UNION
CONTRACT YOU KNOW THE LINES HAD.
CONCERN AND ALL THE THINGS IS
THAT IS HEY WE CAN DO THIS AND
ARGUMENT FROM CALIBRATORS WELL
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT YOU DON'T DO
THIS YOU'RE NOT THAT'S NOT YOUR
MISSION YOU'RE NOT ONLINE. AND
WE SAID HEY WE SHOULD HAVE A FEW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES GIVE THEM.
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW THEIR ONLINE
PRESENCE WHY REINVENT THE WHEEL.
WELL NOW WE HAVE ALL THIS ONLINE
BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC SO IS
THIS A BIT OF DUPLICATION. OF A
HUNDRED AND TEN COLLEGES THAT DO
THIS. VERY WELL AND I I'D ARGUE-
YOU KNOW. THEY'VE THEY'VE
FIGURED OUT BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR AWHILE AND SO. YOU
KNOW WE'RE PUMPING YOU KNOW-
GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD TO THIS SO.
WHY WOULD WE CONTINUE WITH THIS
EXPERIMENT WE HAVE OVER HERE A
BUNCH OF COLLEGES A HUNDRED THE
NOW DO ONLINE. VERY WELL. THIS
IS ACTUALLY NOT A POPULATION
THAT WE'RE DOING WELL WITH. THE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION FREE.
CERTIFICATION ACROSS OUR HIRED
INSTANCE OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WE SEE VERY LOW RATES OF
COMPLETION OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD WITH THIS POPULATION OF
LEARNERS SO IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT
BEING ONLINE BUT IT IS ACTUALLY
ABOUT HAVING A MODEL. THAT
ALLOWS US TO- STRUCTURE AROUND
THE NEEDS OF THE LEARNERS AND
THAT IS AGAIN ASYNCHRONOUS NOT
TIED TO THE ACADEMIC CALENDAR
NOT JUST ONLINE BUT SKILLS BASED
BASED ON THE MASTERY OF SKILLS.
OKAY SO YOU'RE SAYING WE'RE NOT
DOING WELL WITH COMPLETION OVER
THERE. BUT WE'VE DONE A COUPLE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
EXPERIMENT. AND YOU. HAVE TO
BIRD EIGHTY INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
COME YEAH. SO HOW COULD YOU
CRITICIZE THE SYSTEM WHEN READ A
GREAT FAILURE. FROM YOU ALL WITH
COMPLETING PEOPLE YEAH AND IT'S
NOT EXACTLY A CRITICISM OF THE
SYSTEM IS THE REALITY THAT THOSE
SYSTEMS ARE NOT REALLY BUILT.
LIKELY NOT GOING OUT YES
ABSOLUTELY. PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SUCCEEDED. THE EIGHTY. EIGHTY
PEOPLE ROUGHLY IN THIS ROOM AND
OUTSIDE RIGHT NOW. YES SELL SELL
THOSE ARE NOT ROUTINELY AND WE-
CERTAINLY DO NOT RISK WE RE AT
SATISFIED WITH MISLEADING. WE
FOCUS ON. CYNICAL AND THEN. IN
THAT. THAT YOU CAN AFFECTS.
SUCCESS SO WE REALIZE WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE IMPROVEMENTS WE'VE
AND- AT THE COLLEGE IS THAT WE
GET STUDENTS. AND ON THE RIGHT
TRACK SO WHEN YOU KNOW JUST EVEN
LOOKING AT IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE'VE MADE OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS. YOU KNOW SIX MONTHS AGO
80% OF OUR STUDENTS HAD MADE
SOME SORT OF SATISFACTORY
ACADEMIC PROGRESS IN THE COURSE
OF A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS. IN
JUST THIS PERIOD WITH
IMPROVEMENTS WITH INTERVENTION
WITH EFFORT AND WITH ENGAGEMENT
WITH OUR STUDENTS WE'VE SEEN
THAT SHORTENED BY TWO MONTHS AND
SO WE KNOW WE'RE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK AND WE KNOW THAT. A LOT OF
THE STUDENTS THAT ARE COMING
INTO OUR INSTITUTION NOW WILL
RECEIVE THAT IMPROVED VERSION OF
THE EXPERIENCE. THAT WILL
CONDITION THEIR SUCCESS WE'LL
SEE AN UPTICK IN COMPLETIONS
OVER A PERIOD OF- THE COMING
SUMMER FALL EXCEPT TRACK. AT
WHEN THE FLOW OF THE STUDENTS AT
THAT TIME TO COMPETE THEIR
COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAMS. SO DO
YOU THINK IT'S A GOOD INVESTMENT
THAT WE'VE SPENT ROUGHLY ONE
POINT FIVE. MILLION DOLLARS. PER
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S GOT A
CERTIFICATE. THAT CALIFORNIA FOR
WEEKS GIVEN- OVER HOW MILLION
DOLLARS. ON GOING AND WHAT TIME
TO RIGHT. WE HAVE EIGHTY PEOPLE
WITH A CERTIFICATE AND- WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MOST PEOPLE HAD DEGREES
IN THE FIRST PLACE SO. WE WOULD
JUST NOT GOOD INVEST FOR YOU. I
THINK IT'S A CRITICAL I'VE KNOWN
PER PERSON I THINK IT'S A
CRITICAL INVESTMENT TO OF FOR US
TO MAKE OVER THE- YEARS THAT ARE
DONE. WHEN YOU PUT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION. PER GRADUATE AT
YEAH I ABSOLUTELY WOULD BECAUSE
WE HAVEN'T EXPENDED DOWN THAT
THE FULL SCOPE OF THAT RESEARCH
HAS BEEN QUITE JUDICIOUS WITH
THE WAY WE'RE DOING IT BECAUSE
WE'RE FOCUSED ON ENHANCING
QUALITY SPENT. A LITTLE OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION SO FAR. AT WITH
THREE YEARS OF ONGOING PLUS THE
ONE TIME. TWICE WE HAVE NOT
EXPENDED ALL OF THAT DOWN BUT
BUT YES TO PUT INTO PLACE TO
START OF INFRASTRUCTURE
ABSOLUTELY THAT CAN SCALE AND
THEN OVER TIME AS YOU I THINK
EARLIER POINTED OUT WE WILL DO
THE MATH HERE WELCOME BACK BUT
I'M I'M- PRETTY SURE IT'S
ROUGHLY. ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR NORTH OF ONE WELL NORTH OF
ONE MILLION DOLLARS PER
GRADUATE- HELLO MR MEDINA WILL
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT. THE
AUDIT THAT HE'S PARTICIPATED IN. CERTI MORE TWO MORE ISSUES ON
SHOULD THE JUMP INTO THAT WE
TALK ABOUT HERE IN THE AGENDA-
WHY DO YOU THINK THERE BEEN SO
FEW. STUDENTS WHO HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR SHORT TERM PROGRAMS.
THAT'S ONE THING YOU FOCUS ON IS
FLEXIBILITY AND I GET A CLAIM
CAL BRIGHT LIKE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES HAVE EASIER ENTRY. THE
BEARS EVENTUALLY ARE DIFFERENT
THAN ROLLING ONCE OR TWICE A
YEAR LIKE OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE. SO FOR THE SHORT TERM
PROGRAMS WHY DO WE HAVE SO FEW
STUDENTS WHO HAVE COMPLETED.
IT'S A IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
WE LOOK AT IT VERY CLOSELY
BECAUSE RIGHT SAID ACUTE
INSTITUTIONAL PRIORITY FOR US.
AND WHAT WE FIND IS THAT WHEN
WE'RE ABLE TO REACH STUDENTS AND
INTERACT WITH STUDENTS WE SEE
THE THOSE IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE
MAKE IN THOSE INTERVENTIONS.
THING TO SUPPORT THEM THROUGH
WHAT IS USUALLY A VERY
CHALLENGING TIME IN THEIR LIFE
WITH A LOT OF COMPETING
PRIORITIES AT THE SAME TIME WE
BALANCE THE NEED THAT WE HAVE TO
DEMONSTRATE COMPLETIONS WITH THE
GRACE THAT WE HAVE TO GIVE
STUDENTS IN THE REALITIES THAT
THAT THEY'RE- FACING. AT THAT
DRAWS THEM TO A SELF PACED KIND
OF PROGRAM SO WE HAVE TO ALWAYS
BE ASKING OURSELVES ARE WE DOING
EVERYTHING INSTITUTIONALLY
POSSIBLE IN TERMS OF SUPPORTING
OUR STUDENTS THROUGHPUT- AND SO
WHEN WE SEE THOSE EARLY
INDICATORS OF SUCCESS AT THE
BEGINNING END OF THE PROCESS THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING WITH OUR STUDENTS THE
WAY THAT OUR COUNSELORS AND OUR
STUDENTS SUPPORT SPECIALIST.
INTERACT WITH OUR STUDENTS ON A
VERY REGULAR BASIS TO SUPPORT
AND ALSO TO RECOGNIZE TIMES IN
WHICH THEY MEET NEED MORE TIME
OR TO BREAK- THOSE ARE THE WAYS
IN WHICH WE HAVE HAD IMPLEMENTED
A SERIES OF DIFFERENT SUPPORTS
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE. A YEAR AGO
SO YOU KNOW EVERY SIX MONTHS
EVERY DAY REALLY WE ARE
IMPROVING UPON WHAT WE'RE DOING
AND IMPLEMENTING THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS AND- I THINK THAT'S
PARTICULARLY SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
THAT THE TIME THE TIME FRAMES IN
WHICH STUDENTS. ACHIEVE A BETTER
EXPERIENCE- AND THE WAY THEY
ENTER INSTITUTIONS DOESN'T
REFLECT WHAT WAS THERE SIX
MONTHS AGO IT REFLECTS AN
IMPROVED EXPERIENCE AND THAT'LL
CONTINUE THANK YOU. I'LL LET
MISTER MEDINA FOCUS ON THE THEIR
AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS BUT ONE
LAST QUESTION HERE SO AS YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR THERE IS A BILL.
TO ELIMINATE- CALIBRATE WHICH IS
YOU KNOW STILL- TO THE SENATE
ABILITY. TO YOUR BILL CERVANTES
AND THEN THERE IS A PROPOSAL TO-
NOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN OUR
BUDGET PUSH ZERO FINANCE- I. THE
BILLS YOU NAY. IN ASSEMBLY- I
ONLY MET ONE LAWMAKERS. CAL
RIGHT OUT OF A HUNDRED TWENTY SO
MAYBE HAVE OTHERS BUT I'VE SEEN
ONE- LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR SAID
BERNIE GIVE YOU ONE MORE YEAR.
ESSENTIALLY TO US IS LIKE I
REALIZE YOU'RE ZERO FUNDING IT.
HOW MANY GIVEN ONE MORE YEAR. TO
GET THEIR ACT TOGETHER. AND SHOW
SUCCESS SO DO YOU THINK THAT YOU
. NOT YOU PERSONALLY SIGNED BY
YOU DO YOU THINK THIS ENTITY HAS
SHOWN SUCCESS IN ONE YEAR TO
PROVE ITS WORTHINESS BASED UPON
THE NUMBERS WE HAVE BEFORE US
TODAY I ABSOLUTELY DO AND
EXPLAIN WHY WITH EIGHTY
GRADUATES THAT THOUSAND STUDENTS
I ABSOLUTELY DO BECAUSE WE'RE
SOLVING A VERY DIFFICULT PROBLEM
FOR A GROUP OF LEARNERS THAT
HASN'T BEEN SOLVED FOR IN THE
SYSTEM. AND WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
ON THE RIGHT TRACK OF SOLVING
THOSE THINGS BOTH BECAUSE WE'RE
MEETING WITH ALL OF THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN SET
OUT FOR US BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
AT BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING THOSE
EARLY SIGNS OF SUCCESSES AND SO
THE FACT THAT WE NEED TIME TO
ACTUALLY BUILD MORE OUT FROM THE
INSTITUTION AS WAS ORIGINALLY
ENVISIONED IN THE LEGISLATION
THAT KIND OF SEVEN YEAR TO START
OF TIME FRAME. I BELIEVE WE'RE
TRACKING TOWARDS AND WE'RE
WORKING VERY HARD TO HAVE A
GREAT TEAM IN PLACE COMING FROM
A WHOLE RANGE OF PUBLIC
NONPROFIT AND AT PRIVATE SECTOR
EXPERIENCES M. WE HAVE THE TEAM
IN PLACEI'VE BEEN FINALLY ABLE
TO PUT THE TEAM IN PLACE TO
CARRY THISWORK FORWARD AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SEEING SO MUCH
PROGRESS AND IN THE PAST SIX
MONTHS FOR EXAMPLE. I DON'T I
CAN'T SEE HOW YOU SAVE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS WITH THAT.
WHEN YOUR GOAL WAS TO FOCUS ON
PEOPLE WITH LIMITED EDUCATION
AND A THIRD OF YOUR STUDENTS.
HAVE BACHELOR'S DEGREES. AS IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE LIKE I'M
NOT SURE WHAT YOU'RE SELLING
YOURSELF- YOU MISTER MEDINA. THE
THIS YEAR- I WILL TAKE THIS BACK
TO WIN THIS- I EIGHT. RIGHT YEAH
THAT WAS THE LITTLE CONFUSED FOR
THAT. RIGHT AND IS THIS. TAKE US
BACK TO THE BEGIN AND WHO THE
STUDENTS WERE GONNA BE AND WHAT
THIS PRO WAS A FOR AND IT WAS
VERY MUCH THE THERE WAS A NICHE
OF STUDENTS OF THOSE ARE NOT
STUDENTS A NICHE OF WORKERS
ACTUALLY RIGHT WHO WERE
UNSKILLED I NEEDED TO IMPROVE.
THEIR SKILLS. PEOPLE IN THE-WORKFORCE WHO DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS
TO- TO EDUCATION. AND THAT THIS
NICHE WAS OUT THERE- THAT IT WAS
NEEDED THAT THIS NEW ENTITY
COULD MEET THE NEEDS OF THOSE
WORKING INDIVIDUALS. RIGHT- THE
OTHER ENTITIES MAYBE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES. WE'RE TAPPING IAN
TAPPING IN TO THE STUDENTS OR TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO NEEDED TO
IMPROVE- THEIR SKILLS. AND IT
WAS THEM WHO THE PROGRAM WAS
INTENDED FOR. AND THAT THERE WAS
A GREAT NEED. FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES ADULT ED DIDN'T
MEET THE NEED FOR. AND SO I
WOULD AGAIN POINT OUT A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT PROBABLY ALREADY
HAVE- AND THAT THAT SUCH LOW
NUMBERS DOESN'T SHOW- THE NEED
FOR IT HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
ATTRACT- THE WORKERS- IN THE
WORK FORCE SO I HAVEN'T SEEN IT
BEEN DEMONSTRATED- THAT THE NEED
IS THERE. GIVEN THE LOW NUMBER
OF- FEW STUDENTS WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED SINCE THE INCEPTION
DO DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT NUMBER
IS HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN ANY WAY IN THE
PROGRAM IN THE FOUR YEARS RIGHT
IN THE FOUR YEARS THAT. THREE
YEARS THAT ITS EXISTENCE I DON'T
HAVE THE RUNNING TOTAL I HAVE
OUR CURRENT ENROLLMENTS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH THAT
INFORMATION IF IT'S HELPFUL TO.
THE RIGHT NOW IT'S ONE THOUSAND
STUDENTS RIGHT ONE THOUSAND
STUDENTS. AND EIGHTY IS THE
TOTAL OF HAPU HAVE FINISHED- IT
IN IN ALL THE TIME THAT COD
RIGHT AS BEEN. IN EXISTENCE YES
YES SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN HOME
LET'S SAY SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS
AFTER THAT AND- OKAY. YEAH I
DON'T SEE WHERE THE FIGURES
SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT. YOU KNOW
THAT THAT WE WERE TOLD THAT THIS
WAS NEEDED- SO BADLY. BECAUSE
THE NUMBERS JUST HAVEN'T BEEN
THERE- IN A ROMAN IN GRADUATION
. AND I THINK THE QUESTION ALSO
CAME UP HOW MANY OF THE
GRADUATES OF THE- EIGHTY RIGHT
THE QUESTION CAME UP HOW MANY OF
THEM HAVEBEEN ABLE TO. TO GET
JOBS AND TO GET JOBS IN THE
FIELD THAT THEY TRAIN FOR. IS
THAT DATA AVAILABLE. AT THE DATA
IS NOT AVAILABLE ON ACTIVE YET
I'M ACTUALLY GLAD THAT YOU ASKED
THAT BECAUSE M. WE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON THE LABOR MARKET
OUTCOMES IN ALL OF THE FORMS AND
WE HAVE JUST RECENTLY ACTUALLY
JOINED THE CCC LAUNCH BOARD AND
SO WE'LL SEE DATA COMING OUT OF
THAT- LIKELY IN THE NEXT TWELVE
MONTHS IT'LL BE IMPLEMENTED NEXT
QUARTER. AND THAT THE DATA
ITSELF IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
GATHER FOR INSTITUTIONS AND SO
WE ARE ACTUALLY SPENDING A LOT
OF TIMES ON TIME ON BUILDING THE
DATA INFRASTRUCTURE FOR US TO
COLLECT A LOT OF DIVERSE- TYPES
OF LABOR MARKET OUTCOMES BECAUSE
WHAT WE FIND WITH THIS.
POPULATION OF LEARNERS AS WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT IT FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF HOW THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING THE EMPLOYMENT
MARKET AND WHEN WE DO THAT WE
KNOW THAT FOR SOME CASES. IT IS
SCALING AND THE JOB THAT THEY
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN IT
BECAUSE THE SKILLS REQUIREMENTS
ARE CHANGING IN SOME CASES IT IS
GOING FROM AN HOURLY JOB TO
EIGHTY AND- ADD TO A SALARIED
JOB. AND PROVIDING SOME
STABILITY IN THEIR WORK AND
LIFE- SO THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT LABOR MARKET OUTCOMES
THAT WE DON'T EVEN CURRENTLY
TRACK IN HIGHER ED GENERALLY OUT
WERE IN THE WORK FORCE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE ALSO SEEKING TO AT TO
TRACK RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA WE
FEEL THAT A AND- THAT ALUMNI
SURVEY THAT HELPS US COLLECT
SOME OF THAT SELF REPORTED DATA.
BUT ULTIMATELY WERE WORKING
TOWARDS MORE GLOBAL SOLUTIONS IN
THAT REGARD BECAUSE WE NEED
BETTER DATA ON EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES NOT JUST FOR CALIBRATE
FOR HIRED AS A WHOLE AND SO SOME
OF THESE METRICS WILL BE A KEY
COMPONENT ABOUT THAT. AND ALL OF
THAT IS VERY CLEARLY ACTUALLY
LAID OUT IN TERMS OF OUR
EFFORTS. IN OUR THREE YEAR
STRATEGIC VISION THAT HAS BEEN
ADOPTED BY OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES
TO REALLY FOCUS ON THIS QUESTION
OF- THE EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES IN
ADDITION. COMES TO MAY- FOR
YEARS IN THREE YEARS AND THIS
PROGRAM OUT WITHOUT THAT DATA. I
DON'T KNOW HOW THE LEGISLATURE
COULD REACH ANY KIND OF
CONCLUSION AS TO THE VALUE OF
THE PROGRAM- TO THOSE EIGHTY
INDIVIDUALS EVEN WHO COMPLETED
IT OUT WITHOUT WITHOUT THAT
KNOWLEDGE- WE DON'T HAVE THAT WE
AT ALL. TO SEE YOU KNOW. HOW OF
THEIR- JOB SITUATION IMPROVED-
WERE THEY ABLE TO MOVE UP IN
INCOME. WITH WITHOUT THAT I JUST
DON'T SEE HOW YOU KNOW WE CAN
DRAW ANY CONCLUSIONS- ANSWER
THAT WAS ALSO A KEY
RECOMMENDATION OF THAT STATE
AUDITOR TO AT THE ASKS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WE WOULD
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF DATA
COLLECTION AROUND THOSE THINGS
TO MANY OF THOSE PLANS ARE. AT
DEFINED IN OUR RESPONSE TO THE
STATE AUDIT AND THEY JUST NEED
TIME TO BE IMPLEMENTED AS WAS IN
AGAIN ENVISIONED UNDER THE SEVEN
YEAR STARTUP TIME FRAME. TO THE
IDEA OF- I THINK I THINK IN HERE
THERE IS SOME DISCUSSION. OF
STARTING- THE NURSING PROGRAM.
CORRECT A LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSING LICENSE VOCATIONAL
ALBEIT WHICH WHICH WHICH WOULD
YOU SAY THAT THAT IS DIFFERENT
FROM THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF WHAT
KIND OF RIGHT WAS SET UP TO DO I
DO NOT WORK OURS IS A COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT
THE AUDITOR THEMSELVES RECOGNIZE
THE DIFFERENTIATION OF OUR MODEL
THAT IT IS ASYNCHRONOUS THAT IS
TARGET AROUND A PARTICULAR
POPULATION OF LEARNERS THAT
THERE WAS A NEED FOR IT- SO.
WE'RE REALLY RELYING ON ON THAT
DEFINITION OF IT THE LPN PROGRAM
IS PARTICULARLY UNIQUE BECAUSE
OF ITS PARTNERSHIP WITH SEIU
UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS-
BECAUSE IT STANDS TO PRESENT A
SCALABLE SOLUTION WITH A PARTNER
WHO WILL SUPPORT THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT ASPECTS OF. THE
PROGRAM ITSELF TO ADDRESS
CRITICAL SHORTAGES IN THE STATE
BUT ALSO REALLY TO DIVERSIFY THE
PIPELINE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
WAYS IN WHICH WE FACILITATE MORE
EQUITABLE HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
MANY AREAS AND THAT OUR HEALTH
CARE DESERT'S AT THIS IS A CORE
PART OF AN ACCESS POINT THAT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. AT CAN CAN
REACH AN IN AN ACCESSIBLE WAY-
WITH A PARTNER ON THE GROUND WHO
CARES A LOT ABOUT THOSE WORKERS
WHERE THE JOBS WILL HAVE MARKERS
OF JOB QUALITY. WOULD YOU YOU
WOULDN'T SAY THAT THIS IS A
CHANGE FROM THE ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF THE PROGRAM THE LEGISLATION
SPEAKS S. SERVE VERY
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT- THE TYPES OF
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE IMPORTANT
FOR THE COLLEGE TO HAVE. AND YOU
KNOW LABOR IS IT IS A CRITICAL
PARTNER FOR US THAT'S TRUE IN
TERMS OF. AND THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING PROGRAMMATIC LEE
WITH THAT CA YOU AND IT'S
EQUALLY TRUE OF THE LABOR
REPRESENTATION THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES ENJOY A FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND- AT CSEA. THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. BUT LV ENDS ARE-
BEING TRAINED NOW BY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT DO
YOU HAVE LPN PROGRAMS NOT
COMPETENCY BASED ASYNCHRONOUS
SKILLS BASED PROGRAMS NOT THOSE
WITH A CLINICAL PLACEMENT
PARTNERS SO THERE'S MANY
IMPORTANT AREAS OF
DIFFERENTIATION. AND THEY'RE
SEVERE UNDER PRODUCTION TO IN
TERMS OF THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
THEMSELVES. BUT WHAT I'M HOPEFUL
IS- IN TERMS OF THE WAY THAT
WE'RE DESIGNING THE PARTNERSHIP
IS THERE'S ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONNECT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT HAD THE OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE FACED.
WITH RESPECT TO- HAVING MORE
SCALABLE OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN
THOSE PROGRAMS A CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AT FIRST FOR EXAMPLE
TEND TO BE A BOTTLENECK IN THIS
AREA AND IF WE LOOK AT PROGRAMS
IN THE L. THE END SPACE THAT
ARE. AT PARTICULARLY- IN THE
QUEUE FOR APPROVAL FOR EXAMPLE-
WHAT WE FIND IS MANY OF THEM ARE
NOT ACTUALLY AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO THIS CAN BE A VERY
SUPPORTIVE MECHANISMS WHERE WE
SEE AND THAT INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF CLINICAL PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT FLAT FRONT LINE HEALTH
CARE WORKER ROLE AND IT'S ALSO
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO PARTNER
WITH OTHER COMMUNITY. IS WHO ARE
ALSO AT YOU NEED IN THAT REGARD
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN BE BUILT
HERE THAT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO
THE WHOLE SYSTEM WE'RE WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
YEAH WELL I WOULD SAY THAT IN
CAN. FOR ME AND MY QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. I AS A AS A TEACHER.
WAS VERY SKEPTICAL ABOUT THE
PROGRAM AT THE OUTSET. BECAUSE
AS I THINK THE CHAIR. HAS
MENTIONED. THAT THIS GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE HIRED TO
TRAIN. BECAUSE PERHAPS BECAUSE
OF NOT HAVING A LOT OF EDUCATION
. RIGHT THE IDEA OF DOING IT
ONLINE- WITHOUT A LOT OF-
PERSONAL CONTACT TO ME DIDN'T
DIDN'T SEEM TO JIVE YOU KNOW WHO
THE STUDENTS WERE AND THE METHOD
OF DELIVERY. AND THAT WAS A PRE
PANDEMIC PRE GOING WAY UP ONLINE
SO I WAS VERY SKEPTICAL CRITICAL
- AND OPPOSE- THE PROGRAM AT THE
OUTSET. WE'RE WE'RE NOW- AS BEEN
POINTED OUT- FOUR YEARS IN AT
LEAST INTO THE FUNDING OF IT- WE
SEE THE NUMBERS IN FRONT OF US-
I WOULD GIVE YOU THAT THERE BEEN
SOME IMPROVEMENTS I SOME
IMPROVEMENTS SINCE THE ADDED-
CERTAINLY- ADMINISTRATIVELY
WE'VE SEEN. MUCH IMPROVEMENT-
THERE AT LEAST WITH THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE- WELL GRATEFUL FOR
THAT- BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY
. IT DOES COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE. IN FUNDING AND TO
MAKE DECISIONS TO MAKE DECISIONS
ON WHERE WE SPEND OUR MONEY AND-
WHERE WE THINK WE GET MORE OF
FOR OUR MONEY- AND WHERE THE
STUDENTS DO SO- AGAIN WE'RE
FACED WITH WITH WITH THE NUMBERS
WERE FACED WITH HAVING TO MAKE
THOSE KIND OF DISTANCE. I REMIND
MY COLLEAGUES THAT I STILL HAVE-
IN THE IN THE WORKS BUT
LEGISLATION. THAT WOULD CALL FOR
THE END OF COUNT RIGHT- IT'S AN-
FORGET EXACTLY WHERE IT IS BUT-
I SHARE MY COLLEAGUES- CONCERNS.
THAT I'VE EXPRESSED OVER THE
YEARS AND OUT I'M NOT CONVINCED
THAT IT IS THE BEST USE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS- VERY
LIMITED RESOURCES WHEN IT COMES
TO EDUCATION. THANK MR LEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- I'LL
I'LL BE BRIEF JUST BECAUSE I'M
RUNNING BETWEEN COMMITTEES BUT I
DO APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK YOU
AND YOUR TEAM ARE DOING LIKE I
SAID LAST YEAR YOU KNOW YOU ARE
HANDED A- A HAND THAT IS THAT IS
NOT FAVORABLE IN THIS REGARD
AND- I CERTAINLY WAS NOT HERE
WHEN CALVERT WAS INSTITUTED BUT
STILL WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN A FAN
OF EVEN PRE PANDEMIC I THINK
REALLY WHAT OUR INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING EVEN ARCADE AS
WELL THE TWO CATIONS SESSION OF
FIGURING OUT AS THEY CAN HAVE
THE MEDITATION OF ONLINE
LEARNING AND SOMETIMES I THINK
WITH THE COMMUNITY ROOTED FOCUS
OF EACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THEY
ARE MORE PREDISPOSITION TO BE A
GATEWAY ACCESS OF VISUAL
LEARNING HAVING MORE FLEXIBILITY
I'M ALL FOR FREE I'M ALL FOR
EXPERIMENTATION FIGURE OUT NEW
THINGS CAN TRY THESE THINGS BUT
I THINK EVEN IN THE SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME GIVEN THE RESULTS WERE
SAYING IT'S NOT QUITE THE
RESULTS YOU WANT TO SEE AND AT
THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW REAL LIFE
HAS ALSO CAUGHT UP IN THAT SENSE
THE PANDEMIC SHOWED EVERYONE
ELSE WITH DIGITAL EDUCATIONAL
CLEAR DEAL ACCESS COULD LOOK
LIKE AND AGAIN THAT'S OUT OF
YOUR CONTROL YOU'RE TRYING TO
YOUR DO YOUR BEST WITH THE CARDS
YOU'RE DEALT. I STILL DON'T
THINK I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TO
THIS YEAR SO I SUPPORT OUR
COLLEAGUES EFFORTS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN REALLOCATE THESE
RESOURCES ESPECIALLY INTO
EXISTING FROM COLLEGE- SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW THERE'S SO MANY
STUDENTS IN NEED RIGHT NOW AND I
THINK INSTEAD OF HAVING A NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN JUST REINVEST
IN THE OLD INFRASTRUCTURE AND
AGAIN I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING YOUR TEAM AND I
THINK YOU'RE STE YOUR QUESTION
ON IT BUT AGAIN. DEALT WITH SOME
TOUGH TOUGH HAND RIGHT THERE BUT. I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
HAVING TODAY. THANK YOU. FOR THE
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPENED- FOR THE SENATE ACTUALLY
IS NO. YEAH WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
UP AND COME BACK AFTER MAY
REVISING GO BACK TO THAT THE
GENDER ISSUE NUMBER TWO THANK
YOU COMMUNITY COLLEGE
APPORTIONMENT FUNDING FORMULA.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN DAN HAD OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO START
I WOULD LIKE TO SIGNAL THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA OR SCF
. EVEN TO THE VOLATILE FISCAL
CONDITIONS POSED BY THE LAST FEW
YEARS THE FORMULA HAS PROVED
RESILIENT AND A STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR THE COLLEGES. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES THE
STATUTORY- I SEE IF HAVE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT OF FIVE POINT
THREE THREE PERCENT. WHICH
TRANSLATES TO FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINE POINT FOUR MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. FURTHER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
POINT 5% ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
COMING TO TWENTY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS IS MORE OF
A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT IT
PROVIDES FUNDING WHICH CAN BE
USED BY DISTRICTS THAT HAPPENED
TO BE GROWING- AND ANY UNUSED
GROWTH FUNDING IS POTENTIALLY
AVAILABLE TO COVER INCREASES TO
A DISTRICTS SUPPLEMENTAL SUCCESS
ALLOCATIONS. THE ADMINISTRATION
REMAINS FOCUSED ON MOVING
TOWARDS FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FUNDING FORMULA. AS SUCH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED A
GRADUAL PHASE OUT TO THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION OF THE SCF.
THE EXISTING WILL THOMAS
PROVISION IS SLATED TO EXPIRE
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO CREATE A FUNDING FOR
USING TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE FUNDING LEVELS. ALLOWING
FUNDING RATES TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE BY THE STATUTORY COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT. BUT
REMOVING APPLICATION OF THE CODE
TO THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. OBJECTIVELY THIS
APPROACH ALLOWS DISTRICTS TO
TRANSITION TO THE CORE FUNDING
pFORMULA OVER TIME. OR PREVENTING
PHYSICAL THE CLIENTS BETWEEN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
AT TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. THE EIGHT PAGES OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO SIGNAL
INTEREST IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
TO INCLUDE FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS WITHIN THE SUPPLEMENTAL
ALLOCATION OF THE SCF. IN LINE
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION MADE BY
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
ONCE A RELIABLE AND STABLE DATA
SOURCE IS AVAILABLE. ABOUT IT
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THAT THESE INVESTMENTS OKAY
THANK YOU L. L. THANK YOU AUSTIN
HOUSING AGAIN WITH THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AS YOUR GENDER DENOTES
THE COST OF LIVING RATE FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. IS
LIKELY TO BE HIGHER THAN THE
FIVE POINT 33% PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OUR OFFICE
ESTIMATES ABOUT A SIX POINT 2%
OF THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT- RATE WHICH WOULD
COST ABOUT SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES IS IN HIS JANUARY
BUDGET. YOUR TURN A CARD IS YOU
POINTED OUT AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE HEARING. YOU HAVE A NUMBER
OF COST PRESSURES OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CURRENTLY
FIRST YOU HAVE- EMPLOYEES THEIR
OWN COST OF LIVING. HAS GONE UP
BECAUSE OF INFLATION SO THERE'S
PRESSURE ON DISTRICTS PROVIDE TO
PROVIDE PAY INCREASES. DISTRICTS
OF ALSO HAVE REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS THE PENSIONS AND THAT'S
EXPECTED TO GO UP BY ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. NOW DISTRICTS ARE
REALIZING SOME SAVINGS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
RUNNING AS MANY- COURSE SECTIONS
THERE'S SO THERE'S SOME SAVINGS
FROM PART TIME FACULTY NOT
NEEDING THOSE TEMPORARY FACULTY.
DUE TO LOWER- ENROLLMENT DEMAND.
RIGHT IF THAT TREND WERE TO
CONTINUE IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE DISTRICTS WILL CONTINUE TO
SEE SAVINGS THOUGH LIKELY NOT
ENOUGH TO OFFSET THE UPWARD
PRESSURE THE DISTRICTS ARE
EXPERIENCING IN THEIR BUDGETS.
SO WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
MAKE A DECISION ON A CALL THE
RATE. ONCE OF THE STATE GETS
UPDATED INFORMATION- FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY
LATER THIS MONTH. AND THEN
LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT UPDATED CALL THE RATE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE WHERE THAT'S TRENDING
IT MAY REVISE AND MAKE A
DECISION THEN ON THE KOLA. WITH
REGARD TO THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA THE
APPORTIONMENT FUNDING FOR THE
COLLEGES- MISTER HAD OUR JUST
DESCRIBED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION. NOW WHEN THE STATE
CREATED THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF DISTRICTS IT
ENDED UP GENERATING LESS MONEY.
UNDER THE NEW FORMULA THAN UNDER
THE OLD FORMULA AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE AGREED TO PROVIDE
TEMPORARY FUNDING TO THOSE
DISTRICTS THESE. SO CALLED HOLD
HARMLESS FUNDING TO HELP THEM
TRANSITION TO GIVE THEM TIME TO
TRANSITION. NOW THE GOVERNOR HAS
A PROPOSAL HERE THAT'S INTENDED
TO PREVENT MANY DISTRICTS FROM
HITTING A FISCAL CLIFF IN A FEW
YEARS. THE STATE CURRENT HOLD
HARMLESS VISION IS SCHEDULED TO
END AND DISTRICTS ARE FUNDED
BASED ON THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA. SO WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF. SEVENTEEN A
FISCAL CLIFF FOR THESE DISTRICTS
IS LAUDABLE AT THE SAME TIME OF
BEING A HOLD HARMLESS DISTRICT
MEANS RECEIVING A PORTION OF
FUNDING REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
STUDENTS THE DISTRICT'S SERVICE.
REGARDLESS OF WHO THOSE STUDENTS
ARE REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOMES
OF THOSE STUDENTS SO BEING A
HOLD HARMLESS DISTRICT GETTING
MONEY NO MATTER WHAT REALLY
CREATES A POOR INCENTIVES ON
THOSE DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
SHOULD STRIVE TO GET DISTRICTS
OFFICE HOLD HARMLESS FUNDING.
AND FUNDED BASED ON THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. ONE WAY TO DO THAT
WOULD BE TO INCREASE THE VALUE
OF THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA THROUGH BASE INCREASES.
BEYOND THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AND SO WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S HOLD HARMLESS
PROVOKED PROPOSAL. BUT GO
FURTHER THAN THAT AND BEGIN
EXPLORING THE POSSIBILITY OF
RAISING THE BASE FUNDING FOR THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
SO THE DISTRICTS ARE GENERATING
MORE THROUGH IT THEN CURRENTLY.
SO LEGISLATURE COULD DO
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO WHAT IT DID
WITH THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WITH K. TWELVE SET A-
TARGET LEVEL OF BASE FUNDING.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE- FOR THE CALL DISTRICTS
FUNDED AT. AND THEN LOOK AT THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE SO LOOK AT THAT GROWTH
IN THE GUARANTEE AND THEN
DEVELOP A MULTI YEAR PLAN FOR
REACHING THOSE TARGETS. AND AT
HIGHER BASE ALSO HAS THE
ADVANTAGE OF HELPING DISTRICTS
ADDRESS A HIGHER OPERATING COSTS
. THE TWO OTHER- ITEMS IN THE
GENERAL THE SNOW VERY BRIEFLY-
FIRST WE DO WE ALSO AGREE WITH
THE GOVERNOR THAT ADDING FIRST
GENERATION METRIC TO THE
STUDENTS SENDING. CENTER FUNDING
FORMULA HAS MERIT- ONCE- THE
LEGISLATURE IS ABLE TO GET
BETTER DATA FROM THE DISTRICTS
ON FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS. WE
ALSO DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
ABOUT FORTY DISTRICTS THAT ARE
NOT ON A HOLD HARMLESS THERE
FUNDED BY THE STUDENT CENTERED
FORM FUNDING FORMULA BUT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY BEING PROTECTED BY
WHAT'S CALLED EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS ALLOWANCE. SO THIS IS
MONEY THAT THEY'RE GETTING DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC SO THEY'RE BEING
FUNDED AT PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS AS
IF THE PANDEMIC COULD NOT HIT.
WELL THAT DEALS THOSE EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS ALLOWANCES WHICH IS
AUTHORIZED BY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ARE SCHEDULED TO EXPIRE.
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR SO AT
THE END OF JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN
DISTRICTS WOULD HAVE KIND OF A
ONE YEAR TRANSITION PERIOD OF
AND STARTING IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. YOU TO HAVE A
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS TO START TO
SEE A REDUCTION IN THE FUNDING
LEVELS AND THEIR PORTION IT
FUNDING. SO THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANTED TO ADD REQUEST THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE. ON THESE EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS ALLOWANCE. WHAT
THEY'RE PLANNING TO DO IF THEY
DECIDED YET WHETHER TO EXTEND
NEIGHBORS TO CONDITIONS
ALLOWANCE FOR ANOTHER YEAR SO I
THINK THEY'LL BE VERY IMPORTANT
FOR LEGISLATORS OF. THE
LEGISLATURE TO THINK OF- IN THE
NEXT YEAR. AND CLOSING OUT THIS
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. GOOD MORNING
AGAIN WAS THAT NEVER WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULAS KEY PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO AN EQUITABLE
RECOVERY AS YOU KNOW THAT
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR ACCESS AND
ROMAN BASE FUNDING TO STUDENT
EQUITY BY TARGETING- FUNDS TO
DISTRICTS SERVING LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND FOR STUDENT SUCCESS
BY PROVIDING DISTRICTS WITH
RESOURCES FOR SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME
. I HEARD TO THE STUDENTS AND
THE FUNDING FORMULA DISTRICTS
WERE FUNDED ALMOST ENTIRELY BY
ENROLLMENT FUNDING SOMETHING
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN DISASTROUS
DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT WE'VE
LEARNED AS AN APPROACH THAT DID
NOT WORK. IT DOESN'T WORK FOR
ADVANCING THE STUDENTS FULL CHEN
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY BEYOND THE
INITIAL ENROLLMENT AND IT WOULD
NOT OF WORK IN THE MIDST OF
THESE- DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFTS THAT
WE'RE SEEING ACROSS THE STATES-
WHEN DISTRICTS HAVE SEEN
ENROLLMENT DECLINES EVEN BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC- EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC DISTRICTS WERE EXPECTED
TO LOSE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AND
YOU TO ENROLLMENT DECLINES SO
THE S. C. EFFORT RECOGNIZES THAT
A COLLEGES WORK ENCOMPASSES-
MORE THAN JUST ENROLLMENT. AND
CRITICAL ACADEMIC AND STUDENT
SUPPORT POINTS ALONG THEIR
JOURNEY. WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR FUNDING
FLOOR AND THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS
CHAIN PROVIDES DISTRICTS WITH
STABILITY- AS THEY WORK TO RE
ENGAGE CALIFORNIA AND- FURTHER
ON THE DRIVING TENANTS OF THE
SCF OF ACCESS EQUITY AND
SUCCESS. MORE RELEVANT THAN EVER
AND REMIND US THAT STUDENTS COME
FIRST. UNDER THE SCF WE'RE
BEGINNING TO SEE- SOME EARLY
INDICATORS THAT SHOW THAT-
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATE DEGREES. FOR
TRANSFER COMPLETIONS BY LOW
INCOME STUDENTS HAVE INCREASED
BY ROUGHLY THIRTY FIVE PERCENT.
WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE IN-
TRANSFER LEVEL ENGLISH AND MATH-
FOR FIRST GENERATE FOR FIRST
YEAR LOW INCOME STUDENTS THAT
SIXTY NINE PERCENT. AND EVEN
LARGER GAINS OF 89% FOR PELL
RECIPIENTS- AND 90% INCREASE.
FOR POP PROMISE GRANT
RECIPIENTS. STAY WIDE LIVING
WAGES FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ARE ALSO UP BY 20% I ALSO WANT
TO COMMEND COMMITTEE STAFF THEY
PROVIDED AN EXCELLENT ANALYSIS
AND SOUND RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
OTHER APPROACHES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN INCLUDE- CAN
CONSIDER SPECIFICALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A POINT THAT INCREASE
IN THE SCFA BASE RATE WOULD HELP
COLLEGES IN ADDRESSING SEVERAL
CHALLENGES. NOT ONLY WHAT A
HIGHER BASE RIGHT HELP DISTRICTS
RESPOND TO RISING STAFF AND
FACULTY COSTS AND PENSION
PRESSURES BUT IT COULD HELP
DISTRICTS FACING ENROLLMENT TO
CRY DECLINES TO SOFTEN THAT
ASSOCIATED FUNDING. ONE SOLUTION
IS A- CONSIDERATION OF A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION INCREASE- TO
THE- BASIC ALLOCATION IN THE
FORM OF A TECH BASIC TO
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE
CLARA MANAGING NOW AND DO ALL
CAMPUSES THAT ARE BOTH BRICK AND
MORTAR- AND CLOUDBASE
INSTITUTIONS. WE REMAIN FOCUSED
ON THE STUDENT'S JOURNEY AS A
NORTH STAR I LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU IN THE NEXT
MONTH IS HE FINALIZED THIS ITEM
. THANK YOU HAVE ANSWERED THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU MISTER DONNA
. YES SIR THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATIONS- JUST
A COUPLE COMMENTS HERE I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND I'M A FIRM
BELIEVER THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT
IT A FIRM BELIEVER THAT WE NEED
TO SUPPORT IT BETTER THAN WE
HAVE. AND ONE WAY TO DO THAT IS
TO FUND IT ADEQUATELY AND I LOOK
AT THE PROPOSED BUDGET. IT WAS
IN JANUARY S. AND I REALIZE THIS
IS A PROCESS. BUT A FIVE POINT
33% COAL IS WOEFULLY. INADEQUATE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE- THAT GOES
FOR THE K. TWELVE SIDE TO- AND
WHY IS IT. WAS AND HOW IT WHAT I
KEEP HEARING OUR HISTORIC
NUMBERS A STORE NUMBERS HISTORIC
NOT A HISTORIC INCREASE. THAT
MATCHES- YOU KNOW HAVE. HISTORIC
INFLATION. RIGHT THAT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN IN FORTY YEARS. SO THAT
FIVE POINT 33% DOESN'T EVEN MEET
INFLATION. LOOK WHAT'S GOING ON
OUT THERE IF YOU TAKE THE- THE
SCHOOL COST PRICE AND ACCESS MY
OWN LITTLE ANIMAL I'VE CREATED I
KNOW OTHERS HAVE THEIR OWN
DEVICES BUT YOU TAKE. FIVE POINT
THREE THREE AS THE OFFER IN THE
IN THE JANUARY PROPOSED BUDGET
THAT IS NOW IN OUR HANDS. FROM
THE GOVERNOR. IF YOU LOOK AT CPI
5% PLUS. STIRS IN PERSIAN MIX
SOMEONE AVERAGE GET TWO POINT
THREE FIVE. AND THEN YOU COME UP
TO MAYBE 4% OTHER COSTS THAT ARE
UNIQUE. TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
DECLINING ENROLLMENT SAID RIGHT
NOW THERE'S SOME HELP THERE ON
THE DECLINE IN ROMA- BUT- EASILY
YOU'RE PROBABLY AT ABOUT 13%
PLUS. COST PRESSURES MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FROM LAST
YEAR TO THIS YEAR SO FIVE POINT
33% IS WAY TOO LOW AND THIS
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO ADDRESS
THAT- I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AROUND THE HOLD
HARMLESS AND I THINK THE IDEA
HERE. THE MECHANISM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED IN THE
BUDGET IS REALLY A SLOPE MORE
THAN A CLIFF. SOMETHING WE'RE
SEEING A BIT ON THE K. TWELVE
SIDE AS WELL. YEAH I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
TARGETING THE FUNDING ON A PER
STUDENT LEVEL BUT I A TARGET. IS
REALLY. UPROMISE AND DOLLARS ARE
A COMMITMENT. AND WE CAN'T GET A
JUST JUST SETTING UP TARGETS
THAT WE MIGHT OR MIGHT NOT MEET.
ARE MORE ASPIRATIONAL. THAN THEY
ARE REALITY AND SO THIS YEAR WE
HAVE MORE MONEY MORE ON GOING
MONEY AND WE SHOULD PUTTHAT IS
IT INTO THE BASE. SO THAT WE CAN
FIND EVERY COMMITTEE COLLEGE
EVERY COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
ADEQUATELY. IT'S A NO BRAINER I
MEAN NO CATEGORY BECAUSE WE
DON'T NEED THAT THIS YEAR HEY.
HEY HEY THE CLAREMONT. WE CAN
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION BUT AGAIN
. PUT THE MONEY INTO THE BASE SO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN DO
THE WORK SERVE THE STUDENTS AND
MOVE THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
FORWARD. THANK YOU. OKAY I DON'T
DISAGREE AND THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE HEAR FROM OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- LOBBY GAME IS
THAT RIGHT AS YOU KNOW YOU'RE
YOU GUYS ARE ON MESSAGE YOUR
HUNDRED PLUS DISTRICTS IN
CONTACT ALL OF US AND SAY THE
SAME THING AND FOCUSING ON THAT.
INADEQUATE COLAS IS IT IS A
THING WE HEAR- THE MOST AND SO
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE WILL
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION LOOK
WHAT. HAVE SO FAR AS PROP NINETY
EIGHT REVENUES AFTER. WE GET THE
MARY VICE. REVENUE PROJECTIONS.
SO HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN ISSUE
NUMBER THREE PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH INSURANCE PROPOSAL. DAN
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- IN
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE FOR
AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE HE
COMMITTED TO CONSIDERING OPTIONS
TO BETTER SUPPORT PART TIME
FACULTY WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
TO BUILD A COMMITMENT WITH THE
INVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND INTO
THE PART TIME FACULTY HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM. THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS THAT THIS
INVESTMENT WILL PROVIDE A STRONG
FISCAL INCENTIVES FOR DISTRICTS
AUTHOR HEALTH INSURANCE TO MORE
OF THEIR PART TIME FACULTY WHILE
STILL PROVIDING LOCAL CONTROL
AND FLEXIBILITY ON OF
MEDITATION- WITHOUT HAVING AN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT THIS ABOUT. THANK YOU
ELENA SO IS YOUR JANET NOTES IN
HIS MOST AT HANOVER JUST MENTION
THE GOVERNOR WOULD LIKE TO
EXPAND HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
PART TIME FACULTY AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOU PART TIME
FACULTY ARE A CRITICAL PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE STATE HAS A
REAL INTEREST IN MAKING SURE.
THAT THEY'RE TAKEN CARE OF. WE
DO NOTE THAT WITH THIS PURPOSE.
THAT LEGISLATURE LACKS BASS OF
BASIC INFORMATION TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION. ON THIS
PROPOSAL. THE LEGISLATURE
CURRENTLY DOES NOT KNOW HOW MANY
FACULTY PART TIME FACULTY
ALREADY HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
AND WHERE THEY GET THAT
INSURANCE FROM THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO DOESN'T KNOW HOW MANY PART
TIME FACULTY LACK. HEALTH CARE
INSURANCE BUT DESPITE THE
STATE'S REQUIREMENT THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ADEQUATE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SO WITHOUT
THIS BASIC INFORMATION IT'S
REALLY NOT POSSIBLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE IF
THERE'S A PROBLEM AND HOW
WIDESPREAD THAT PROBLEM MIGHT
BE. THE. HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO
PART TIME FACULTY BUT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS LIMITED
INFORMATION CURRENTLY ON THE
EXTENT OF THAT COVERAGE AT
DISTRICT PROVIDED COVERAGE. AND
THE COST THAT DISTRICTS ARE
PASSED ON TO EMPLOYEES OR MAKE
EMPLOYEES CHARGING WHETHER SOME
PART TIME FACULTY MIGHT IN FACT
HAVE BEEN BETTER OFF GETTING
THEIR HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
THROUGH COVERED CALIFORNIA WHICH
PROVIDES SUBSIDIES FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS. THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH TO PROVIDING HEALTH
CARE TO PART TIME FACULTY
THROUGH DISTRICT SPONSORED
PLANS- SHOULD ALSO BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT- GIVEN THAT PART TIME
FACULTY ARE CONSIDERED TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES AND I MENTIONED THAT
IN THE PREVIOUS ISSUE THEY'RE
CONSIDERED TEMPORARY M. DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES. THEY MAY NOT BE
RETAIN FROM ONE SEMESTER TO THE
NEXT FOR ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT
AND SO EVEN IF A DISTRICT THEIR
DISTRICT WERE TO OFFER ROBUST
COVERAGE TO PART TIME FACULTY
THE LEGISLATURE FACES THE POLICY
QUESTION. OF WHETHER. THIS KEEPS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM REALLY
IS THE BEST WAY TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. GIVEN THAT
YOU COULD HAVE PART TIME FACULTY
WORKING FOR A DISTRICT BECAUSE
THEY NEEDED TO TEACH CLASSES
THERE ON HEALTHCARE AND THEN
THEY'RE TOLD THEY'RE NOT NEEDED
FOR THE NEXT SEMESTER THE NEXT
YEAR AND THEY MIGHT BE OFF THE
INSURANCE AT THAT POINT THAT
COULD BE VERY DISRUPTIVE AND
UNSTABLE. FOUR THESE IN TE
EMPLOYEES USE TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
OF COURSE THERE'S A QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT ABOUT PART TIME
FACULTY PART TIME EMPLOYEES
RATHER WORKING- IN OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND LOCAL AGENCIES. SO
WE RECOMMEND- THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT ADMINISTRATION TO GET
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
INSURED STATUS A PART TIME
FACULTY. AND ON PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTH CARE PLANS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY OFFERED BY
DISTRICTS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION TO
WORK WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES
TOGETHER SIMILAR INFORMATION ON
PART TIME EMPLOYEES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND THE LEGISLATURE
COULD GIVE THE ADMINISTRATION
UNTIL MAYBE THE FALL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO SUBMIT THIS
INFORMATION AND THEN
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE COULD
USE THAT INFORMATION. TO REALLY
HELP BUILD- THE TO GATHER
INFORMATION USE IT TO MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF TO INFORM
POTENTIAL BUDGET DECISIONS FOR
NEXT BUDGET YEAR ONCE THIS
INFORMATION REALLY IS SOLID AND
WE HAVE A MUCH BETTER IDEA OF
THE EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM. THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU CAN ANY
COLLEGES GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE A ROBUST
INVESTMENT IN PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH AT FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND WE'VE LONG BEEN
UNDER INVESTING IN HEALTH FOR A
PART TIME FACULTY WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO QUALITY
CARE I BELIEVE THAT THIS
INVESTMENT IS LONG OVERDUE.
FOLLOWING EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH DISTRICTS IN FACULTY
PARTNERS WE DO BELIEVE THAT AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THE PROGRAM
OVERALL IS A WARRANTED- ONE THAT
WOULD PROVIDE ON A GREATER-
HEALTH REIMBURSEMENT RATIO
CURRENTLY DISTRICTS CAN ONLY BE
REIMBURSED 50% FOR THEIR
EXPENDITURES AND PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTH THIS LIMITS THE
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN PART
TIME FACULTY HEALTH PROGRAMS OR
LIMITS THE FEASIBILITY OF
OFFERING QUALITY PROGRAMS. THIS
SPECIFICALLY HE WE WOULD REQUEST
THAT THE PROGRAM- I
CONSIDERATION OF ALLOWING A 100%
REIMBURSEMENT FOR QUALITY
HEALTHCARE- PLANS PROVIDED TO
PART TIME FACULTY DISTRICTS
DISTRICTS WOULD ALSO CONSIDER-
MAKING ELIGIBLE REIMBURSEMENTS
AND HELP STATEMENT STATEMENTS
FOR THE PART TIME FACULTY WHO
DEMONSTRATE PARTICIPATION IN
COVERED CALIFORNIA INSTEAD OF
THE DISTRICT PLAN BUT OVERALL WE
ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND BELIEVE
THIS IS THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THANK YOU HAVE AN ANSWER
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU. SO
HOW WILL THIS WORK WITH TWO
HUNDRED MILLION STATEWIDE IN
YOUR- DISTRICTS IN ITS- GRANT
PROGRAM FIRST COME FIRST SERVE
HOW YOU HAVE YOUR DIFFERENT
COLLEGES PARTICIPATED CURRENTLY
THE PROGRAM WORKS FOR THE
COLLEGES WILL APPLY FOR
REIMBURSEMENT- AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THIRTY THREE DISTRICTS THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING- AND THEY
SUBMIT EVIDENCE OF HOW MANY
INDIVIDUAL THEY PROVIDED-
HEALTH. PLANS TO OF THE COST AND
THEN WE HAVE REIMBURSE THEM- FOR
A 50% OF THOSE- AND DIVIDE OUT
RIGHT NOW WE ONLY HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE PROGRAM SO
THEY'RE GETTING A CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR FOR THEIR REIMBURSEMENT-
THIS WOULD ALLOW- MORE TO
PARTICIPATE. AS THEY WOULD SEE
AN INCENTIVE AND ACTUALLY AND
JOINING AND BEING PART OF THE
PROGRAM. SO PAID US A PICTURE OF
A HYPOTHETICAL OF HOW THIS WOULD
IMPACT A PART TIME. MANY COLLEGE
FACULTY MEMBER IN THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE OF LOOK WHAT THEY HAVE
NOW WHERE THEY PAY WHAT THEY GET
AND WITH THIS POTENTIALLY. WELL
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THEM.
CURRENTLY NOT ALL DISTRICTS
OFFERED THE PROGRAMS AND SOME
THAT DO OFFER HEALTH- A
REIMBURSEMENT. DON'T PARTICIPATE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET
ENOUGH BACK BUT THOSE THAT DO-
WILL OFFER UP TO A CERTAIN
AMOUNT- IN COVERAGE. OF FOR
THEIR WORK- AND- THAT COULD
INCLUDE A HEALTH OR DENTAL- AND
THEN THE EMPLOYEE PAYS A PORTION
THE DISTRICT PAYS ANOTHER
PORTION. ARE AND OF WHAT THIS
COULD DO- IS CREATE. INCENTIVES
FOR BETTER QUALITY HEALTH OF
PROGRAMS FOR A PART TIME
FACULTY. AND THEN MORE DISTRICTS
TO PARTICIPATE FOR US TO ALSO
HAVE MORE ROBUST DATA ON HOW
MANY ARE PARTICIPATING IN HOW
MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING
SERVED WHAT KINDS OF. PLANS
THEY'RE OFFERING- WHAT KIND OF
COVERAGE- AND A VARIETY OF OTHER
KEY METRICS MMHM. SO AS IT IT
TALKS ON ABOUT HALF OF THE
DISTRICTS CURRENTLY PARTICIPATE
. SO WILL THIS WILL YOU FOCUS ON
THE DISTRICTS THAT DON'T
CURRENTLY PARTICIPATE FOR THE
ONES THAT DO AND HELP THEM
EXPAND THEIR- PROGRAMS. WE WOULD
FOCUS ON BOTH WITH THE FIRST
FOCUSING ON THOSE THAT AREN'T
PARTICIPATING BUT ALSO THOSE
THAT DO PARTICIPATE SO THAT-
MORE FACULTY ARE OFFERED THIS
ACROSS THE STATE HOME BASED ON
WHAT WE KNOW AND WHAT IS
AVAILABLE TO US THERE ARE OVER
THIRTY ONE ON FILE THIRTY ONE
HUNDRED. FACULTY THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO IT'S NOT A LOT- THAT
WE KNOW BUT THIS AGAIN COULD
CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR MORE TO
OFFER THE PROGRAM AND MORE TO
MORE FACULTY TO HAVE PART TIME
FACULTY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
QUALITY CARE. OKAY MISTER
O'DONNELL. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO DO WE KNOW HOW MANY
PART TIME FACULTY THERE ARE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. WE I
DON'T RECALL OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD AND I DON'T WANT TO GIVE
YOU WRONG NUMBER BUT GIVE ME.
JUST A SECOND OKAY GIVE ME THAT
NUMBER BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO KNOW.
BUT HOW THE NUMBER GOES INTO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT.
DO SOME MATH HERE- I GOT A
SUMMER PARTICIPATING NOW BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME LIKE THIS TO THIS
TOUR IS A LOT OF MONEY ONGOING
RIGHT TO UNDER MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING RIGHT- IT SEEMS TO ME
LIKE WE DO IT WE SEEM TO DO
EVERYTHING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO NOT HIRE PEOPLE
FULL TIME. SO NOW WE'RE GONNA
GET BENEFITS FOR WORKING PART
TIME WHY NOT JUST HIRE THEM FULL
TIME. IT'S JUST SEEMS TO ME LIKE
WE JUST. IN OUR LIVES IN THEIR
OWN HOUSE LOOKING FOR THE CORNER
AND THE CORNERS REALLY HIRING
PEOPLE FULL TIME IT'S A NO
BRAINER TO ME WANTED TO HIRE
THEM FULL TIME GIVEN THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY DESERVE. AS A
FULL TIME EMPLOYEE- SO AGAIN I
I'M I'M STILL STRUGGLING WITH
THIS TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
CONCEPT BECAUSE IT'S A PATCH NOT
A FIX. THANK YOU. I CANNOT THANK
YOU L. A. L. JUST TO RESPOND TO
MR O'DONNELL- IT'S ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND PART TIME FACULTY
OKAY CURRENTLY IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND- WHAT'S
ON OUR TO SUMMER WORKING JUST.
ONE CLASS SUMMER OFFERING YOU
TWO OR THREE CLASSES- BUT JUST
TO THE POINT WHERE MAKING
EARLIER IT'S JUST NOT KNOWN
RIGHT NOW HOW MANY OF THOSE
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE RIGHT WHERE THEY GET
IT FROM HOW MANY DON'T. RIGHT
THERE'S A LOT LOGISTICS HERE TO
IF I COULD MISTER JR THERE'S A
LOT OF LOGISTICS HERE TO FIGURE
OUT WE SOME MIGHT BE FULL TIME
SOMEWHERE ELSE. RIGHT WATER
EITHER TEACHING OR NOT TEACHING
THEY MIGHT COMMITTEE EACH ONE
CLASS BECAUSE THEY JUST WANT TO
TEACH ONE CLASS. I DON'T WANT
THE HEALTH INSURANCE THAT'S
RIGHT A LOT ARE THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'VE HEARD ANECDOTALLY TALKING
WITH DISTRICTS- AND THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS YOU KNOW START IS
LOOKING INTO THIS AND- TRYING TO
DO SOME SURVEYS. ABOUT YOU KNOW
THAT THE NUMBER OF THAT PART
TIME FACULTY TO GET THEIR
HEALTHCARE ALREADY FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE LOOKS LIKE IT'S A
FAIRLY LARGE PERCENTAGE BUT
AGAIN THAT'S SOMETHING THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE RELAX INSTEAD OF
STANDING HELP WHAT WHAT IS THE
PROBLEM EXACTLY HOW WIDESPREAD
IS IT BUT I JUST. IF THE FREEWAY
FLYER THING WE'VE GOT GOING ON
ACROSS THE STATE SOME OF OUR
PART TIMERS ARE NOT FREQUENT
FLYERS RIGHT THEY JUST TEACH ONE
OR TWO CLASSES BECAUSE- THAT'S
ALL THEY WANT TO TEACH. NOW
OTHERS. OUR TEACHING TWENTY
UNITS BECAUSE EGYPT. COLLEGES
RIGHT BOUNCING AROUND EVERY DAY.
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW WE FIGURE
THIS OUT LOGISTICALLY OTHER THAN
HIRE PEOPLE FULL TIME. THANK YOU
. OKAY DR CHOI. YUP MYSELF FIVE
FOR THE PART TIME AS A ADAM
FACULTY FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS AT
THE PORCELAIN COLLEGES TO TEACH
KOREAN LANGUAGE- IT WAS OKAY
BECAUSE THERE WAS ONLY ONE ONE
ONE CLASS- IF WHAT. BERMAN I
THINK THE BOTTOM LINE OF
QUESTION IS THAT THE- IF-
COMMENDATORY JEWS ARE HIRING
PART TIME AT JIM FACTORS T. IS
UP. TO SAVE- UP MONEY FOR PAYING
BENEFITS BY HIRING FOR TIME
YEAH- IF THIS OF COURSE IS A ONE
IN ONE LIMITED TOWARDS- THAT'S
OKAY BUT- IF- FOR EXAMPLE IF I
THAT WAS SAID IN SPANISH CLASS
OF WHICH WAS- MORE POPULAR AND
THE MANY COURSES ARE BEING
OFFERED THAN ONE INSTRUCTOR CAN
TEACH SEVERAL COURSES AND A
QUALIFIED ENOUGH UP FOR TIME
STAGGERS. BUT THE I WONDER IF IN
THAT SITUATION HAPPEN IS- YOU
YOU PROVIDE THE FOUR TIME
OPPORTUNITY FOR MOST QUALIFIED
TO ALMOST A SENIOR PERSON TO
TAKE CARE OF ALL ONE TWO THREE
ALL COURSES- I THINK THAT THAT
IS SO REALLY DESIRABLE- SO THAT
THAT DEDICATED PERSON CAN
DEVELOP. THAT THE PROGRAM IN
THAT THE DEPARTMENT- AND EXPAND
THE WHOLE FREELY- RATHER THAN
HIRING. THREE DIFFERENT UP PART
TIME PEOPLE. FOR IN THE SAME
DISAPPROVE I THINK THAT IS ALL
SO I THINK OF THE US OF WHAT. WE
HAVE THE QUESTION THAT THE TIME. DO YOU WANT A RESPONSE THAT
TECH. YEAH OKAY. WELL. I THINK
IF YOU TALK TO COLLEGES WILL SAY
THERE'S SOME. REASONS WHY THEY-
LIKE TO HAVE PART TIME FACULTY
IT'S SEPARATE FROM SAVING MONEY
THEY LIKE THE FLEXIBILITY HAVING
A PART TIME FACULTY THEY'RE NOT
SURE IF THE HOW MANY COURSES ARE
GOING TO NEED OR HOW LONG
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED THAT
PROGRAM SO THEY DON'T NEED TO
HAVE- TENURE AND YOU FIND A SPOT
FOR THAT- FACULTY FOR THE NEXT
THIRTY YEARS ALSO YOU CAN GET A
GET EXPERTISE YOU YOU MIGHT HAVE
SOMEBODY IN THE COMMUNITY WHO IS
AN EXPERT IN A CERTAIN AREA. YU
CAN BRING THEM ON MAYBE THEY
DON'T WANT A FULL TIME JOB AT
THE COLLEGE BUT THEY'RE WILLING
TO HELP AND TEACH- BUT YOU'RE AT
THE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT THERE
ARE. REASONS WHY YOU WANT. FULL
TIME FACULTY YOU NEED THE FULL
THE FULL TIME FACULTY FOR THAT
STABILITY TO BUILD THE PROGRAM
MAINTAIN THE PROGRAM. WORK ON A
SERVICE TO THE COLLEGE. AND HI
ANYONE HIRING DEVELOP THE
CURRICULUM DEVELOP THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH INDUSTRY. AND
SO THAT'S SOMETHING COLLEGES-
PRODUCT STRUGGLE WITH IS HOW
MANY PART TIMERS VERSUS HOW MANY
FULL TIMERS JUSTO HARKEN BACK TO
THE EARLIER ISSUE WE HAD
RECOMMENDED INCREASING BASE
FUNDING FOR THE COLLEGES AND ONE
ONE OF THE- ADVANTAGES OF THAT
COULD BE YOU MORE MONEY TO THE
COLLEGES COULD HELP THEM THE
POTENTIALLY HIRE MORE FULL TIME
FACULTY AND HAVE MORE FULL TIME
FACULTY IF THAT'S IN FACT WHAT.
WHAT THEY THINK IS THE BEST WAY
TO MOVE THERE- PROGRAMS FORWARD
AND KEEP THOSE PROGRAMS REVISED. THE STRONGLY- RECOMMEND US AND
WHEN. SURE ENOUGH FORCESOUT ONE
PART TIME- PERSON READY AND
WILLING AND QUALIFIED
INSTRUCTORS- TO WORK ITSELF FOR
THE TIME CAN TAKE CARE OF ALL
THAT THAT POLICIES SO I THINK
THAT THAT IS A MORE DESIRABLE-
BECAUSE THAT THAT PERSON MAY
PACKED AND THE VISIT THREE OF
THE FOUR DIFFERENT ENOUGH BUT
THE BUT THE COLLEGES ON CAMPUS
IS- IS- INSTRUCT ON THE FREEWAY
HE IN ALL KIND OF THINGS. SO- AT
IS SO CORD BY THE- WEATHER. THE
CAMPER. IS A- WE'RE TRYING. TO-
IMPLEMENT THAT KIND OF UP FOR
TIME JOB THAT THE PROGRAM IS
THERE ANY- THE CENTRALIZED- WHAT
THE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE CAN
SUPERVISE TWO OR OR STUDY WHY DO
WE HAVE A SO MANY YOU KNOW AT
CHEN- FACULTY MEMBERS AND- I
DON'T KNOW AT THIS TIME WITH
THOSE AT THE ANY MONITORING
SYSTEM. TO EVALUATE THE- IN THE
SAME DISCIPLINE TOO MANY ADS IN
FACT WAS DISAPPOINTING WHICH
COULD HAVE BEEN. A CONSOLIDATED
IN CONSOLIDATED INTO A FULL TIME
POSITION. YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW OKAY WE
KNOW IT CREDITORS LOOKING TO A
YOU KNOW FULL TIME PART TIME
FACULTY THAT I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A- YOUR REQUIREMENT I
THE STATE. ON HUNDRED PART TIME
FULL TIME RATIONS. OKAY. OKAY
THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OFTEN NEXT ISSUE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE CAPITAL OUTLAY.
AGAIN DEVIN OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND
FUNDING OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE MILLION ONE TIME
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF
SEVENTEEN PROJECTS ANTICIPATED
TO COMPLETE DESIGN BY SPRING
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND THE
WORKING DRAWING PHASE OF ONE
PROJECT. THIS ALLOCATION
REPRESENTS THE NEXT INSTALLMENT
OF THE TWO BILLION AVAILABLE TO
A COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNDER
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. TO SUPPORT DEFERED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS AT THE
CAMPUSES. THIS FUNDING WILL
BUILD ON THE FIVE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN MILLION INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT TO
FURTHER ADDRESS THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WITHOUT
HAVING TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU L. L. THANK YOU WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
GOT A WITH THE- CAPITAL OUTLAY-
PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN YOUR
AGENDA THESE ARE ALL CONTINUING
PROJECTS AND SEEM TO BE. ON TIME
AND ON BUDGET- IN ADDITION- AS
YOUR AGENDA NOTES WE ARE
ENCOURAGED TO SEE THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG FOR THE
SYSTEM ACTUALLY GO DOWN AS A
RESULT OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
FUNDING IN THE IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET SO THE BACKLOG
WAS IDENTIFIED ABOUT ONE POINT
SIX BILLION IT'S NOW ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS AGAIN
AS A RESULT OF A LOT OF THE
FUNDING GOING TO FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET. SO DEFERRED
SPENDING ONE TIME MONEY ON
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE THINK
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD USE OF ONE
TIME MONEY WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE STRIVE TO PROVIDE AT
LEAST AS MUCH AS WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING IN JANUARY.
IF THE PROPOSITION- NINETY
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IS HIGHER MAY REVISE
WHICH IS LIKELY- THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER PROVIDING EVEN
MORE FUNDING THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED IN JANUARY
WE ALSO THE ENCOURAGE A
LEGISLATURE DEVELOP TO DEVELOP A
LONG TERM STRATEGY FOR NOT JUST
PAIN. THE BACKLOG BUT ALSO
KEEPING IT FROM CREEPING BACK
UP- AS BUILDING SYSTEMS COME DUE
AND SO WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ON DEVELOPING A MULTI
YEAR PLAN FOR ADDRESSING THE
BACKLOG AND ADDRESSING
MAINTENANCE AS IT COMES DUE AND
FUNDING IT AS IT COMES DUE SO
THAT WE DON'T END UP WITH IT
ANOTHER BIG DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG IN SEVERAL YEARS FROM
NOW. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
HER CAN COLLEGE. GOOD MORNING
AGAIN WAS THAT EVER WITH THIS
CANCERS OFFICE- THANKS TO A
ROBUST TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
INVESTMENT FOR MAINTENANCE. AND
AS WAS MENTIONED THE BACKLOG HAS
BEEN REDUCED TO ONE POINT TWO
BILLION. STATE FUNDING HAS
PREVENTED THE BACKLOG FROM
GROWING THE EXTERNAL PRESSURES
SUCH AS INCREASED COST OF
CONSTRUCTION SUPPLIES. AND LABOR
HAVE MADE IT DIFFICULT- FOR THE
BACKLOG TO BE. ELIMINATED
COMPLETELY THAT WE MAKE
IMPORTANT STRIDES. THEREFORE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OF THAT CAN
COMMITTEE COLLEGES. CAN CONTINUE
TO MAKE PROGRESS TOWARD FULL
ELIMINATION OF THAT BACKLOG
ENSURING QUALITY AND SAFE
FACILITIES FOR STUDENTS FACULTY
AND STAFF. WITH REGARD TO
CAPITAL OUTLAY THE TEAMSTERS
OFFICE- LEADS- A COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS OF FACILITIES PROPOSALS
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND RECOGNITION
OF CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS AND
POPULATION TRENDS. THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS APPROVED CHANGES TO
THE SCORING METHODOLOGY AND
WE'RE EMPHASIZING MODERNIZATION
OVER GROWTH. AND CONSTRUCTION OF
NEW BUILDINGS THIS RESPONSIBLE
APPROACH ENSURES THAT COLLEGES
ARE MAXIMIZING THE RESOURCES-
THEY'RE USING- WHILE- USING
THEIR PHYSICAL FOOTPRINT
EFFECTIVELY. THE PROJECT BEFORE
YOU HAVE BEEN ESCORTED TO THIS
RUBRIC ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ENTERING OUR FINAL ROUND OF PROP
FIFTY ONE BOND FUNDING AN ABSENT
RESOURCES FUTURE PROJECTS WILL
NOT HAVE A DEDICATED. A SOURCE.
THANK YOU HAVE BEEN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY. THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU-
SLEAZE THIS IS THE I THINK
FINANCIALLY AS A THIS IS THE
LAST PHASE OF THAT PRIOR BOND
FUNDS VERY- YES. PLEASE YEAH.
SYSTEM THAT WE DON'T HAVE A NEW
BONDS OR IN A FUSION OF MONEY-
ONE TIME MONEY FOR CAPITAL
NEEDS. INCLUDED EXTINCT
EXTINGUISHED RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAPITAL PROJECTS RIGHT HERE AT
THE TIME. OKAY. FOLLOWING IS A
REMINDER FOR US AS WELL. AND
THEN WITH DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
OF COURSE IS ALWAYS A BALLOT
CIRCLES SO CERTAINLY SEE HOW
MUCH MONEY WE HAVE AFTER THAT.
THEY REALIZE IS COMPLETE. OKAY
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE STUDENTS
SUPPORT. PROPOSALS. DAN HAD OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- TO BEGIN
THIS PANEL I ONE OF THREE
PROPOSES THAT UTILIZE ONE TIME
RESOURCES TO SIMPLIFY THE
COLLEGE GOING AND TRANSFER
PRODUCTS VARIANTS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED AND
FIVE MILLION ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT COMMON COURSE NUMBER
AND- THIS INVESTMENT IS RELATED
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN. AND BUILDS UPON
THE INVESTMENT OF TEN MILLION
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A COMMON COURSE
NUMBING SYSTEM ACROSS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
SIXTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND.
FOR COLLEGES TO IMPLEMENT THE
TRANSFER FOR PROVISIONS OF
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT. THIRD
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO ASSIST COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. BUT THE PROCUREMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF SOFTWARE
THAT CLEARLY MAPS OUT ALL INTER
SEGMENTAL BURKE NOT TO INTERCEPT
OF CURRICULAR PATHWAYS. TO HELP
STUDENTS CHOOSE THEIR PATHWAY
THE SAUTEED TRANSFERRED TO IN
THE SEGMENTS AND REDUCE ACCESS
UNITS TAKEN ON ABOUT THE DEGREE
PROGRAM OR PROGRAM COMPLETION.
THESE PROPOSALS WILL BUILD UPON
ONGOING EFFORTS BY THE COLLEGES
TO IMPLEMENT THE GUIDED PATHWAYS
FRAMER. THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
RECOGNIZES THAT THE PANDEMIC AND
ENSUING RECESSION HAVE NOT
IMPACTED ALL GROUPS EQUALLY.
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
PERSISTENT LONG TERM EQUITY GAPS
HAVE EXISTED OF MOST IF NOT ALL
OF OUR STATES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AS SUCH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A SLATE OF NEW
INVESTMENTS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND WORK TOWARDS MEETING THE
MULTI YEAR ROADMAP GOAL OF
ELIMINATING EQUITY GAPS ACROSS
THE SYSTEM. IN PARTICULAR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TEN
MILLION ON GOING TO SUPPORT THE
NEXT UP PROGRAM TEN MILLION ON
GOING TO SUPPORT THE SUSTAINABLE
IMPLEMENTATION OF- YOU
COMPLIMENT OPPORTUNITY BEST
PRACTICES. TO DIVERSIFY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY STAFF
AND ADMINISTRATORS. TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME SUPPORT
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS TO ELIGIBLE AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS. ONE POINT ONE MILLION
ON GOING TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF- AMEND STUDENT
CHARTERS TO AN INCREASED NUMBER
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
AND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND ONE TIME TO SUPPORT. A
STUDY OF THE U. MOSHE PROGRAMS-
PRACTICES THAT PROMOTE STUDENT
SUCCESS FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS TO PROGRAMS THAT ARE
STATUTORILY OR TYPICALLY RECEIVE
ONE. OF HAVE ANY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT
THESE ABOUT. OKAY THANK YOU. SO
THEIR NUMBER OF PROPOSALS- IN
ISSUE FIVE THOSE ARE ON PAGES
TWENTY EIGHT AND TWENTY NINE OF
YOUR AGENDA WE GENERALLY DON'T
HAVE A CONCERN. WITH THE- WITH
MANY OF THOSE PROPOSALS I JUST
MAKE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS- FIRST
THE LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE
MUCH INFORMATION ON THE AMEND. A
PROPOSAL OR A TWO MAN IS BOTTOM
OF PAGE TWENTY EIGHT AMEND
PROPOSAL- THIS WOULD BE A NEWLY
FUNDED- STATE PROGRAM- SO THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO JUST
GET SOME BASIC INFORMATION TO
DATE THAT THE INFORMATION.
PROVIDED IS BEEN PRETTY LIMITED
US LEGISLATURE GET GET
INFORMATION ON WHAT IS ALLOWABLE
USES OF THIS FINDING OUT HOW
WITH THE PROPOSED AMOUNT HOW WAS
THE PROPOSED AMOUNT THE ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS ON
DETERMINED HOW THE FUNDS BE
ALLOCATED- HOW WOULD THE PROGRAM
MEASURE SUCCESS. ALSO HOW WOULD
THE PROGRAM INTERACT WITH
ANOTHER STATE FUNDED PROGRAM
FOCUSED ON AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS AND THAT'S- A THE-
MOTOR PROGRAM. SO THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO DIRECT
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION AND THEN USE IT
TO MAKE A DECISION IN THE FINAL
BUDGET- AS WE UNDERSTAND IT- THE
PROGRAM PATHWAYS MAPPING
TECHNOLOGY TO MISTER HANOVER
MENTIONED THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
PROPOSED. THAT WOULD BE A USER
FRIENDLY WAY FOR STUDENTS TO SEE
WHAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSES
STUDENTS SHOULD TAKE AND WHAT
WATER TO GET A CERTIFICATE OR
DEGREE. NO SUCH TECHNOLOGY MIGHT
HAVE MERIT BUT WE DO NOTE THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL SOON BE
CHANGING THEIR COLLEGE SPECIFIC
COURSE NUMBERS THE COURSE NAME
AND NUMBERS BUT THEY HAVE NOW
THERE'S LEGISLATION. THAT THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED TO MOVE TO A
COMMON COURSE NUMBER IN SYSTEM
FOR ALL THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THE COLLEGES HAVE
TO INCORPORATE THE NEW COURSE
NAME AND NUMBERS THIS COMMON
NORM NUMBER IN SYSTEM. INTO
THEIR COURSE CATALOGS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR NOW THE WORK HASN'T
EVEN REALLY BEGUN YET ON THAT-
BUT THEY HAVE UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TO GET THESE OF
COURSE NUMBERS IN THE CATALOG.
SO GIVEN THIS PRETTY MAJOR
UNDERTAKING THAT THE COLLEGES
ARE ABOUT TO EMBARK ON OF IT WE
THINK IT MIGHT BE PREMATURE TO
CREATE THIS PROGRM MAPPING TOOL
AND ROLL IT OUT USING- THE
FUNDING AS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR. SO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THIS OR OTHER PROPOSALS THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU. CAN WE CAN
COLLEGES. GOOD MORNING AGAIN WAS
THAT NEVER WITH THE K. PUMP
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHICH THE GO
FOR PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN
SEVERAL PROGRAMS THAT DIRECTLY
FOCUS ON STUDENT SUPPORTS MANY
OF WHICH WERE ESTABLISHED FOR
THE FOR SIDE OF THIS COMMITTEE
IN THE INTEREST AND OF TIME-
GIVE FOCUS MY REMARKS ON THREE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE AGENDA- AS OF INTEREST
FOR GETTING MORE INFORMATION THE
FIRST IS- THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALE EDUCATION NETWORK
DEVELOPMENT KNOWN AS A MAN-
WHICH PROVIDES SUPPORT GUIDANCE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
AMANDA IS PART OF CRITICAL WORK
AND URGENT EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
BLACK STUDENT SUCCESS- THIS
PROPOSAL IS MODEST AND WOULD
FOCUS ON STUDENT CHARTERS OTHER
MEN AND- IN SUPPORTING A STUDENT
SUPPORT STRUCTURE THAT
ESTABLISHES AFFIRMING
ENVIRONMENTS- WHERE AFRICAN
AMERICAN MALE STUDENTS AND MEN
OF COLOR ARE ABLE TO THRIVE THE
AIM OF A MANNED- STUDENT
CHARTERS IS TO APPROVE IMPROVE
ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND TO DEVELOP
CULTURALLY COMPETENT STUDENT
LEADERS THERE ARE CURRENTLY
TWENTY FOUR AMEND STERN CHARTERS
THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIRTY
ADDITIONAL ONES. A SO THAT THERE. IS A BROADER REACH ACROSS THE
STATE. SECOND I WANTED BRIEFLY
FOCUS ON FINANCIAL AID OFFICES-
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES HAVE BEEN
MORE CRITICAL AND ESSENTIAL THAN
EVER THESE OFFICES HAVE WORKED
AROUND THE CLOCK TO PROVIDE
BILLIONS IN EMERGENCY GRANTS. TO
SUPPORT A HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANT AND TO
SUPPORT CALFRESH ENROLLMENT.
HOWEVER FINANCIAL AID OFFICES-
WORKLOAD HAS INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY IT'S ONE OF THE
FEW PROGRAMS THAT IS ACTUALLY
SEEN A REDUCTION IN STATE
FUNDING. THIS IS BECAUSE
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES HAVE A
FORMULA THAT IS BASED ON
ENROLLMENT- AND GIVEN THE
IMPORTANT ROLE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICES PLAYED MEETING STUDENT
INCREASE IS WARRANTED AN
ESSENTIAL. LASTLY I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT- EFFORTS AROUND
EMERGENCY GRANTS- AS WELL AND I
WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND- THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DISTRICTS
RECEIVED OVER FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION IN ONE TIME FEDERAL
FUNDING AVAILABLE- FOR DIRECT
STUDENT AID BUT ALSO FOR-
INSTITUTIONAL ABRASIONS IN
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC. THIS
IS MANTA THAT- THESE RESOURCES
HAVE BEEN PACKAGED IN
COMBINATION WITH STATE
INVESTMENTS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH EMERGENCY GRANTS RANGING
FROM SIX HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PROVIDING THEM WITH
LAPTOPS HOT SPOTS AND OTHER
SUPPORT AND BASIC NEEDS
INCLUDING HOUSING. AND SO THESE
OF ALL- BEEN- REALLY VALUABLE
AND MUCH NEEDED BOTH IN
SUPPORTING STUDENTS BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT WE CAN RE ENROLL
STUDENTS THAT HAD TO STOP OUT.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU. OKAY.
SUFFER THE INCREASES IN LAST
YEAR'S PROMO JAB MESA AND QUENTE
. DO WE HAVE ANY FROM THEIR
COMMUNICATORS IS TO HAVE ANY
RAPE REPORT BACK ON. AND-
IMPLEMENTATION NOW THAT'S BEEN
HOW THAT'S BEEN GOING. AT THE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU SITE RECEIVED
AN INCREASE- LIST LAST YEAR
THEY'RE STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE ACADEMIC YEAR- BUT I WILL-
FINALIZE THE ACADEMIC YEAR AND
GET MORE INFORMATION ON HOW THAT
SUPPORT SOME OF IT HAS BEEN TO
KEEP UP WITH THE COST OF
OPERATION BUT ALSO TO EXPAND
ACCESS- PARTICULARLY ON TO
STUDENTS THAT HARPER FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED BACKGROUNDS
BUT- HAPPY TO SHARE AN UPDATE AS
WE LEARN MORE AND GET ADDITIONAL
DATA. YEAH AND- YEAH THESE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU KNOW THE
COMMITTEES VERY SUPPORTIVE OF IN
- SOME OF THE LINGERING SUCCESS
RATES AMONG CERTAIN COMMITTEES
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN NOTED
AND WARRANTS INVESTMENT. THE
OTHER ONE THAT WE HAVEN'T GROUP
THAT WE HAD FOCUSED ON OBVIOUS A
SMALL GROUP IN CALIFORNIA BUT
NOT A LOT OF TREMENDOUS ACADEMIC
SUCCESS ALWAYS IS NATIVE
AMERICANS AND SO THERE'S A
THERE'S THEIR- REQUEST. BY FEW
ENTITIES TO SERVE TO SUPPORT
IT'S CALLED THE NATIVE AMERICAN
. STUDENT SUPPORT AND SUCCESS
PROGRAM. ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH
THAT. NOT AT THIS TIME OKAY
HAPPY TO LEARN MORE YEAH I THINK
IT'S SIMILAR TO A MOSHE IN THAT
EMOJI WAS A PROGRAM WHICH WAS
NEVER FUNDED THROUGH THE STATE
THROUGH. THEY CANCERS OFFICE
UNTIL I THINK THREE YEARS AGO
WHEN THIS COMMITTEE PUT AT THE
STATE- NINE ITEM IN THERE. SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
INTRIGUED ABOUT TEN WHEN I. SEE
IF WE CAN HELP STUDENTS WHO
HISTORICALLY HAVE BEEN FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND- SO IF
YOU CAN WORK WITH US AND GET
BACK TO US ON THAT- I DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THESE ITEMS ARE
ALL PROGRAMS WITH THE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT FOR WE WILL.
YOU KNOW TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WE
CAN DO THAT. FURTHER- SUPPORT
THESE EFFORTS WHEN WE FINALIZE
OUR BUDGET AFTER ME- NEXT ISSUE
ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE POSITIONS NINETEEN
POSITIONS TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL ONGOING
SUPPORT. BINANCE. GOOD MORNING
CHECK A CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
TALKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES INCREASE OF ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION ON GOING GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT NINE NEW
POSITIONS AT THE CCC
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT TEN
ADDITIONAL NEW POSITIONS IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. THESE
NEW RICK- TO SUPPORT THE GOALS
OF THE CCC MULTI YEAR ROADMAP
THESE NEW RESOURCES WILL AID THE
CCC CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
SUPPORTING CURRICULA CURRICULUM
RELATED REFORMS TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS AND
INCREASE STATE OPERATIONS
CAPACITY FOR DATA ANALYSIS
RESEARCH LEGAL AFFAIRS DISTRICTS
HEALTH MONITORING AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU ELENA.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
YOU YOU MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET
OF THE HEARING ABOUT. ALL THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MONEY
COMING TO THE COLLEGES OF THE
LAST LAST FEW YEARS AND NEW
PROGRAMS CREATED. IN THE STATE
IS GIVEN THE CHANCE WAS OFFICE
MORE MORE RESPONSIBILITY- ON
ADMINISTERING THESE PROGRAMS OF-
THAT FOR THE MOST PART IS NOT
BEEN- IS NOT GIVEN POSITIONS TO
THE TO THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
AND YOU CAN SEE ACTUALLY ON PAGE
THIRTY SIX UNDERSTAFFED COMMENT
THE JUST A- A LIST OF SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
CREATED OVER THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS. THESE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SO WE DO SEE
MERIT- TO PROVIDING- OR WERE
OPEN TO THE IDEA OF PROVIDING
MORE POSITIONS TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- YOU CAN SEE
OUR RECORD RECOMMENDATIONS ON
PAGES THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE OF
THE AGENDA. YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S ACTUAL PROPOSALS TO
US IS KIND OF A MIXED BAG WE DO
SEE JUSTIFICATION FOR SOME OF
THESE POSITIONS BUT IN OTHER
CASES- THE POSITIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN SUFFICIENTLY JUSTIFIED. AT
THIS TIME. AS WE READ-
APPROVING- TWO POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT- TRANSFER REFORMS THIS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWENTY EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN BILL THAT
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IN THE FALL.
IT MAKES SENSE TO US TO APPROVE
THOSE POSITIONS BUT TO MAKE A
LIMITED TERM SINCE THE WORK THEY
WOULD BE DOING WOULD JUST BE
THROUGH TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
SEVEN. NO REASON AT THIS TIME TO
MAKE THOSE PERMANENT POSITIONS
AS THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES WE ALSO
RECOMMEND APPROVING. TO OTHER
POSITIONS- THAT WOULD WORK ON
BASIC NEEDS RISING SCHOLARS
PROGRAM A NUMBER OF OTHER
PROGRAMS OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS
CREATED. BUT WE RECOMMEND.
MOVING UP FUNDING FOR THOSE
POSITIONS TO TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE THE GOVERNOR HAS THOSE
POSITIONS FUNDED IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR BUT THE PROGRAMS ARE
STARTING UP NOW AND SO WE THINK
THE CHANCES OFFICE. WOULD
BENEFIT FROM GETTING. POSITION
AUTHORIZATION FOR THOSE-
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. WE ALSO- WE RIVER WE
REJECT A COUPLE POSITIONS WE
RECOMMEND A LEGISLATURE REJECT A
COUPLE POSITIONS SAY- SPECIALIST
POSITION A PROGRAM ASSISTANT. A
POSITION THEY WOULD BE WORKING
ON ETHNIC STUDIES AND A
COMPETENCY BASED. EDUCATION
CURRICULUM. WE THINK THAT THIS
SUDDEN BURKE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD
BE SUPPORTED BUT THE INFORMATION
WE GOT FROM THE CHANCES OFFICES
THAT ALREADY. TWO POSITIONS TO
SPECIALISTS OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ARE DEDICATED TO THAT
WORKLOAD. AS FOR THE OTHER
THIRTEEN POSITIONS THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE VERY WELL
NAY NEED THOSE POSITIONS TO
ADMINISTER BUT- RIGHT AS OF
RIGHT NOW THERE'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH WORKLOAD JUSTIFICATION OF
BACKUP YOU KNOW THAT WE'VE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS RECEIVED.
FROM OF THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THOSE POSITIONS SO WE RECOMMEND
GIVING ADMINISTRATION SO MORE
TIME UNTIL MAY REVISED PERHAPS
TO. DEVELOP WORKLOAD
JUSTIFICATION WHAT EXACTLY THESE
POSITIONS WOULD BE DOING WHY
THEY'RE NEEDED WHY THE CURRENT.
POSITIONS THAT ARE AUTHORIZED
ARE INSUFFICIENT AND THEN
LEGISLATURE CAN USE THAT
INFORMATION TO MAKE A DECISION
ON A POSITION OF AUTHORITY FOR
NEXT YEAR AND THE FOLLOWING YEAR
PERHAPS THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU AT CANCERS OFFICE AND GOOD
AFTERNOON OR MORNING AGAIN- OF
SPECIFIC IMPORTANCE TO
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERIES THE
ABILITY FOR THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO ADVANCE. AT
EDUCATIONAL REFORMS AND
WORKFORCE PATHWAYS THAT HELP
CALIFORNIANS RECOVER AND THRIVE.
CURRENTLY THE CHANCES OFFICES
NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
IMPLEMENT MAJOR STATEWIDE
PRIORITIES AND RECENTLY ENACTED
POLICIES MANY OF WHICH OF THIS
BODY PRIORITISES AND CHAMPIONS.
TODAY THE CANCERS OFFICE
ADMINISTERS OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIVE PROGRAMS COMPARED TO THIRTY
ONE JUST TEN YEARS AGO WITH ONLY
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
STAFF. THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
VACANCY RATE IS ALSO BELOW STATE
AGENCY AVERAGES. THE PROPOSED
POSITIONS FOR THE OFFICE ARE
NEEDED TO CONTINUE TO BETTER
SERVE OUR HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
COLLEGES AND ADDRESS CORE GAP
AREAS INCLUDING POLICIES AND
INITIATIVES AND SOME OF THE
HIGHEST PROFILE. AND CRITICAL
WORK AT THAT WE UNDERTAKE AT OUR
COLLEGES BOTH- IN AREAS OF GREAT
DISTRICT LEVEL INVESTMENT NEED.
MANY OF THESE INCLUDE RISING
SCHOLARS TRANSFERABLE ARM
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
IMPLEMENTATION COMMON COURSE
NUMBERRING FISCAL HEALTH OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST AGREES STUDENT
RETENTION STRATEGIES. CALFRESH
FOOD SECURITY BASIC NEEDS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES EXPANSION OF
DIGITAL ACCESSIBILITY DIGITAL
COURSE CONTENT DEVELOPMENT DOING
ROLE MEANT DATA SECURITY
ONBOARDING REDESIGN ALL TO BE T.
Q. I A. STUDENTS SUPPORT. JUST
TO NAME A FEW ABSENT RESOURCES
TO EXPAND CAPACITY THIS CRITICAL
WORK AROUND IMPLEMENTATION
INNOVATION AND COMPLIANCE HAS
BEEN AMASSED INTO EXISTING
DUTIES SO WE JUST. PILE ON TO
PEOPLE'S EXISTING. EXISTING
WORK. LIMITING THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY TIME AND
EXPERTISE AND ANALYSIS NEEDED TO
MEET BOTH THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE IS INTENDED
DELIVERABLES. IN ADDITION THESE
POSITIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY DATA THAT
IS OFTEN NECESSARY FOR THE
SYSTEM FOR COLLEGE LEVEL
DECISION MAKING TO FOSTER
INCREASED IT- TO SCALE EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES. TO DEVELOP AN
UNDERSTANDING OF SOLUTIONS- AND
TO ALSO SERVE THE LEGISLATURE AS
YOU ARE EXPLORING ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS. SO WE
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THESE
POSITIONS AND ACTUALLY CONSIDER
OUR FULL PROPOSAL OF THIRTY ONE
POSITIONS HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN THE
NEXT MONTH TO SHARE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NEED AND
THE GAP AREA. THANK YOU. OKAY I
THINK YEAH I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS- I GENERALLY
SUPPORT OF THIS I KNOW WE- FOCUS
ON. SEVEN GREAT EFFORTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS AND NEW PROGRAMS TO
BILLS AND BUDGET EFFORTS AND- WE
CAN'T JUST LOADING ON LOAD ON
MORE AND MORE STUFF TO DO
WITHOUT RECOGNIZING IT TAKES
WORK TO GET IT DONE EFFECTIVELY
SO. I WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN-
AND THEN GET TO OUR LAST ISSUE
BECAUSE VERY GOOD NUMBER EIGHT-
CYBER SECURITY PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU. RUN THROUGH THIS QUICKLY
PLACE THANK YOU. TWENTY AGAIN
TENER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED MILLION ONE TWO OR
ONE HUNDRED MILLION- PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND OF
WHICH TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS ON
GOING TO ADDRESS THE
MODERNIZATION. OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
SENSITIVE DATA PROTECTION
EFFORTS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THIS PROPOSAL MIRRORS
OUR QUEST INCLUDED IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM REQUEST
TO BETTER EQUIP COLLEGES TO
PROTECT THEIR DATA AGAINST
ATTACKS SIMILAR TO THOSE
ATTEMPTED OVER THE PAST ECONOMIC
HERE. AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA
ONGOING FUNDING WOULD BE
PRIMARILY UTILIZED FOR DISTRICTS
TO HIRE ON CYBER SECURITY STAFF
AS WELL AS ESTABLISH SYSTEM WIDE
OVERSIGHT. ONE TIME FUNDS WOULD
BE USED TO PROCURE SECURITY
UPGRADES FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NETWORKS AND- THE FOR THE CCC
APPLY. WITHOUT HAVING ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT- THANK YOU L. A. L.
pMERIT TO THE PROPOSAL- MAINTAIN
INFORMATION SECURITY PREVENTING.
FRAUD IS REALLY CRITICAL- IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
LAUDABLE THAT THE- GOVERNOR
ADDRESSES THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
WE FIND MERIT- WITH PROVIDING
FUNDS FOR COLLEGES THEY CAN USE
TO HIRE SOME DEDICATED
CYBERSECURITY STAFF YOU DON'T
HAVE THAT. IN IN IN A LOT OF
COLLEGES WHERE THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN DEDICATED CYBERSECURITY
STAFF WE DO SEE MERIT TO A
STRONGER STATE LEVEL ROLE. WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- LEADING
THAT EFFORT COLLECTING BETTER
DATA FROM COLLEGES WHEN THERE
ARE CYBER ATTACKS WERE. FRIED
SUSPECTED FRAUD SO- OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE MAINLY
AROUND JUST THE ALLOCATION
METHOD OF THE FUNDS AND THEN IN
SOME CASES JUST NEEDS- NEED FOR
SO SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
CLARITY ABOUT HOW THE MONEY
WOULD BE USED AND HOW THE AMOUNT
WAS- WAS REACHED AND SO WE
RECOMMEND THAT ACTUALLY IS ON
PAGE THIRTY NINE OF THE- AGENDA
YOU CAN SEE THE DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS- SO WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING THE TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO THE
COLLEGES BUT HAVING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
DEVELOPMENT ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY. SO THAT THERE'S A
MINIMUM FUNDING AMOUNT FOR THE
DISTRICTS AND- AND SOME
ADDITIONAL MONEY IF IT'S A MULTI
COLLEGE DISTRICT. ALSO WE THINK
THOUGH THE CHANCES OFFICE
ADMINISTRATION COULD. USE SOME
TIME BETWEEN NOW AND MAY BE
REVISED TO THINK THROUGH MORE
ABOUT HOW THE STATE LEVEL ROLE
IS GOING TO WORK YOU CAN SEE IN
YOUR AGENDA OTHERS STATEWIDE
CYBER SECURITY TEAMS ARE
PROPOSED. THERE'S A SYSTEM LEVEL
OVERSIGHT BODY THEY'RE ALSO
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE POSITIONS
WHICH WERE YOU KNOW IN THE IN
THE PREVIOUS ISSUE ITEM SO IT'S
A PRETTY COMPLEX ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE AND JUST THINK THE
LEGISLATURE. COULD USE SOME
BETTER INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
EXACTLY THIS WOULD WORK AND
WHAT'S OF DIVISION OF LABOR. BOB
WITH REGARD TO- THOSE ONE TIME
FUNDS THAT MISTER HANOVER
MENTIONED. THAT'S A TOTAL OF
SIXTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME. TO THE COLLEGES- WE
RECOMMEND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE YOU KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GET THE CHANCES
OFFICE COPE WITH AN ALLOCATION.
METHODOLOGY THAT ADDRESSES NOT
JUST THE- ENROLLMENT OF THE SIZE
OF THE COLLEGE BUT ALSO ITS
CURRENT LEVEL OF PREPAREDNESS
FOR CYBER ATTACKS TO TRYING TO
LIFT UP. ALL THE COLLEGES TO A
MINIMUM LEVEL OF CYBER SECURITY
GIVEN THAT. THE CASE NOW IS
THERE ARE PRETTY DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF PREPAREDNESS. SO HOW
MANY CHANCES OFFICE REALLY
PRIORITIZE YOUR MONEY FOR THOSE
THAT THAT NEED THE MOST HELP IN
GETTING THEM UP TO THAT LEVEL
AND ALSO AT THE LEGISLATURE DOES
NEED A BETTER IDEA OF WHAT'S THE
ON GOING. COST OF THIS PACKAGE
IS A LOT OF ONE TIME MONEY BUT
THE ONE TIME MONEY'S GOING TO BE
USED FOR THINGS LIKE ANNUAL
LICENSES FOR SOFTWARE. AND
TRAINING AND SOME CONSULTING
SERVICES THERE ARE SOME COSTS
THAT. WE ACTUALLY ARE MORE INFO
IN ONGOING NATURE LEGISLATURE
JUST NEEDS A MUCH BETTER IDEA
ABOUT WHAT THOSE ONGOING COSTS
ARE. AND JUST FINALLY ON THE CCC
APPLY- PROPOSALS SEEK AGAIN
THAT'S ON PAGE THIRTY NINE THERE
IS A ON GOING IN ONE TIME MONEY
FOR THAT. CCC APPLIED AS THE-
COMMON ONLINE APPLICATION PORTAL
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- HAS
DEFINITELY COULD USE SOME
UPDATING AND REDESIGNING AND
BETTER ANTI FRAUD SECURITY SO
WE'RE IN FAVOR IN SUPPORT OF
FUNDING FOR THAT. BUT THE THERE
NEEDS TO BE THAT SOME ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD JUSTIFICATION FOR SOME
OF THE. ASPECTS OF THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. OKAY I THINK YOU'RE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. HAD GOT GOOD
MORNING AGAIN- OUR SYSTEM NEEDS
A STRONG INVESTMENT IN
TECHNOLOGY RESOURCES ESPECIALLY
CYBER SECURITY- THE SEVERITY OF
OUR NEEDS CONTINUE TO INCREASE
EVEN AS JUST LAST MONTH. ANOTHER
DISTRICT EXPERIENCED A CYBER
SECURITY ATTACK. MODERNIZING
STATE AND DISTRICT LEVEL
TECHNOLOGY AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND CCC APPLY ARE CRITICAL TO
ENSURE. FACULTY AND STUDENTS
SENSITIVE DATA ARE PROTECTED
FROM THESE ATTACKS WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT DATA CHALLENGES
AND LIMITED TECHNOLOGY CAPACITY
RISK. UNDERMINING A KEY REFORMS
THAT ADVANCE STUDENT SUCCESS.
THE PROPOSED ACKNOWLEDGING
SECURITY INVESTMENTS ARE TWO
FOLD RELYING ON STATE AND LOCAL
ACTION. WELL SMALL PORTION WOULD
BE USED FOR ONGOING SOFTWARE
CARS COST. THE MAJORITY WILL
SUPPORT ON GOING MODERATE-
MONITORING AND IMPLEMENTATION.
STATE LEVEL ACTIONS ARE FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY MONITORING
TAILORING SUPPORT FOR DISTRICTS-
PRIOR- THOUGH NOT EXCLUSIVELY-
BUT MOSTLY TARGETING ON THOSE
SMALLER LESS MATURE. TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT EXISTS AT
CERTAIN DISTRICTS. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THESE OPTIONS AND
UPGRADES NOT BE DONE IN A SILO.
WE MUST TACKLE GROWING
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES AND RISK AND
THIS IS AN ONGOING EFFORT AND
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES- EFFORTS BY
BAD ACTORS BECOME MORE
SOPHISTICATED. SECOND WE MUST
AND IMPROVE THE STUDENT USER
EXPERIENCE AND REDESIGN CCC
APPLY THIS IS A COMPLEX
ENDEAVOR- THAT SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WE COLLECT THE DATA
THAT WE NEED FROM STUDENTS BUT
WE ALSO DON'T MAKE THE
APPLICATION SO CUMBERSOME THAT
STUDENTS AND PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS STOP MIDWAY THROUGH. SO
THE EFFORT IS REALLY GOING TO BE
A DELICATE AND URGENT BALANCE OF
ART AND SCIENCE SO AGAIN WE
THINK THESE. INVESTMENTS ARE
CRITICAL AND SEEK YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU HAVE BEEN TWENTY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE WILL- I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE WE WILL
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN UNTIL AFTER
THE MAY REVISION I WITH THAT
WE'LL NOW PROCEED TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS HERE IN PERSON PLEASE-
LINED UP AT THE MICROPHONE WILL
THAT PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ONE
MINUTE OR LESS. ONE MINUTE OR
LESS AND THEN WHEN HE SAID THANK
YOU. AND THEN- WILL GO TO THE
PHONE. YEAH THAT. HI HI GOOD
AFTERNOON HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
IT'S KIND OF INTIMIDATING IN THE
FACE ARE YOU DOING GREAT. THANK
YOU- AND LIKE TO READ A
STATEMENT- HELLO OR HELLO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
TEMAS CHESHIRE. I'M A MEMBER OF
THE CORONATION- AND A FULL TIME
PROFESSOR FULSOME THEY COLLEGE I
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE SECOND AMERICAN
HIGHER EDUCATION COLLABORATIVE.
I WANT TO REMIND YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST BEFORE I FINISH THE
STATEMENT IS IT YOUR NATIVE LAND
UNCEDED LAND THAT BELONGS TO
THEM I DO. MEANWHILE CAN BE SENT
ON THE SHINS- WHEN THIS-
COMMITTEE MEETING BEGAN. I
DIDN'T HEAR ANY RECOGNITION OF
THIS FACT AND SO I WANTED TO
REMIND YOU. ABOUT THAT YOU WERE
ON NATIVE LAND- I AM HERE- AZAM
OF THE SEGMENT. HIGHER EDUCATION
COLLABORATIVE. WE ARE PROPOSING
A NEW PROGRAM TO SUPPORT NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS CALL THE NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS SUPPORT
SUCCESS PROGRAM. WE'RE WRITING
WITH. A UNIFIED VOICE TO
RECOMMEND INCLUSION OF FUNDING.
OF THE PROGRAM TO THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND ARE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. WE CURRENTLY HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOHN
JAMES C. RAMOS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON IT AMERICAN
AFFAIRS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARILLO. I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE NAY MAKING
AFFAIRS WE ALSO HAVE THE SUPPORT
FROM THE FACT ASSOCIATION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE CITY CALIFORNIA HAS A LARGE
POPULATION IN AMERICANS IN THE
UNITED STATES. MEDICINES
PERSISTENTLY OF SOME OF THE
LOWEST RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
GRADUATION RATES OF ANY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
ETHNIC GROUP IN THE US. WITH 24%
OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD NATIVE. AMERICAN STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN COLLEGE COMPARED
2401% OF THE OVERALL STUDENT
POPULATION. AND IT SHOWS THAT
NATIVE STUDENTS HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST DROPOUT RATES WITH UP TO
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN DURING THE
FIRST YEAR OF COLLEGE THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE SYSTEM IS
CONTINUE TO FURTHER MARGINALIZE
NAMES STUDENTS. I NEED TO
MENTION THAT WE BROUGHT THE
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS SUPPORT
AND SUCCESS PROGRAM TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AND ESSENTIALLY TOLD US
TO COME TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
ASK FOR MONEY- OUR BUDGET WOULD
BE A FIVE YEAR BUDGET- AND- FOR
TWENTY. PLUS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
EACH CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHO SUCCESSFULLY APPLIED
WILL RECEIVE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
ULTIMATELY WE HOPE IMPACT
BETWEEN FOUR AND SIX THOUSAND
NATIVE AMERICANS CUT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND- ACROSS THE
STATE- WE HAVE STAFFING OF
ASKING OF A TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PROGRAM AGREEMENT WE HAVE TO ASK
YOU TO WRAP UP. OKAY ONE MINUTE
AND I WAS LIKE TRIPLE BUT I
CAN'T AT THIS YOUR FIRST TIME
HERE SO THANK YOU BUT I WANT LET
YOU KNOW THAT THAT I'M VERY
SUPPORT OF THIS I'M WORKING WITH
MISTER RAMOS AND- JUST STAY
TUNED TO WORK ON THIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH BIGGER PLACE I
THINK WE AND WE HAVE A LETTER
HERE TO THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MARK MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO KERN. BROUGHT THE
SAMPOERNA DINO IN YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS- WE SUPPORT
THE- READ BENCHING OF THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
TO THE CURRENT YEAR ON THE HOLD
HARMLESS IN ORDER. TO ADDRESS
THE EMERGENCY CAN DO. AND WE
DON'T THINK THAT. SHOULD THE IN
OF THIS OVER THE WHOLE HARMLESS
AND WE SUPPORT A MADE AND IN THE
BASE AS WELL THE JOB BY THE L.
A. AS JUST A BEGINNING OF THOSE-
WE SUPPORT THE TECHNOLOGY
CATEGORICAL- AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT INCREASED ACTUALLY. AND
THEN WE SUPPORT- A SMALL
INVESTMENT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
INTO ETHNIC STUDIES FACULTY
GIVEN THE RAPID AMOUNT OF ETHNIC
STUDIES- CURRICULUM THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO UNDERTAKE IN
THE COMING YEARS. AND THEN WE DO
ALSO SUPPORT THE SCHEDULED
MAINTENANCE AND WE'VE ALSO
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON OTHER. ISSUES THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MONEY GRANDMA ON BEHALF OF THE
STE- THE STATE CENTER FUNDING
FOR EQUITY COLOR. SO THEY'RE
PRETTY COALITION IS MEETING WITH
MANY OF YOU YOUR YOU AND YOUR
STAFF MEMBERS THIS WEEK TO SHARE
REPORT THAT THEY HAVE PREPARED
ON THE IMPACT OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPLICATION. IN
COLLEGES AND LIVING COLLEGES
RESIDING IN HIGH COST AREAS. IN
ITALY STUDENTS WHO LIVE IN THESE
HIGH COST AREAS MUST MAKE MORE
MONEY IN ORDER TO SURVIVE IN
THOSE AREAS. THEREBY MAKING THEM
LESS ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCIAL AID
. FACT STUDENTS PARTICIPATION IN
THE PROMISED GRANTS IN STATE WHY
JUST 42% BUT ONLY 24% IN HIGH
COST REGIONS. FOR THE PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION OF THE 20% VERSUS
10% IN HIGH COST REGIONS.
COALITION HAS PREPARED A REPORT
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS TO MAKE A
MINOR ADJUSTMENT TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPLICATION. TO
INCLUDE HARD FOR MARKET HOUSING-
INDEX. IN ORDER TO PROVIDE A
MINOR ADJUSTMENT TO ADDRESS THE
COST OF THE REGIONAL COSTS. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS POLICY IS
TIED UP IN THE LARGER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FUNDING ITEMS BUT WE ASK
THAT YOU KEEP THIS IN MIND AS
YOU HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK A PLACE
. GOOD MORNING JULIE NIGEL ARE
FROM THE FOSTER AND KINSHIP CARE
EDUCATION PROGRAM. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT THE NEXT UP
PROGRAM BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SPEAK TO SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT
ON TODAY'S HEARING AGENDA. AND
THAT IS THIS FOSTER AND KINSHIP
CARE EDUCATION PROGRAM WE I AM
FROM THE FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE
PROGRAM- WE ARE A TINY LITTLE
PROGRAM BUDGET WISE WE ARE
FUNDED WITH TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO PROP NINETY EIGHT WITH A
FEDERAL MATCH. YET WE HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- WE ARE CURRENTLY FACING A
ALMOST THREE QUARTERS OF A
MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT NEXT
YEAR. A REDUCTION IN FUNDING-
DUE TO THE FEDERAL CALCULATION
THE WAY IT'S MATCHED- BUT OUR
PROGRAM. THAT IMPACTS- FOSTER
PARENTS UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROVIDING THE
TRAINING THAT IS STATE MANDATED.
IF YOU WANT TO BECOME A CARE
GIVER OR IF YOU ARE ALREADY CARE
GIVER THEIR MANDATE TO ATTEND
ANNUAL HOURS- WE ARE THE ONLY
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES LOCALIZED
TRAINING WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE OFFICES.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN UNDERFUNDED FOR
YEARS- AND THE FEDERAL. RATE IS
DECLINING WE ARE LOSING PROGRAMS
SO THAT MEANS THAT MANY PROGRAMS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE JUST CAN'T
FUNCTION ANYMORE AND THEN. THAT
LEAVES CARE GIVERS. LESS SUPPORT
LESS QUALITY LOCALIZED
INFORMATION SO WE'RE ASKING YOU.
TO FIND TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT
THIS PROGRAM AND SUSTAIN US. UP
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE QUALITY TRAINING FOR
CAREGIVERS THAT ARE CARING FOR
CHILDREN UP AND DOWN THE STATE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING
I'M SHERRY SCHROEDER AND I'M
ALSO A CALIFORNIA RESOURCE
PARENT A FOSTER PARENT AND I'M
ALSO THE DIRECTOR FOSTER AND
KINSHIP CARE EDUCATION. AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAMS AND
I FIRST JUST WANTED TO. SAY ON
BEHALF OF THE NEXT UP PROGRAM I
WISH AND ARE YOU THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WE HAD THAT
PROGRAM SO I WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO NEXT UP.
SECONDARILY AS A RESOURCE PARENT
MY ONE OF MY BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS
BEHIND ME. WHO'S HAD THAT
PROGRAM BUT I ALSO KNOW I
COULDN'T BE A CARE GIVER IF I
DIDN'T HAVE TO FOSTER AND
KINSHIP CARE EDUCATION PROGRAM.
I'VE BEEN THERE THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS ALSO PART TIME NO BENEFITS
AS ARE ABOUT 50% OF OUR FOSTER
AND KINSHIP CARE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WE ARE DECLINING GROUP
WE WERE SIXTY TWO ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS AGO. WE'RE DOWN TO FIFTY
FOUR ANTICIPATING LOSING WITH
THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF FEDERAL LOSS
THAT. SO ALL THE STANDARD IS SO
LOW FEWER AND FEWER CHILDREN ARE
QUALIFYING FEWER PEOPLE FILED
CHILD ABUSE REPORTS DURING
CODED. SO THAT NUMBER IS GOING
TO IMPACT US OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS WE ANTICIPATE. PROBABLY
LOSING HALF OF OUR PROGRAMS IF
THIS CONTINUES WE'RE VITAL WE'RE
PREPARING OUR CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE PARENTS AND- I KNOW
THAT I'VE MADE A DIFFERENCE TO
THOUSANDS OF PROSPECTIVE
RESOURCE PARENTS. AND IT MADE A
DIFFERENCE TO MY THIRTY YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME TO LIVE IN
OUR HOME ALL TRANSITIONAL AGE
YOUTH SO. I WANTED TO SHOW MY
DAUGHTER A MALE. HI GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS A MALE ELEMENTS TO ME
I AM ALSO A STUDENT AT SIERRA
COLLEGE THAT DOES HAVE THE- NEXT
A PROGRAM THAT YOU GUYS WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER- I JUST
DON'T WANT TO. PUT MY BEST FOOT
FORWARD AND SAY AS A STUDENT
ALSO KIND OF AS A- RECIPIENT OF
NEXT UP FUNDS AND EXTREME
SUPPORT THE I THINK THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS VITAL. TO NOT JUST ME
TO ALSO THE BUNCH OF OTHER FAST
USING TRADITIONAL AGE USE THAT
TO GET IT. IT'S HELPED ME- PAY
MY RENT MY INSURANCE HELP ME GET
FOOD AND STUFF LIKE THAT. AND
IT'S CRUCIAL TO A LOT OF
STUDENTS SO I REALLY EMPHASIZE
THAT YOU GUYS- HELPER PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOUR TEAM
IS THE COMMITTEE CALLED THE OF
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WOULD
ENCOURAGE INVESTMENTS OF THE ME
REVISED. CONTINUES TO. TREND
UPWARDS. TO SUPPORT THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR BASIL
AUGMENTATION FOR TECHNOLOGY. TO
HELP I DON'T PENSION OBLIGATION
COSTS AS WELL. IT FOR FINANCIAL
REFORM THE TWEETERS OF THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE AND THEN
DISTILLING LESS ISSUE THE CEOS
DID SUBMIT A LETTER WHICH AND-
RECEIVED. WHICH ENCOURAGE THE
RETENTION OF THE HOLD HARMLESS
HERE FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND I. APPRECIATE YOUR-
THANKS SO MUCH. MISTER MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS- WE'RE A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE PROPOSED
INCREASE TO THE PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTH INSURANCE
PROGRAM. HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT
THE MASSIVE INCREASES FUNDING TO
THE PROGRAM WILL NECESSITATE
PROGRAM APPLICATIONS ARE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT- THOSE
PLANS GOALS WERE THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE OF PROVIDING HEALTH CARE
TO- ALL PART TIME FACULTY- FOR
THE RELEASE TO THE- SKIFF. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE- PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR IN THE STUDENT
CENTER FUNDING FORMULA SHOULD
INCLUDE A COLD IN THE OUT YEARS
NOT JUST. SORT OF A ONE TIME WE
BENCHING- AND LASTLY WE WE'VE
CONSISTENTLY SERVE MAINTAINED
OUR POSITION AS A REALLY TO
CALIBRATE- WE BELIEVE THOSE
PLANS WOULD BE BETTER SERVED
GOING AND BEING INVESTED IN THE-
CURRENT EXISTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND WE- SUPPORT
THE LATEST LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS-
BOTH IN THE BUDGET OTHERWISE IN
THIS. IN THIS AREA THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES
OUR IN PERSON TESTIMONY WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONES. MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE- LINE UP THE
SPEAKERS. I CERTAINLY AN OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMMENTS FROM THE
LINE. THIRTY NINE ONE MOMENT. HI
AND YOUR LINE OF MY NAME IS. HI
MY NAME IS LISA CAME AND I AM A
PART TIME PSYCHOLOGY INSTRUCTOR
AT LOS ANGELES TRADE TECH
COLLEGE I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HEALTHCARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROPERTY.
BARCZEWO LONG. MANY OF US PART
TIME FACULTY IN CALIFORNIA MANY
COLLEGES ON WILLINGLY FONG
WITHOUT HEALTHCARE BENEFITS. THE
FOURTH OF MANY OF US OUT OF OUR
BELOVED PROFESSION. AND THOSE
REMAINING AND HARMS OUR ABILITY
TO BE FULLY PRESENT FOR OUR
STUDENTS. I PERSONALLY JUGGLE
THIS BIRTHDAY ABILITY FOR THE
LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS CHAPTER
THREE CLASSES AND FIND MYSELF IN
CONSTANT CONFLICT TEACHING
STUDENTS ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO PRACTICE.
AND HEALTH CARE REGIMENT MYSELF.
HL BADLY HEALTHCARE BENEFITS TO
ALL OF PRACTICES. SO AGAIN I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ON GOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE. ABOUT
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
WILL GO TO LINE THREE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NANCY
CONSTANTINA CONNELL AND I AM A
PART TIME SPANISH AN ESL
INSTRUCTOR AT THREE DIFFERENT
COLLEGES IN THREE DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS IN THE SAN DIEGO
REGION I AM HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE. FOR PART TIME. ISN'T. YOU
NEED TO CALL. SIX YEARS AGO. THE
ISSUES WHICH- MAJOR STROKES.
THANK WHICH TOOK FOURTEEN YEARS
TO. DURING THE SUMMER. I WOULD
EIGHT TO TAKE CARE OF MY HEALTH
IN MY HEALTH AND BE THERE FOR ME
THROUGH. EVERYTHING THANK. NO WE
- MY YOUR- ONLY. HELLO THEY'RE
JUST PROBLEMS CREE A VICIOUS
CYCLE I URGE YOU. TO WE- PORT
WHAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. AKOTO LINE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS ALL. HELLO MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH AND I'M A TIME I
HISTORY AT EL CAMINO COLLEGE I'M
HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY FAR TOO MANY
PART TIME FACULTY GO ABOUT
HEALTHCARE AND ITS INVESTMENT
WILL ENSURE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
AND I CAN NOW FOCUS OUR ENERGY
ON YOU CAN FIX THAT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO TIMELINE TEN. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU HI I'M CAROL
LEVEL HAT AB PART TIME DANCE
FACULTY AT SAN JOSE CITY COLLEGE
FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS PLEASE
SUPPORT THE FULL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
FOR ONGOING PART TIME HEALTHCARE
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D BE SPENDING
SO MUCH TIME AND ENERGY FOCUSING
ON BASIC HEALTH CARE. THIS TIME
SHOULD BE SPENT FOCUSING ON
STUDENT SUCCESS WHEN I LOST
HEALTHCARE DUE TO LOW ENROLLMENT
THE OPEN MARKET WITH NOT VIABLE
WITH MY CHRONIC CONDITION THE
FULL TWO HUNDRED MILLION WILL
ENSURE THAT PART TIME FACULTY
WILL HAVE HELP WHEN THERE ARE
GAPS IN OUR COVERAGE. INCIDENTLY
FULL TIME POSITIONS ARE VERY FEW
AND FAR BETWEEN WE NOW AND EVEN
FULL TIMERS ARE HAVING A PROBLEM
FILLING THEIR VOTE THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THE FACULTY WHO
WORK HERE. THANK WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTEEN AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU SHARE
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS
LINDA CHAN I AM A PART TIME
INSTRUCTOR AT CITRUS MONTANA
TONY I'M PASADENA COLLEGES I'VE
BEEN IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM FOR OVER FORTY YEARS I
HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITHOUT ANY
HEALTH CARE DURING THAT TIME AND
RAISE A CHILD. WITHOUT THE
HEALTHCARE WE PROMISE TO QUALITY
HEALTH EDUCATION TO OUR STUDENTS
AND FACULTY CANNOT DELIVER THAT
QUALITY EDUCATION WHEN THEY'RE
ILL OR INJURED OR HAVE NO HEALTH
CARE. IT IS NOT FAIR TO THE
STUDENTS. WALKING INTO A
CLASSROOM WHEN YOU'RE INJURED
AND STILL HAVE THE DIGITAL OVER
A QUALITY EDUCATION IS NOT A
GOOD THING I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
THAT YOU HAD A MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE ON GOING FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BECAUSE THIS
IS WHAT'S GOOD FOR STUDENTS AT.
THE RIGHT THING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE WERE GO TIMELINE TWENTY.
LINE TWENTY YEAR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHELLE
MEYER I'M A PART TIME PHYSICALLY
AT LOS ANGELES PIERCE COLLEGE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. PART TIME FACULTY FACE
INSTABILITY IN EMPLOYMENT WHICH
EQUATES TO INSTABILITY AND IN
MANY CASES A LOT OF HEALTH CARE
THE PANDEMIC IS OPEN OUR EYES TO
URGENTNEED TO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE TO PART TIME FACULTY.
FACULTY HEALTH CARE WELL THIS
EQUATES TO ACADEMIC SUCCESS
SUCCESS STUDENTS AGAIN I URGE
YOU TO RECOGNIZE THE VALUE ADD
THINGS CONTRIBUTE TO OUT QUALITY
EDUCATION AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
TO SUCCESS STUDENTS AM PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE FOR PART TIME COMMITTEE
COLLEGE FACULTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO THE LINE
TWENTY FOUR. AND MY TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KRISTEN CROAK AND I'M AN
EMPLOYEE WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT I'M
HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE. FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY. I'VE SERVED AS
A PART TIME FACULTY MEMBER FOR
SEVEN YEARS AND I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT RELIABLE AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE AS- FOR
INSURING THAT WE CAN PROVIDE OUR
STUDENTS WITH A QUALITY
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE. MANY
PART TIME EDUCATIONAL
PROFESSIONALS ACROSS TURKEY
ARCONIC RISK OF LOSING THEIR
HEALTHCARE WINNERS FIND TEACHING
LOAD ACTUALLY BROWN CLASSES ARE
CANCELED AT THE LAST MINUTE. DUE
TO SITUATIONS SUCH AS THE
ONGOING COVERED CONDUCT.
REPORTING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WILL HAVE A TO. POSITIVE IMPACT
FOR THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
OUR PART TIME FACULTY AND OUR
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
QUESTION WILL COME FROM LINE
FORTY ONE. LINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON LINE FORTY ONE. THE GAME LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON. HEARING
NO RESPONSE WE WILL CONTINUE
WITH THE LINE TWENTY EIGHT. BY
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALAN YOUR COSTA
AND I'M A PART TIME FRANKLY
FLYER WHO TEACHES NONCREDIT ESL
AT WEST VALLEY COLLEGE SAN JOSE
CITY COLLEGE AND SAN JOSE STATE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE COMPANY'S PROPOSAL
UP TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE BUT PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY. TOO
MANY UNIDENTIFIED PART TIME
FACULTY FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS
AND GO WITHOUT HEALTH CARE AND
IT HURTS NOT ONLY THEM BUT THEIR
ABILITY TO DO THE IMPORTANT WORK
EDUCATING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AND WORKERS. FOR OVER TWO YEARS
I'VE BEEN TEACHING CREDIT ESL AT
THREE TO FOUR DIFFERENT COLLEGES
JUST TO MAKE ENDS MEET. TEACHING
PART TIME IS MY FULL TIME CAREER
IN MY FIELD OF THE SL THEY DO
NOT HIRE FULL TIME STAFF. I AM
ONE OF MANY PART TIME FACULTY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO HAS
GONE WITHOUT HEALTHCARE DUE TO
MY PART TIME STATUS. I COULD
DEVOTE SO MUCH MORE ATTENTION TO
MY STUDENT ID NONCREDIT
EDUCATORS LIKE ME ARE INCLUDED.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
ON GOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE WILL GO TIMELINE. SEVENTEEN
LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME'S PHIL
WHO AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE UP TO SIX ONE
FIVE SEVEN ASSEMBLY EVERY
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS. I WAS
ALSO PREVIOUSLY A FULL TIME
ENGLISH PROFESSOR OUT TO GO TO
COLLEGE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO PRESERVE
THE GOVERNOR'S TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FUNDING FOR PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTHCARE OR PART TIME
COLLEAGUES DO THE SAME WORK WE
DO BE SERVICING STUDENTS WE DO.
AND THEY GET. LIKELY TO. OKAY
PROTECT THE PARTS COLLEAGUES BUT
THE TWO HUNDRED DAY ONGOING
FUNDING THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT QUESTION WILL COME
FROM THE LINE EIGHTEEN. LINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS AVAILABLE HERE AND I
AM A PART TIME SHE CANNOT SHE
CANNOT STUDY THE STRUCTURE AT
SENDING THE CITY COLLEGE I'M
HERE TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR PART
TIME TOO MANY COLLEGE FACULTY. I
STARTED TEACHING AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX BUT AFTER ONE
YEAR I QUIT BECAUSE I REALIZED I
DIDN'T HAVE ANY HEALTH BENEFITS.
INTO NINE AND BACK TO SAN DIEGO
AND NOW WORK AT THE TEN YOU
COMING BECAUSE DISTRICT WHERE
OUR UNION HAS FOUGHT TO MAKE
SURE. ADJUNCTS ARE ABLE TO GET
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS AFTER
TEACHING- SENT FOR TWO
CONSECUTIVE SEMESTERS. WITH TWO
HUNDRED MILLION MORE- ARE MORE
BACK UP HE WILL BE AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS THIS CAN HELP ENCOURAGE
FACULTY LIKE MYSELF. YOU TEACH
AND BE RETAINED IN BETWEEN
COLLEGE OUR SYSTEM WHAT WE CAN
BE A MOTIVATION AND INSPIRE
OTHER. STUDENTS THAT REFLECT.
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THEY GOT SOME. OUR
NEXT QUESTION WILL COME FROM THE
LINE EIGHTEEN AMPS OUTSIDE LINE
NINETEEN LINE NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LANA DEL WHAT AND I'M A
PART TIME ESL INSTRUCTOR EL
CAMINO SANTA MONICA COLLEGE'S I
RESPECTFULLY DEMAND THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
THE PART TIME COLLEGE FACULTY
WHERE WE FALLING SHORT OF IN
DOING A DISSERVICE TO OUR DAHLE
ADULT LEARNERS BY CREATING
UNSTABLE ONE MINUTES. OUT CHECK
. CLEAN AND THE BALL AND YOU THE
OF BURNERS BILL WHICH FURTHER
GREAT IT IN EQUITY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AT PROVIDE THE SAME
CALIBER AND- APART TIME COUNTY
EDUCATOR TO RECEIVE QUALITY.
HEALTH PART TIME FACULTY PEOPLE
HEALTH CARE THE BILL EIGHTY
PROVIDES FOR STUDENTS WHAT AGAIN
I RESPECTFULLY DEMAND USED THE
GUY PUBLIC BUT HUNDRED. AND
ONGOING FUNDING HEALTH CARE FOR
PART TIME COLLEGE BACK THANK YOU
IBM TIME. THANK YOU NEXT FIGURE
PLEASE THANK YOU. OUR RESPONSE
WILL COME FROM THE LINE FORTY
LINE FOURTEEN LINE IS A- HELLO
NAME IS LINDA NEED AN I THINK
THE IN THE PART TIME THAT COULD
THE SERVER COLLEGE SACRAMENTO.
TWO THOUSAND GREAT. BUT I LIKE
SO MANY PART TIMERS SMALL ACT
JOB THAT I OF MORE THAN ONE BOOK
JOB I URGE YOU TO THE OUR OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO HELP ALL PART
AND COLLEGE BACK HAVE ACT TO
AFFORDABLE QUALITY HOW. I'M MORE
OF THE LUCKY ONE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN I WOULD DIAGNOSED WITH
STAGE FOUR BREAST CANCER I WAS
ABLE TO GET A FULL YEAR OF
AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY
TREATMENT THROUGH THE HEALTHCARE
PLAN I WOULD HAVE ROLLED INTO MY
DISTRICT. I THROUGH MY CHEMO.
SURGERY AND RADIATION. BECAUSE I
LOVE MY JOB AND I LOVE MY- BUT
TOO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF THE
HAVE. COVERAGE PLEASE SUPPORT
THE FINAL IN THE BUDGET SO THAT
THE CARE I RECEIVED CAN BE THE
RULE RATHERTHAN THE EXCEPTION.
FOR THE THOUSANDS OF US WHO ARE
CLASSIFIED AT PARKHEAD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY THREE LINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LAST WEEK THE LA TIMES REPORTED
THAT THE UC SANTA BARBARA
CHANCELLOR RECEIVED A 28% PAY
INCREASE. AS AN ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR I'M CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCE A PAY DECREASE OF
MORE THAN 60% DUE TO LOW
ENROLLMENT. WHAT CONCERNS ME
MOST THAT I MAY ALSO LOSE MY
HEALTH INSURANCE A DILEMMA THAT
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
EDUCATORS ARE FACING. IT'S TIME
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MAKE A
SMALL COMMITMENT TO THE
DEDICATED TEACHERS WHO SUFFER
UNDER AN INEQUITABLE SYSTEM AND
AT THE VERY LEAST MAKE SURE WE
HAVE HEALTH CARE. MY NAME IS
RALPH DROP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT RESPONSE COMES FROM THE
LINE AT THIRTEEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LISA
STEINHARDT AND I'VE BEEN A PART
TIME BIOLOGY INSTRUCTOR FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS AT CA BRIO WEST
VALLEY IN HEART NOW UNITY
COLLEGES I TEACH CALIFORNIA'S
ESSENTIAL WORKERS INCLUDING PRE
NURSING STUDENTS AND PARAMEDIC
FIREFIGHTERS. I AM HERE TODAY TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY.
MAKING SURE PART TIME FACULTY
HAVE ACCESS TO QUALITY
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE WILL MEAN
THE WORLD TO ME AND MY
COLLEAGUES TO MAKE UP 70% OF THE
FACULTY IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND WE'LL MAKE SURE WE
ARE ABLE TO BE THERE FOR OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT RESPONSE COMES FROM THE
LINE FORTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SH GREETINGS ASSEMBLY FINANCE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE LAND I'M
SPEAKING TO YOU FROM AS THE
MEANWHILE MY DINNER SYDNEY AND
LAND I AM SHELVE THE LIVES OF
BRIEFLY FLYIN EARLY. EDUCATOR
I'M PART TIME AND I TEACH MORE
THAN FULL TIME FOR TWO DISTRICTS
FOURTEEN COLLEGES LIKE MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO VALLEY I AM
HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL FOR THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING. FOR HEALTH CARE
FROM PART CAN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY BECAUSE WE NEED
HEALTHCARE WITH YOUR SUPPORT IN
MAKING SURE PART TIME FACULTY
HAVE ACCESS TO CONSISTENT
AFFORDABLE AND QUALITY
HEALTHCARE WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL LEARNING EXPERIENCES
THAT SUPPORT SUCCESSFUL ACADEMIC
AND SOCIETAL OPPORTUNITIES OUR
STUDENTS ARE WORKFORCE. AND THE
WORLD THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO FORTY. AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME MONTH BABY. THE
PHARMACIST AS WELL HELLO MARK.
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED AND I'M GOING
FUNDING FOR CARE PART TIME HOURS
BACK. I SERVICE A COLLEGE
COUNSELOR AND MENTAL HEALTH
IMPORTANT. FINDATOPDOC TO MENTAL
HEALTH BENEFITS- I WOULD BE WELL
MY STUDENTS- MEET THEIR- UNTIL
AGAIN I- URGE YOU SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED. FOR TWO
HUNDRED NINETY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WERE GO TO LINE AND
YEAH YOUR LINE IS ALL. HELLO AS
ASSEMBLY GET MORE MAIN IS RUTH
WILSON. WITH LOW NAY THIRTY ONE-
I AM A PART TIME YES SIR YOUR IN
CAN COLLEGE DISTRICT. I'M HERE
TO URGE YOU SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED FOR TWO HUNDRED DOLLAR
AND GOING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR
PART TIME BECOME BACK. HERE MANY
PART TIME GO WITHOUT HEALTH CARE
AND IT NOT ONLY THEM THEIR TO
ONE WORK EDUCATE. CALIFORNIA AND
WORKERS THANK YOU MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THEY CAN EXPECT YOU WE-
LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING R. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD MY
NAME IS CHRIS COOPER I'M WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE IN
LOS ANGELES. MICHAEL TIME
OCCUPATION FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS THIS HAVE BEEN NOT JOHN
PART TIME. PROFESSOR OF
POLITICAL SCIENCE AT SEVERAL
COLLEGES. I TYPICALLY TEACH TO
THE CREATE A RICH STUDENTS
EITHER TRANSFER EACH TWO TO
THREE HUNDRED PLANTS. EACH YEAR
. MAINTAIN MY IS A SENSE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS WORK. PLEASE
MAKE ADEQUATE ON THE BALLOT IN
SCOTT CITY CORPORATE HEADED JUST
SIR ADEQUATE WE- AND REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE THIS ESSENTIAL. AND
BASIC. PRIOR TO YOU TO SUPPORT
GOVERNOR'S. I'M GOING TO HAVE
MILLION FOR PART TIME FACULTY
HELPING. NEEDS HELP WITH Q. CALL
. AGAIN TAKE. FOR SURE. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO ONLINE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON NAME IS ALREADY AT THE
MANY OF I'M A JIMMY MEMBER IN
OUT AND AMERICA GROUP RIVER
COLLEGE AND THE BACK THE
BEGINNING THEM THEIR- YOU TO I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT GOVERNOR
PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED MILLI ON
FUNDING PART TIME FACULTY. AT
ARE THE BACKBONE OF BECAUSE AND
STUDENTS FACT DEPENDS ON THEM
PART TIME FACULTY WORKERS ARE AT
FULL TIME FACULTY SUPPORT
QUALITY EDUCATION TO OUR- IT IS
AN ECHO ISSUE THEY ARE NOT
PROVIDE WITH A- HIGH QUALITY
OKAY. YEAH DISTRICT PARK FACULTY
NUMBER NO THAT WOULD A LITTLE
FOR IT EACH YEAR AND THE- STARTS
BECAUSE THE THERE ARE INSURANCE
FROM THAT THIS DEPEND ON DENTAL
. IN MY ROLE HEAR HOW STORIES
EVERYTHING BUT FROM FROM PART
TIME. ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE DO TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN AND
FAT IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE THE OUTDOOR
ELIGIBLE FOR HOW HE WITHOUT ME
THEY DON'T KNOW THEY COULD PAY
FOR AND FOOD WELL A BIG CHUNK OF
THEIR P. GO TO HELPING. YEAH
EXACTLY WORK REALLY HARD PLEASE
SUPPORT THAT PROPOSED SO YET AND.
DROP PROVIDING EDUCATION ONLINE
AND ON GROUND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS LAURA SWEENEY AND I
TEACH A THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT FOR EIGHT YEARS I'M
HERE TO URGE THE COURT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF ON GOING
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY HEALTHCARE PART TIME
FACULTY ARE HUMAN BEINGS TO GET
SICK AND MANY PART TIME FACULTY
HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR DISTRICTS
FOR YEARS AND DECADES. SO
LEGALLY NOT THOSE TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES AND MANY TEACHERS AND
SURROUNDING. AND WE SHOULD BE
HIRED FULL TIME AT THAT WHICH IS
ANOTHER IMPORTANT ISSUE
ADDITIONALLY PART TIME FACULTY
MAKES SO LITTLE BUT WE CAN'T
AFFORD PLANS TO COVER CALIFORNIA
AND END UP PAYING MONTHLY
PREMIUMS FOR INSURANCE WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO USE BECAUSE COPAYS ARE
SO HIGH IN COVERAGE VERY LITTLE.
WE DESERVE TO BE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND CARE THANKS WE ARE
HUMAN BEINGS TO WORK. HARD TO
SERVE OUR STUDENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO ONLINE TO
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IT'S AN HONOR TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS VICTOR
LEE ANDERSON THE THIRD AND I'M A
PART TIME FOURTEEN YEAR
COSMETOLOGY AND LEAD BARBER
CONVERSION INSTRUCTOR AT SAN
DIEGO CITY COLLEGE. I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY.
I AM ONE OF THE MANY PART TIME
FACULTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO GONE WITHOUT
HEALTHCARE. AND HAD TO GO WITH
WITHOUT MY ESSENTIAL
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION WHILE
TEACHING MY CLASSES IN PERSON
AND ONLINE. BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
AFFORD THEM WITHOUT INSURANCE.
IT HAS BEEN A PRIVATE TRAGEDY
AND TRIAL TO SAY THE LEAST AND I
KNOW. THERE ARE MORE TEACHERS
OUT THERE WHO ARE SUFFERING IN
SILENCE NOBLY. WITH WOUNDED
PRIDE LIKE ME WONDERING WHAT IS
GOING TO TAKE TO SEE THIS ISSUE
RESOLVED. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. SO THAT WE CAN BE OUR
BEST HEALTHY CELLS FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR STUDENTS. ALWAYS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO ONLINE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
JEFF JOHNSON AND I AM A TWENTY
YEAR NON TEMPORARY AN ESSENTIAL
PART TIME INSTRUCTOR AT SAN
DIEGO MESA IN SOUTHWESTERN
COLLEGES AND I'M CALLING TO THE
IN SUPPORT OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING PART TIME
HEALTHCARE. WHILE MY FAMILY AND
I KNOW HER HEALTHCARE THROUGH
WORK IT WAS NOT ALWAYS SO. I WAS
WORKING AT FOUR SCHOOLS IN MY
FAMILY WAS LIVING ON RICK MELTED
CHEESE WHEN WE GOT INSURANCE A
YEAR LATER MY WIFE WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH TYPE TWO DIABETES. WITHOUT
THE INSURANCE WE COULD HAVE
AFFORDED INSULIN AND I'M NOT
SURE MY WIFE WILL BE HERE. WHAT
VALUE DOES ONE PLACE AND GIVEN A
LIFE. PART TIME SHOULD BE ABLE
TO WORRY ABOUT MORE THAN THEIR
STUDENT SUCCESS RATHER THAN
THEIR LIVES WITH THE LIVES OF
THEIR FAMILIES I CANNOT AFFORD
TO SUFFER LONGER IN THE NAME OF
RESEARCH THAT IS WHY THE WHOLE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE PART TIME HEALTHCARE. IS A
MUST. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
LINE SEVENTY ONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU I'M
SHARING WEST AND I'M A PART TIME
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND
COMPUTER INFORMATION SYSTEMS
INSTRUCTOR AT SIERRA AND
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE YET. I'M
ALSO AN EARLY RETIREE FROM HIGH
TECH INDUSTRY THE LAST TWENTY
TWO YEARS UNTIL A PACKARD AND
HEWLETT PACKARD ENTERPRISE I'VE
BEEN AN INDUSTRY ADVISORY HERE
COLLEGE. AND I'M PASSIONATE
ABOUT EDUCATION AND BRINGING
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE TO OUR
STUDENTS. I'M ON THIS CALL LIKE
SO MANY OTHERS YOU'VE HEARD TO
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR ON GOING FUNDING
FOR PART TIME FACULTY AND
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. BOB MIKE. IS
I TEACH COURSES AT TWO DIFFERENT
COLLEGES AND DON'T QUALIFY FOR
HEALTH CARE. TO EITHER ONE OF
THEM. AS AN EARLY- ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WOULDN'T EARLY
STAGE CAREER- INSTRUCTOR. IS
TEACHING NINE COURSES AT FOUR
INSTITUTIONS. TO MAKE THE
CURRENT ME- AND- I HAVE NO
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. SO I'M
STUNNED BY THE LACK OF BENEFITS
FOR PART TIMERS WERE SO HEAVILY
RELIED ON AND YOU TALK ABOUT
BUILDING A THREE WAY FIRE
PROBLEM BY BRINGING FULL TIMERS
ON AND THAT IS PART OF THE
ISSUE. BUT YOU MAY ONLY HAVE-
I'M NOT STUDENTS FOR CERTAIN
TOPICS AT- ONE COLLEGE AND IN
ORDER TO GET A FULL LOAD YOU MAY
STILL NEED TO TEACH A COUPLE
DIFFERENT COLLEGES TO PLEASE
KEEP THAT IN MIND WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM- IN. STARBUCKS PROVIDE
BETTER PART TIME BENEFITS. AND
PART TIMERS RECEIVE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND
PRIVATE INSURANCE CAN BE FIFTEEN
GRAND BEFORE THE INSURANCE
COMPANY COVERS ADANI. SO ADDICT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WAGE THAT'S
NOT AFFORDABLE EITHER SO- PLEASE
BE AWARE THE- THAT THIS TRULY
IS- HEALTHCARE BENEFITS GAP WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE OUR STUDENTS
HAVE TO CARRY THIS BURDEN AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL GO
PROVIDING SIXTY ONE. IN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
SOPHIA GONZALEZ FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
YOU'LL BE AT THAT LOCATION I AM
HERE TO EARN YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE EXTENDED OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES BY
CREDITING YOUR PS REQUEST FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
FUNDING. FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR TARGETED
ENROLLMENT RECRUITMENT TEN
MILLION ONGOING FOR THE CARE
PROGRAM AND TAKE MILLION FOR OUR
FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAM NEXT UP.
THE OPIATES IS A STRONG AND
PROUD TRADITION OF RECRUITING
STUDENTS FOR MOST PART OF OLD
AND HOURS COMMUNITY WORK TALK
ABOUT- ROMAN AND THE LACK
STUDENTS PARTISAN. IN A BEING ON
CAN. EUROPEAN BECAUSE OVER AND
UP. IN MAKING THAT WE GO AND
RECRUIT INTO OUR COMMUNITY THEM
BRING ARE STUDENTS. OUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
CROP. THANK YOU WE WILL GO
ONLINE SEVENTY THREE AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS THE LEAST BOB AND I'M A
PART TIME INSTRUCTOR AT THE
COLLEGE OF ALAMEDA IN A PROGRAM
FOR ADULTS WITH BOXES. I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTHCARE
FOR PART AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARK CITY I LOVE MY JOB BUT I
CONSIDERED LEAVING MANY TRYING
BECAUSE I CANNOT GET HEALTH
INSURANCE THROUGH MY- EMPLOYER.
MY FAULT AND THE PERSON LIVING
WITH A DISABILITY SO I TRULY
NEED HEALTH INSURANCE NOT
GETTING INSURANCE THROUGH MY
WORK AND PACKED MY HEALTH AND
NOT IMPACT MY ABILITY TO BE THE
TEACHER REYES STUDENTS TRULY
DOES HER. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY ONE AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. THANK YOU MY NAME IS REBECCA.
EXACTLY THE COORDINATOR FROM
FULL COMBAT COLLEGES UPS CARE
AND NEXT. PLEASE SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT OF EXTENDED OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES YOUR PS
THIS BUDGET CYCLE BY GRANTING
YOUR PS IS REQUEST FOR TEN
MILLION ON GOING FUNDING TO
ETHIOPIA. FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR TARGETED
ENROLLMENT RECRUITMENT TEN
MILLION ONGOING FOR OUR CARE
PROGRAM IN TEN MILLION FOR
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAM NEXT
UP. HE'LL PS IS THE ORIGINAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EQUITY PROGRAM
AND PROBABLY DELIVERS
COMPREHENSIVE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES TO FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS
THE INCREASE IN FUNDING TO
ETHIOPIA CARE AND NEXT STEP
ALLOWS YOU TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING OUR CLLEGES MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ONGOING SUPPORT IN
PROVIDING. THE SAFETY HERE AT.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY FOUR AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON LEGISLATORS
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY RODENBERG
PART TIME FACULTY MEMBER T THE
MIDDLE COLLEGE PROGRAM AT
SKYLINE COLLEGE AND ST PER NOW.
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY. IN MY DISTRICT
70% OF OUR CLASSES ARE TAUGHT BY
PART TIME INSTRUCTORS.
ACCORDINGLY 70% OF THE STUDENTS
THAT WE SERVE HAVE INSTRUCTORS
WHO IS VERY HEALTH AND WELL
BEING IS CONTINGENT UPON THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL. SEVEN
YEARS I HAVE PAID OUT OF POCKET
FOR WHAT THE HEALTH INSURANCE
INDUSTRY CALLED THE CATASTROPHIC
PLAN. I NEVER WENT TO THE DOCTOR
FOR FEAR OF HIGH COPAYS AND
DEDUCTIBLES. HOW MANY
PREVENTABLE DISEASES ARE GOING
UNTREATED AMONGST OUR FACULTY
AND HOW MANY STUDENTS ACROSS OUR
STATE ARE LOSING QUALITY
INSTRUCTION BECAUSE OF THIS.
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL TO FUND
HEALTHCARE FOR PART TIMERS NOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL GO
TO LINE SEVENTY FIVE AND
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MY NAME IS NAJAF HAVE THE
CONTENT I'M AN ADJUNCT
PHILOSOPHY AND HUMANA PROFESSOR
AT SOUTHWEST. FLORIDA JUSTICE
PROGRAM AND AS YOUNG AS FIFTY
MIRAMAR COLLEGE AND I'M A MEMBER
OF THE SELECTING COMMITTEE OF
THE NFL FACT ABOUT. I AM A
MEMBER OF THE EIGHTY S. GIL NINE
SIXTY ONE I LOVE MY JOB I'VE
BEEN AN ADJUNCT FOR MORE THAN
NINETEEN YEARS HEALTHCARE FOR-
JOHN IS A- AND THEN. ISSUE SINCE
YOU BELIEVE IN THE VALUE OF
EDUCATION THEN YOU BELIEVE THAT
WE DESERVE TO BE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND CARE I JUGGLE MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE BY TRAVELING
AMONG FOUR CAMPUSES. I AM ONE OF
FORTY TWO THOUSAND PLUS ADJUNCT
FACULTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE GUNS AT
TIMES WITHOUT HEALTHCARE IT'S
NOT ALL THE TIME. WE DO WE NEED
TO GET SICK WHILE THE FORTY ONE
THOUSAND FULL TIME I HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN RESPECT BOAT
INSURANCE I HAVE TO RELY. ON ON
GOING OUT TO HUNDRED FIFTY IF I
. PAID IN CASE AND P. FOR OUT OF
POCKET I URGE YOU TO. THE KNOWS
APPROACH. FOR TWO. HUNT OF
MILLIONS DOLLAR FOR FUN HELP.
SPECIALLY BEEN HAD A GOOD TOUCH
WITH VIDEO BECAUSE CALL. I
WANTED SERVICE STUDENTS AND
THANK I CAN STAND THEM IF I AM I
SAID THAT IT IN. THE FORMER AGO
I HAD GO TO BE SEEN BY A
PHYSICIAN IT'S COST ME HOW
TWENTY FIFTY DOCTOR AND NOW THAT
FIFTY TO THE FOR AND YOU. I OLD
- USED TO SET TEN THE BY FOR
EASTERN MAKES. TO BE TOLD AT
THAT COLLEGE. AS CAL MIDDLE EAST
AND THAT IS THAT GROWN COST
CUTTING. THAT DOES THE TO BE.
AND I WHAT I CAN AND COLLEGE
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR LISTENING
TO OUR. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
QUESTION WILL COME FROM. SEVENTY
AND LINE IS ALL. I'M FUNNY IF
NOT TODAY THEN I'M A PART TIME
INSTRUCTOR AND DIEGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT I TEACH ENGLISH
AS A SECOND LANGUAGE TO ADULT
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES. I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY. AS
YOU KNOW COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
DRASTICALLY REDUCED THE NUMBER
OF FULL TIME POSITIONS AND MOST
FACULTY ARE PART TIME. ALL FINE
FOR HEALTHCARE INSURANCE CAN
TAKE YEARS FOR PART TIMERS AND
SOME OF US NEVER ACHIEVE IT.
DISTRESS AND UNCERTAINTY OF NOT
HAVING THESE BENEFITS AFFECT OUR
WELL BEING AND OUR ABILITY TO
SERVE OUR STUDENTS. I AM STILL
WAITING TO QUALIFY FOR HEALTH
CARE BENEFITS AFTER MORE THAN A
YEAR WORKING FOR A NEW DISTRICT
. WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE THE PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
RESPONSIBLE COME FROM LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT. AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ENROLLMENT
CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES FACING OUR
COLLEGES IN ADDITION THE
EXPLANATION CONSIDER TODAY WELL
INTENTIONED LEGISLATION AT EIGHT
BUDGET CHANGES OVER THE PAST
DECADE HAVE PENALIZED FOR CAN
FIT AND- WE ENCOURAGE MEETING
STUDENTS WHERE THEY'RE AT I
FUNDING PART IN FOR THE SAME
RATE A FULL TIME STUDENT.
INCREASING THE FUNDING AND
ELIMINATING PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING WE RECOGNIZE THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS AMEND THE
FUNDING FORMULA PROVISIONS BUT
WE ENCOURAGE ADDING A COUPLE OF
THE FUNDING FROM PROPOSAL
INCREASING THE COLOR KEEP UP
WITH INFLATION. WE ALSO AFTER
FURTHER INVESTMENT SERVICES
INCLUDE FIFTEEN DOLLARS FOR THE
MEET THE PROGRAMS AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS OR FIVE YEARS
THE CREATION OF A NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENT RECORDS EXCEPT
PROGRAM AT TWENTY COLLEGE. WERE
POLICE OF THE PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR PARTS
FACULTY HEALTHCARE AND FINALLY
WE SUPPORT ELIMINATING CALGARY
COLLEGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL GO TO LINES. NINE AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JEWISH OR WHERE I'M A PER TIME
CAN BE STUDIES AND AT RIDEAU
COLLEGE AND SHE BECAUSE- I'M
HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT YOU. PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
BETWEEN MY FEW COLLEGES I'VE
WORKED OVER A FULL TIME LOAD AT
THE SINGLE MOM. AND A RESTAURANT
SERVER I QUALIFIED THE MEDIC NOW
NOW THAT I'M A COLLEGE
INSTRUCTOR I'M LOSING MY
INSURANCE. COLLEGES AND THERE'S
WILL PEBBLE. APARTMENTS WITHOUT
ACT REPORTER HEALTH CARE
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH CARE OUR
ABILITY TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS
THE FULL POTENTIAL OFTEN
COMPROMISE. SO I COULD YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL A FEW HUNDRED MILLION
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY THANK YOU. I'M
EXCITED NUMBER. SEVENTY NINE.
NINE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT A LINE EIGHTY SIX
POINT EIGHTY SIX BILLION US OPEN. EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA- FLOREA
AND I AM A PART TIME BIOLOGY
INSTRUCTOR AT FULL FROM THE
COLLEGE I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
I'M NOT GOING FUNDING FOR
HEALTHCARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY. LAST
AUGUST I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
STAGE TWO BREAST CANCER I
BECAUSE I HAD HEALTH INSURANCE
WHO ARE THE DISTRICT THAT I WORK
FOR MY CANCER WAS DETECTED EARLY
ENOUGH THAT I CAN SURVIVE IT.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN I GOT SICK I
MIGHT CLASS LOW DROPPED OUT
WHICH COST MY MONTHLY PREMIUM TO
QUADRUPLE- AND LAST MONTH- EACH
CANDIDATE MY CHECK A LITTLE BIT
OVER TO BEHIND DOLLARS. THE
DEDUCTION THAT THEY DID FOR SURE
- SO I AM ONE OF THE- OF TIMERS
BECAUSE HAVE THAT TO AND I'M
ABLE TO MY- TREAT MY ILLNESS I
CAN BACK TO I DO BUT- WE IS
INSPIRING MY STUDENTS. AND FOUND
THEM TO WONDER OF BIOLOGY. MY.
ON MY- WORKERS. MANY OF MY
COWORKERS AND FOR I NOT OF. AS I
AM. PART TIMERS ARE A THIS. PART
OF SCHEDULE SEX. WHICH EACH
NIGHT. AND THAT FULL TIME ARE
TO. WE OF BEING THING FOR PART
OF. THE BASIC. PROGRAM THE
COMMITTEE CALL. I RICHARD TODAY
TO SUPPORT THE BUDGET FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. I'M GOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR
PARKS COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
THANK YOU. BY NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MY NINETY. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOHN HOPKINS A IF HE LOCAL
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE AND I
ANSWERED WITH THE PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBER AT INDIGO MAKE
THE COLLEGE AS WELL AS OTHERS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS LIKE
SOUTHWESTERN COLORS IN SAN DIEGO
STATE FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS I'M
SPEAKING TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ONGOING
FIND THE HEALTHCARE PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACK. ON TOP
WITH MEAGER AND OPPRESSIVE WAGES
MOST PART TIME FACULTY LACK THE
PEACE OF MIND THAT HAD BEEN
HEALTHCARE GETS INSPITE OF OUR
COMMITMENT TO STUDENTS THE WORRY
ABOUT PAY FOR AN EXPENSIVE
TREATMENT IMPACT ON THE
ATTENTION WE CAN GET. AFTER ALL
THE WORK YOU DITION. OUR
STUDENTS COULD. WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR. PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR TO FOR ON
FELT CARE BEEN. FOR PART TIME.
EIGHTY BY NINETY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN LINE NINETY TWO. HI THIS IS
DEBBIE RUSHER WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YEARS I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AN
AUGMENTATION TO EXPAND THE NEXT
STEP PROGRAM FOR FOSTER YOUTH
SYSTEM WIDE. SYSTEM WIDE
IMPLEMENTATION RICHARD REQUIRE
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
RATHER THAN THE TEN MILLION
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WHICH WOULD BE HALF OF
THE COLLEGES WITHOUT THE SUPPORT
THIS PROGRAM HAS DEMONSTRATED
SUCCESS AND ALSO STATE ACROSS
STATE SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE COLLEGE
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. LINE
NINETY THREE LINE IS OPEN LINE
NINETY THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS
IN A MEDICARE AND I'VE BEEN A
PART TIME DANCE INSTRUCTOR AT
ORANGE COAST COLLEGE FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS I'M HERE TODAY
TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. I RECENTLY HAD A HEALTH
CARE AND BECAUSE THAT MIGHT
BENEFIT WAS ABLE TO IMMEDIATELY
SEE AN ONCOLOGIST RESOLVE THE
ISSUES AND THEN RETURN MY ENERGY
AND ATTENTION TO MY STUDENTS.
HOWEVER I FEAR FOR MY COLLEAGUES
WHO DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO SUCH
CARE IN THE EVENT OF A HEALTH
CRISIS THEIR ABILITY TO GIVE ALL
ENERGY TO THEIR CLASSROOM IS
GRAVELY COMPROMISED AND OUR
STUDENTS EDUCATION SUFFERS IN
TURN. IT TIME WE NEED TO SUPPORT
WHO ARE SHAPING THE FUTURE OF
THE NEXT GENERATION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LINE EIGHT CAROLINE IS
OPEN NOT EIGHT. HI THIS IS
DANIELLE ONE GROW WITH CHILDREN
NOW CALLING FIRST IN SUPPORT OF
A BUDGET AUGMENTATION OF THIRTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
THE NEXT UP PROGRAM FOR FOSTER
YOUTH SYSTEM WIDE IN ADDITION WE
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING ITEMS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE STUDENT SUCCESS COMPLETION
GRANT PROGRAM. TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STUDENT EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FINANCIAL AID
ADMINISTRATION AND LASTLY
REQUESTED FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL
STAFF POSITIONS IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU.
I NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NINETY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS TWO
BLOCKS ON I AM PART TIME FACULTY
AND I TEACH MATH THAT GUIDELINE
COLLEGE IN COLLEGE ABOUT ONE
METER. I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE FOR PART TIME FACULTY
COLLEGE FACULTY- IT WOULD MEAN
THE WORLD TO ME TO SEE ALL PART
TIME FACULTY HAVE ACCESS. TO
HEALTH CARE SO WE ARE ABLE TO BE
THERE FOR OUR STUDENTS. THANK
YOU. BY NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NINETY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M NOT BUT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AND COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF VARIOUS ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY INCLUDING THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION INCREASE FOR THE
STUDENTS THAT COMPLETION GRANT
PROGRAMS THE TWENTY MILLION FOR
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID FOR
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY STUDENTS. THE
COLA INCREASES FOR THE VARIOUS
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THAT
CYBERSECURITY INVESTMENT FOR
COLLEGES AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
URGE AN INCREASE INVESTMENT OF
TWENTY MILLION RESIDENTS RATHER
THAN THE TEN MILLION ARE TO
EXPAND THE NEXT PROGRAM THANK
YOU. BY NINETY SEVEN LINE IS
OPEN NINE NINE SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
CRUISES AND I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH FROM STUDENT CENTER
COLLEGE ACCORDING TO THE PORT OF
THE THIRTY TWO MILLION TO EXPAND
THE NEXT PROGRAM FOR FOSTER
YOUTH. THIS BUDGET AUGMENTATION
WOULD HELP CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH SUCH AS MYSELF
BECOME DEPENDENT SESSION AT. THE
TRULY BELIEVE THAT EDUCATE IS
OUR OPTION TO EFFECTIVELY SHIFT
SHOULD OF OUR LIVES THANK THANK
YOU. MY NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NINETY NINE. HELLO MY NAME
IS JORDAN THE LET'S MANAGER FOR
K. YOU CAN R. C. Y. THE STATE
WHITE MEMBERS ORGAN. COMPRISED
KERN FORMER FOX USED I'M CALLING
IT THE OF THE DOCUMENT THIRTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
THE NEXT THE PROGRAM FOR
QUASHING. ARE OR THAT CRACKLES
POINTS SENATE EIGHTY FIVE AT
DOUBLE ROOM THE TO Q. COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN PLYMOUTH TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE WEEK FOR AND
FUNDS- ARE ACCEPTABLE STATE.
EDUCATION HAS BEEN A PILLAR FROM
US FOR ME CURRENT AND FORMER YOU
WHO WERE UNABLE TO REACH THAT
THE- FOR FAMILY OR THE CHILD
WELFARE. THANK YOU. THANK NINE
NINETY ONE LINE OF THE NINE ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHIU REGARDING
COMMITTEE MEMBER MANY FROM
BEHALF EDUCATION TRUST WHAT. WE
ARE RESEARCH YOUR- WORKING TO NO
. THE JUSTICES AND CALIFORNIA'S
SYSTEM EARLY EDUCATION THROUGH
COLLEGE LIKE THIS MY SUPPORT ON
A FEW PROPOSED FIRST WITH LIKE
TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI IRWIN C. FORM DOLLAR
EQUITABLE PLACE ME AND- SUPPORT
WALKER. THIS IS WHY TIME FUNDING
THE SPORT FACT CAL ADMIN
IMPLEMENT STRATEGY THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO IN THEIR ACT WILL PLACE
THE COMPLETE IMPROVEMENT PLANS.
AS THE TRAIN FOR TWENTY OF AB OH
FIVE BY FALL TWENTY TWO TWO.
STATION NUMBER TWO- WE RECOMMEND
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
STATUTORY CHANGE TO THE STUDENTS
IN A FUNDING FORMULA THE NEW
DATA METRICS STILL BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A MORE EQUITABLE WAY TO
DISTRIBUTE FUNDS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM BY FOCUSING ON
THE ACCESS AND SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED. AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS AND UNDER OTHER
UNDERSHIRTS TWO GROUPS AND LAST
ISSUE NUMBER SIX TENTHS OFFICE
STOPPING WE RECOMMEND
LEGISLATURE APPROVES NEW
POSITIONS THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE CONNECTED. AND LOST SUCH
AS A B. SEVEN OH FIVE PLANTATION
BASIC NEEDS AND DOING ALL THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINE
OPEN. EIGHT HI MY NAME IS THEN
THEM I THE FORMER FOX NEWS
ATTENDING SECOND STATE I. FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACTED IS RIVER
. I THANK ABOUT ARGUING THIRTY
TWO MILLION TWO EXPAND EXCEPT
THEN FOR BOTH YOU AND OF PROGRAM
OF MOTIVATES ME TO AND COULD MY-
FOR ONE I WOULD NOT BE TO. BE
WHERE I TODAY. WITHOUT PROVIDED
TO IN THE ABLE TO GET FOOD
SCHOOL SUPPLY MUCH TO PROVIDE
FROM. I'M ALL HELPS WITH ANY. IN
MOST SUPPORT PROVIDE PROVIDE ME
WITH THE OF SAN WHERE WHEN I NOT
ONE. THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN HELLO MY IS
CHRISTINA. AND I AM WITH
WONDERING FOR YOU AND I AM ALSO
A STUDENT AT THE NATIONAL CALL
IN A FROM A POSH GOT SHOULD I
HERE TO WHAT THE BUDGET
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS EXPAND THE NEXT AROUND.
IT WORKS I DON'T THE NEXT
PROGRAM IS VERY IN. TO KEEP
SEVENTY ALL COLLEGES I MYSELF IS
THAT AM IN THE NAY STEP PROGRAM
HELPS ME TRY. WHERE EDUCATE AND
GETTING THINGS THAT I WILL
NEEDED TO HOW AND ALL THAT- BUT
SACRAMENTO THING YOU AND I ASKED
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION TO THE BASIC
ALLOCATION AT THE TECH BASIC-
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THAT TODAY.
SECOND WHILE AKKA APPRECIATE
GOVERNOR NEW FUNDS PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND THE EXISTING HOLD
HARMLESS WE ASK THAT THAT HOLD
HARMLESS BE REVENGE THIS YEAR'S
AT TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
OUR TOTAL COMPUTATIONAL REVENUE
INCREASED BY COLA- INSTEAD OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND
THEN FINALLY. ALL DISTRICTS ARE
EXPERIENCING INCREASING COSTS
FOR THE CONTINUING OPERATION OF
THE COLLEGES INCLUDING HEALTH
SERVICE IMPROPER EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTION RIGHT. TO THE
EXTENT MORE NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT RESOURCES CAN BE
PROVIDED TO ALLEVIATE THOSE
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION RATE
INCREASES WE WOULD SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL REVENUE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MY NAME THREE YEAR LINE OF
THE EIGHTY THREE. I AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS KIANA RICHIE
AND I AM THE GUARDIAN SCHOLARS
PROGRAM COORDINATOR AT THE BRIO
COLLEGE IN APPS FONG. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A BUDGET AUGMENTATION OF
THIRTY TWO MILLION TO EXPAND THE
NEXT STEP PROGRAM FOR FOSTER
YOUTH STATEWIDE THESE BONDS ARE
CRITICAL THE WHOLE BRIDGE THE
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY GAPS FOR
FOSTER YOUTH THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- AND SPECIFICALLY MY
PROGRAM THAT RELIES SOLELY ON
DONOR FUNDS TO OPERATE TO
SUPPORT- DISPARAGES. AND
VULNERABLE POPULATION. SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND LINE ONE
OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN MIND
MODEL SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
WILLIE DUNCAN ON THAT
SUPERINTENDENT PRESIDENT OF
SIERRA COLLEGE IN A CHAIR AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IO TASK FORCE
ON THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA. I'M CALLING TO URGE
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S HOLD
HARMLESS PROPOSAL AND ALSO SHIFT
THE HOLD HARMLESS YEAR. TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WHICH WOULD REQUIRE NO NEW
FUNDING OVER THE CURRENT YEAR
EXCEPT COLA. THE TWO PROPOSALS
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE TIME TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO THE STUDENT
THAT WE LOCK DURING THE PANDEMIC
WITHOUT TAKING SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET CUTS WHICH WOULD
NECESSITATE REDUCTION IN
SERVICES TO STUDENTS AS WELL AS
REDUCTIONS IN OUR FACULTY AND
STAFF. IN ADDITION I WOULD LIKE
TO SUPPORT THE OTHER TWO ITEMS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE YOUR LETTER
THAT WAS SUBMITTED THOSE ARE
TWO. THE THREE MILLION DOLLARS
BASIC. IN AND ALSO TOOK
ADDITIONAL- NOT NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING TO CALL. TO ADDRESS
RIGHT PENSION THANK YOU. AND I
FIND REPLY FROM WIND OLD. NINE
ONE OF AIRLINES OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHAEL STEWART. I AM A
FULL TIME INSTRUCTOR AND
ACADEMIC SENATE PRESIDENT CALVET
COLLEGE CALDERON HURT
CALIFORNIA'S NEWEST ONLINE
COLLEGE- I FULLY SUPPORT THE
FUNDING OF CALIBRATE COLLEGE
CALIBRATE COLLEGES NOT AN
EXPERIMENT. ONE AND A BETA OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MODEL DESIGNED TO
REACH THOSE FULL BEEN OVERLOOKED
AND FORGOTTEN. AND JUST LIKE
WITH ANY TYPE OF NEW INSTRUCTION
OR DESIGNED IT TAKES TIME TO
BUILD THE MODEL AND PERFECT THE
MODEL. WE HAVE HAD THOUSAND
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN AB. EIGHTY
BUT WE DONE THE- WHAT THE
OPPOSITION COMING AT US ALL THE
TIME. IF WE ARE GIVEN A CHANCE
TO WORK ON OFFENSE WAS BOUGHT
TWENTY DEFENSE WE COULD DO
SOMETHING THAT IS GREAT FOR A
BIG. FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE LOOKING TO
CHANGE GENERATIONAL WEALTH BUT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN FORGOTTEN
PLEASE DON'T LOOK AT THEM AT THE
BUDGET ITEM WIDE UNDER
SPREADSHEET. I SUPPORT CALBERT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU IT'S A LOT- SPEAKER WITH THE
WE WILL.
WATERFALL.